welcome to Simply loans YouTube channel
today we will discuss the data analyst F
course your gateway to the dynamic world
of datadriven insights in this
comprehensive program we will begin on
an accelerating Journey Into the Heart
of data analysis equipping you with the
essential skills and tools to decode the
stories hidden within vast data sets as
organiz ganizations increasingly rely on
data to drive decision making your
ability to extract analyze and visualize
information will be more powerful asset
from mastering statistical techniques to
harnessing the potential of Cutting Edge
analytics software this course is your
key to unraveling the secrets of data
and unlocking opportunities across
Industries get ready to dive into the
realm of data analysis and chart a
course for your data driven future but
before we begin if these are the type of
videos you'd like to watch then hit that
subscribe button and the bell icon to
get notified whenever we host if you're
a professional with minimum one year of
experience and an aspiring data analyst
looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities in collaboration with
leading experts to enhance your
credibility then search no more simply
lar postgraduate program and data
analytics offered by per University in
collaboration with IBM is just what you
need for more details head straight to
our homepage or simply click on the link
in the description box below now without
further delay over to our training just
about everything is data these days from
market research and sales figures to
expenses and Logistics where every click
transaction and interaction generates a
digital footprint now it can be
difficult and timec consuming to sort
through it all and know what's important
and what isn't and what it all means and
in today's data driven World
organizations are realizing the immense
value that lies within the data data
analytics has emerged as a key to
unlocking the value by transforming raw
data into meaningful insights now the
demand for data analytics has
skyrocketed as businesses across
Industries recognize the potential to
drive informed decision making optimize
operations and gain a Competitive Edge
did you know that according to grandv
research the global data analytics
Market size is expected to reach $13
billion by 2027 with a compound annual
growth rate of 10.9% from 2020 to 2027
data analytics involves the process of
Gathering processing and analyzing
extensive data sets to extract valuable
insights and knowledge in the modern
data Centric landscape data analytics
play a vital role in enabling businesses
to maintain their Competitive Edge and
make well-informed decisions now given
the increasing Reliance on data driven
decision making data analytics presents
a plethora of job opportunities across
various Industries roles such as data
analyst business analyst data scientist
data visualization specialist among many
others are in high demand now as the
field of data data analytics continue to
evolve new job titles and
responsibilities are expected to emerge
to meet the industry's growing needs in
order to maintain this Competitive Edge
companies are actively recruiting
skilled data analyst who possess the
ability to extract invaluable insights
from vast volumes of data now these
proficient analysts play a vital role in
uncovering market trends comprehending
customer preferences optimizing
operational efficiencies and formulating
strategic decisions that Foster
substantial business growth and the
average annual salary for a data analyst
in the United States stands at a
approximately $72,000 per year in India
the average annual salary for a data
analyst is around 6 lakhs perom now
these figures indicate the financial
rewards associated with data analytic
roles and reflect the value placed on
individuals with the requisite skills
and expertise in this field so are you
ready to unlock this Secrets hidden
within vast amounts of data and gain a
Competitive Edge in today's cutro
business World well simply learn data
analyst course delivered in
collaboration with IID kpur will provide
you with extensive expertise in this
booming field of data analytics this
data analytics course at I khur is
designed to provide a deep understanding
of the principles techniques and
applications of data analytics to
develop a holistic skill set to
effectively analyze interpret and
extract actionable insights from data
the course follows a structured learning
path that covers various aspects of data
analytics including business analytics
using Excel SQL programming foundations
using python data analytics with r tab
training and capson projects well the
course begins with a focus on business
analytics using Excel which serves as a
foundation for understanding data
analysis and visualization techniques
you will learn to use Excel to
manipulate and analyze data create
meaningful visualizations and derive
insights for business decision making
this module emphasizes the Practical
applications of excel in real world
scenarios the next module introduces
Learners to SQL a powerful language used
for managing and manipulating relational
databases you will learn to write SQL
queries to extract and transform data
perform aggregations and join tables
this module enhances students ability to
hand a large data sets efficiently and
retrieve valuable information from
databases the course then moves on to
programming Foundation using python now
a widely used language for data analysis
and machine learning Learners will learn
the basics of Python Programming
including data structures control flow
functions and much more they'll also
gain hands-on experience in using
popular libraries like numi pandas
matplot lip for data manipulation
analysis and visualization in the
subsequent module students delve into
data analytics with r language R is a
specialized programming language widely
used in statistical analysis and data
visualization Learners will learn the
fundamentals of R programming data
manipulation using packages like dplr
and TDI yr statistical modeling and data
visualization using ggplot 2 this module
provides students with a deeper
understanding of statistical Concepts
and techniques for analyzing and
interpreting data the course then covers
tab training which focuses on data
visualization and storytelling this
segment will help you learn to create
interactive Dash boards and
visualization using tab software you
will gain expertise in designing
compelling visual representations of
data to effectively communicate insights
and Trends to stakeholders and finally
the course concludes with capson
projects where you'll apply the acquired
Knowledge and Skills to solve real world
data analytic problems Capstone projects
like rating predictions for Google Play
apps demand forecast for Walmart zomato
data analysis and much more which will
provide an opportunity to students to
work on end to-end data analystics
process including data collection
cleaning analysis and visualization
these projects enable students to
Showcase their abilities and develop a
portfolio of practical work by
completing the data analytics course by
I kpur Learners will emerge as skilled
Professionals of data analytics equipped
with business analytics Acumen SQL
proficiency Python Programming progress
our statistical expertise and tabes
visualization skills which will make you
ready to reshape the data landscape you
will become the Catalyst of change
driving Innovation and empowering
businesses with the ability to transform
data into their most valuable asset
simply learn job assist will help you
get noticed by top hiring companies and
can get you hired by renowned companies
like Microsoft Google Amazon IBM Goldman
shacks and many more so embark on this
transformative Journey with I cus data
analytics course and unlock the
boundless potential of data let
curiosity be your compass creativity be
your Guiding Light and data be the
foundation of your success together let
us Unleash the Power of data and reshape
the world of business many aspiring data
analyst have gained benefits from this
data analytics program and some of them
have shared their feedback you can find
the testimonials by following the link
to the course page in the description
box below so if you're interested in
becoming a data analyst and acquiring
job ready skills you should check out
this intensive training program starting
on June 15 2023 which is the next cohort
find out more about this program for
which the link is added in the
description box below also we are
dedicated to accessibility offering
financing options to make our program
affordable and budget friendly choice
for you the cost price is just $15,000
50 making it an very attractive
investment so if you have any further
queries regarding the data analytics
training program or need any help then
please feel free to let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
experts will be more than happy to
resolve all your queries at the earliest
so what is data
analytics companies around the world are
generating vast volumes of data every
hour this data could be in the form of
log files web server and transactional
data as well as various customer related
data
also data is being generated at a rapid
rate from social media websites and
applications such as Facebook Instagram
Twitter and
WhatsApp companies want to use this data
to derive value out of it and make
business
decisions that's where data analytics
comes into
use data analytics is the process of
exploring and analyzing large data sets
to find hidden patterns unseen Trends
discover correlations and valuable
insights to make business
predictions data analytics improves the
speed and efficiency of your
business a few years ago a business
would have gathered information manually
performed statistical and complex
analytics and Unearthed information that
could be used for future
decisions but today that business can
identify insights on the Fly for
immediate
decisions most organizations have big
data and many understand the need to
harness that data and extract value out
of it so they use a lot of modern tools
and Technologies to perform data
analytics some of the tools I will
discuss in detail later in this
tutorial now that we have looked at at
what data analytics really is let us
understand the ways in which you can use
data
analytics first is improved decision
making data analytics eliminates a lot
of guess workor and manual tasks from
choosing the right content planning
marketing campaigns and developing
products organizations can use the
insights they gain from data analytics
to make informed decisions leading to
better outcomes and customer
satisfaction it gives you a 360° view of
your customers which helps you
understand the behavior completely
enabling you to better meet their
needs second is better customer service
data analytics provides you with more
accurate insights of your customers
allowing you to TA customer service to
their needs provide more personalization
and build stronger relationships with
them your data can reveal information
about your customers communication
preferences their interests their
concerns and more it helps you give
better recommendations for products and
services next is efficient operations
data analytics can help you streamline
your processes save money and boost
production when you have an improved
understanding of what your audience
wants you waste less time in creating
ads and content that don't match your
audience interests this helps you
optimize your campaigns create better
content strategies and hence improve
results and finally we have effective
marketing when you understand your
audience better you can Market to them
more effectively data analytics also
gives you useful insights into how your
campaigns are performing so that you can
fine-tune them for optimal outcomes
you also find out the probable customers
who are the most likely to interact with
a campaign and convert into
leads now let's discuss the various
steps involved in the data analytics
process as you can see on the screen
there are five process steps now let me
make you understand each of this one by
one so the first step is to understand
the problem
before starting with the analysis you
need to understand the business problem
and Define your goals asking questions
at the outlet is vital because this
would address issues such as how can we
reduce production costs without
sacrificing quality what are some of the
ways to increase sales opportunities
with our current
resources do customers view our brand in
a favorable way answers to these
questions will help you build a clear
road map with lucrative Solutions also
try to find out the key performance
indicators and consider the Matrix to
track along the
way the second step in the process is
data
collection after you have finalized your
goals it's time to start looking for
your data data collection is the process
of gathering information on targeted
variables identified as data
requirements the emphasis is on ensuring
accurate and right data is collected
data collection starts with primary
sources which are also known as internal
sources this is typically structured
data gathered from CRM software Erp
systems marketing automation tools and
others these sources contain information
about customers finances gaps in sales
Etc under external sources you have both
structured and unstructured data so if
you're looking to perform a sentiment
analysis towards your brand you would
gather data from various review websites
or social media
apps
the next step is to clean the
data the data which is collected from
various sources is highly likely to
contain incomplete duplicate and missing
values so you need to clean these
unwanted redundant data to make it ready
for analysis so to generate accurate
results analytics professionals must
identify duplicate and anomalous data
and other inconsistencies that could
skew the analysis according to a report
60% of data scientists say most of the
time is spent cleaning the data while
57% of data scientists say it's their
least enjoyable
task now the fourth step in the process
is data exploration and
Analysis once data is cleaned and ready
you can go ahead and explore the data
using data visualization and business
intelligence tools you can also use
various Data Mining and predictive
modeling techniques to analyze the data
and build
models you can use supervised and
unsupervised algorithms such as linear
regression logistic regression decision
tree KNN K means clustering and lots
more to build prediction models for
making business
decisions and the final step is to
interpret the
results this part is important because
it's how a business will gain actual
value from the previous four
steps interpreting the results will help
you find unseen Trends and patterns in
the data and gain insights you can have
a validation check if the results are
answering your questions these results
can be shown to your clients and
stakeholders for better understanding
and business
collaboration now that we have looked at
the various steps involved in data
analytics let's now see the different
tools that can be used to perform the a
steps so as you can see we have seven
tools including a few programming
languages that will help you perform
analytics better now let's discuss them
one by
one first we have
python python is an objectoriented
open-source programming language that
supports a range of libraries for data
manipulation data visualization and data
modeling python programmers have
developed tons of free and open- Source
libraries that you can use you can find
many of them via the python package
index which is
pypi the repository of python
software python provides the default
package installer called pip or pip
Python has libraries such as numpy for
numerical computation of data pandas to
manipulate data on numerical tables and
time series then you have scipi for
Technical and scientific computations it
also provides psyit learn which is a
machine learning library for creating
classification regression and clustering
algorithms and finally it also has P
torch and tensorflow for deep
learning up next we have r
R is an open source programming language
majorly used for numerical and
statistical analysis it provides a range
of libraries for data analysis and
visualization some of these libraries
are ggplot tidos plotly deer and
Carro then we have tblo tblo is a
popular data visualization and analytics
tools that helps you create a range of
visualizations to interactively present
the data build reports and dashboards to
Showcase insights and Trends it can
connect with multiple data sources and
give hidden business insights and
patterns then we have a competitor of
tblo which is
powerbi powerbi is a business
intelligence tool developed by Microsoft
that has an easy drag and draw
functionality and supports multiple data
sources with features that make data
visually appealing power B supports
features that help you ask questions to
your data and get immediate insights you
can also forecast your data for
predicting future
Trends so the next tool is Click
view click view provides interactive
analytics with in-memory storage
technology to analyze vast volumes of
data and use data discoveries to support
decision
making it provides social media
Discovery and interactive guided
analytics it can manipulate huge data
sets instantly with
accuracy up next next we have Apache
spark Apache spark is an open source
data analytics engine to process data in
real time and Carry Out complex
analytics using SQL queries and machine
learning
algorithms it supports spark streaming
for real-time analytics and Spark SQL
for writing SQL
queries it also has spark MLB which is a
library that has a repository of machine
learning algorithms and then it has
graphics for graphical
computation
and finally we have
SAS SAS is a statistical analysis
software that can help you perform
analytics visualize your data write SQL
queries perform statistical analysis and
build machine learning models to make
future predictions SAS empowers our
customers to move the world forward by
transforming data into
intelligence SAS is investing a lot to
drive software Innovation for Analytics
Gartner has positioned SAS as a magic
quadrant leader for data science and
machine
learning moving on to the applications
of data
analytics data analytics is being used
in almost every sector of business these
days let's discuss a few of
them first we have
retail customers expect retailers to
understand exactly what they need and
when they need it data analytics helps
retailers meet those
demands retailers not only have an
in-depth understanding of their
customers but they can also predict
Trends recommend new products and boost
profitability retailers create
assortments based on customer
preferences invoke the most relevant
engagement strategy for each customer
optimize supply chain and Retail
operations at every step of the customer
Journey the second application is on
Healthcare
Healthcare Industries analyze patient
data to provide life-saving diagnosis
and treatment
options they also deal with healthcare
plans and insurance information to drive
key insights using analytics they can
discover new drugs and come up with new
drug development
methods Advanced analytics allows
Healthcare companies to improve patient
outcomes and
experience cancer cells and diabetic
retinopathy can be discovered using
Medical
Imaging
at number three we have
manufacturing for manufacturers solving
problem is nothing new they fight with
difficult problems and situations on a
daily basis from complex Supply chains
to motion applications to labor
constraints and Equipment breakdowns
they deal with such problems on a
regular basis using data analytics
manufacturing sectors can discover new
cost saving and revenue
opportunities the fourth application is
related to the banking
sector Banking and financial
institutions collect vast volumes of
structured and unstructured data to
derive analytical insights and make
sound financial decisions using
analytics they can find out probable
Loan defaulters customer turnout rate
and detect fraudulent transactions
immediately the final application is
based on
Logistics logistics companies use data
analytics to develop new business models
that can ease their business and improve
productivity they can optimize routes to
ensure delivery reaches on time in a
cost-efficient manner they also focus on
improving order processing capabilities
as well as Performance
Management with that now let's look at
the companies using data analytics on a
daily
basis so we have the e-commerce giant
Amazon then we we have Accenture
followed by the American healthcare
service organization
siga then we have the American supplier
of Health Information Technology
Solutions Services devices and Hardware
serner followed by Target and Antivirus
company
macafe NeXT we have Rapido which is an
Indian bike rental company based in
Bangalore after that we have Flipkart
and the world's largest retail company
Walmart if you're a professional with
minimum one year of experience and an
aspiring data analyst looking for online
training and certifications from
prestigious universities in
collaboration with leading experts to
enhance your credibility then search no
more simply learns postgraduate program
and data analytics offered by per
University in collaboration with IBM is
just what you need for more details head
straight to our homepage or simply click
on the link in the description box below
now without further delay over to our
training a study from new Vantage
Partners suggests 97.2% of companies are
now investing in data and its analysis
nowadays every company needs a data
expert do you also want to become a part
of this Market if yes how to become a
part of it what are the essential skills
one should
have this video will answer all these
questions but before watching this video
please subscribe to Simply learns
YouTube channel and press the Bell icon
to never miss any updates first of all
we have going to discuss who is a data
analyst working of a data analyst skills
required to become a data analyst tools
required and companies hiring and
finally we are going to discuss about
salary of a data analyst let me tell you
how simply learn can help you in your
journey to become a data analyst check
out the course on data analytics in
collaboration with IBM with realtime
project and business case studies you
will learn tools like scipi pandas and
programming languages like python or art
2 enroll Now link is in the description
box below question for you which one of
the following is not a python library
for
visualization M plot lip cpai pandas
Jupiter notebook please leave the answer
in the comment section below moving on
who is a data analyst a data analyst
collects analyzes and interprets data a
data analyst will convert raw data into
useful information data analyst are in
high demand because every industry uses
data data analysis work of a data
analyst as a data analyst you will work
closely with the raw data and generate
valuable insights to help companies
decide their future goal if you like
thinking out of the box you are the
perfect fit for this domain data analyst
help maximize output when it comes to
generating Revenue working closely with
both business and data nevertheless this
field boost handsome salaries for all
levels of expertise can you become a
data analyst without prior experience
yes anyone can become a data analyst if
they enjoy solving real world problems
have a strong background in statistics
and have a creative mind if you feel you
don't have it you can definitely develop
it so let us know the skills in detail
what are the basic skill sets required
for a data analyst data analyst must
know basic mathematics and statistics
programming skills machine learning and
also data visualizations tools so let us
know what are the basics that you need
to learn as a data
analyst mathematics it is always better
to know basic mathematics like linear
algebra and probability fundamentals
linear algebra is used in data
pre-processing and transformation which
is the critical process of every data
analyst statistics a branch of
mathematics that deals with collection
analysis presentation and
implementation probability we know that
probability is the study of How likely
something will happen which is essential
for concluding both probability and
statistics are the backbones of data
analysis it is feasible to become a data
analyst with only a basic understanding
of these three areas of mathematics but
in order to remain relevant and grow as
a data analyst one's mathematical
knowledge should not be restricted
compulsorily use some of the tools as a
data analystic what are
that first is Microsoft Excel it is the
most well-known spreadsheet software in
the world it also has computation and
graphick features that are excellent for
data analyst no matter your area of
expertise or additional software you
might want Excel is a standard in the
industry it's useful built-in features
in C design tools and pivot table it
also generate a wide range of additional
features that help simplify data
manipulation as a programming language
every data analyst should know python it
is easy to learn learn and has a simple
syntax python is quite adaptable and
includes a vast variety of resource
libraries that are appropriate for a
wide range of diverse data analytics
activities these libraries help in
numerical and data computation the
pandas and numpy libraries for instance
are excellent for supporting standard
data processing and stream lining highly
computational operations you can also
choose between Python or r r is a
well-known open-source programming
language much like python data
visualization tool as we previously
mentioned data visualization tool is
also necessary to become a data analyst
powerbi is a userfriendly interface
makes building interactive visual
reports and dashboard simple it's most
vital selling point is its superb data
integration it works flawlessly with
Cloud sources like Google and Facebook
analytics as well as text files SQL
servers and
Excel
is one of the best commercial data
analysis tool available it handles huge
amounts of data better than many other
bi tools and is effortless it has a
visual drag and drop interface however
because it has no scripting layer there
is a limit to what Tableau can do for
example it could be better for
pre-processing data or building more
complex
calculations you might have heard about
May SQL a lot of time it is a standard
language for interacting with databases
and it is very helpful when working with
structure data SQL creates userfriendly
dashboards that may present in various
data ways in since it is so simple to
send complex commands to databases and
change data in seconds it has commands
like add edit delete data in addition
SQL is an excellent tool for creating
data ware houses because of its
Simplicity Clarity and
interactivity over overall I would
suggest that to become a data analyst
you should work on programming languages
like python or R plus MySQL to work on
databases adding to that Excel plus
visualization tools like tblo or powerbi
you now know what are the skills are and
how it is used what are you up to in an
organization as a data
analyst to create and evaluate the
report using automated tools like tblo
or
powerbi
to troubleshoot the reporting database
environment and reports data analyst you
will use statistical method to analyze
data sets and spot any valuable trends
that may develop over time evaluate
company's functional and non-functional
requirement data analyst assess data
warehousing in inspecting and Reporting
needs these are all the responsibility
of a data analyst in an organization
coming to companies hiring a data
analyst IBM accentor capam mini TCS
Facebook Amazon flip cart meta these are
the top companies hiring a data analyst
but data suggest that every small and
mediumsized Company needs a data analyst
therefore demand of a data analyst is in
every company so there is no need to
worry job and salary of a data analyst
this is the final part the salary of a
data analyst is high all over the world
when it comes to the USA the average
salary for a data analyst as a beginner
is going as high as 70,000 plus dollar
per anom for experienced professional it
is going as high as
$120,000 perom in India for a fresher it
is going as high as 8 lakh perom and for
experienced professionals it is 20 lakh
plus perom such as the demand for data
analyst now that we have covered every
important skill it's time for you to
start working on it so so Sky a limit on
what you use it for let's take a look at
types of data
analytics and this can be broken up in
so many ways uh but we're going to start
with looking at the most basic questions
that you're going to be asking in data
analytics and the first one is you want
descriptive analytics what has happened
hindsight uh how many cells per call
ratio coming out of the call center if
we have 500 tourists in a forest and you
have a certain temperature how many
fires were started how many times did
the police have to show up to certain
houses um all that's descriptive the
next one is predictive Predictive
Analytics is what will happen next we
want to predict uh this is great if you
want have a ice cream store and you want
to predict how many people to work at
the ice cream store in a certain day
based on the temperature coming up in
the time of the year and then one of the
biggest growing and most important parts
of the industry is now prescriptive
analytics and you can think of that as
combining the first two we have
descriptive and we have predictive then
you get
prescriptive analytics how can we make
it happen foresight what can we change
to make this work better in all the
industries we looked at before we can
start asking questions uh especially in
City development there's a good one if
we want to have our city generate more
income and we want that income to be
commercial based uh what kind of
commercial buildings do we need to build
in that area that are going to bring
people over do we need huge warehouse
sales Costco sales buildings or do we
need little mom pod joints that are
going to bring in uh people from the
country to come shop there or do you
want an industrial setup what do you
need to bring that IND industry in there
is there a car industry available in
that area uh if it's not a car industry
what other Industries are in that area
all those things are prescriptive we're
guessing we're guessing what can we do
to fix it what can we do to fix crime in
area with education what kind of
education are we going to use to help
people understand what's going on so
that we lower the rate of crime and we
help our communities grow better that's
all prescriptive it's all guessing we
want foresight into how can we make it
happen how can we make this
better and we really can't not go into
enough detail on these three because a
lot of people stumble on this when they
come in and are doing analytics whether
you're the manager shareholder or the uh
data scientists coming in you really
need to understand the descriptive
analytics where you're studying the
total units of furniture sold and the
profit that was made in the past uh here
we go into Predictive Analytics
predicting the total units that would
sell and the profit we can expect in the
future gear up for how many employees we
need how much money we're going to make
and prescriptive analytics finding ways
to improve the sales and the profit so
we can uh sell maybe a different kind of
furniture uh we're going to guess at
what the area is looking for and how
that marketing is going to change hello
everyone we welcome you all to this
video by simply learn in today's session
we will learn a really interesting topic
that is the top 10 skills to become a
data analyst in
2022 in today's Digital World data is
being generated by companies and
individuals every second so the role of
a data analyist holds supreme
importance so if you're looking for a
career in data analytics this video will
help you learn what a data analyst does
and the various skills you need to
possess to become a data analyst in
2022 before we get started make sure you
subscribe to the simply learn Channel
and hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update from
us let's look at the agenda for this
video first we will understand who a
data analyst is then we will understand
the top 10 data analyst skills for 2022
moving on we will look at the salary of
a data analyst and finally we will look
at the company's hiring data analysts
so now let's understand who is a data
analyst a data analyst is a professional
who collects business data from various
sources interprets it and uses various
statistical tools and techniques to
extract insights and useful information
from it they acquire data from primary
or secondary data sources and maintain
databases they also recognize and
understand the organization's goal and
collaborate with different team members
such as programmers business analysts
and data scientists to build an
effective solution to a business
problem now with this basic
understanding of who a data analyst is
let's learn the top 10 data analyst
skills for
2022 at number one we have structured
query language or SQL SQL is a top skill
that every data analyst should have data
analist use SQL commands and functions
to store process analyze and manipulate
structured data using relational and
nosql
databases they also build data models
and write complex SQL queries and
scripts to gather and extract
information from several databases and
data
warehouses some of the popular databases
a data analyst should be familiar with
are Microsoft SQL Server MySQL postr SQL
and ibmdb 2 the second important skill
for a data analyst is Microsoft
Excel Microsoft Excel is one of the most
popular and oldest spreadsheet
applications for creating reports
performing calculations and analyzing
data data analysts need to know how to
handle tabular data in Excel so they
should be aware of features like sorting
filtering conditional formatting pivot
tables water analyses and functions such
as sumifs and
countifs the third crucial data enless
skill for 2022 is data cleaning and
wrangling usually the data collected by
anglist from various heterogeneous
sources is often messy and contains a
lot of missing
values so it is always crucial to clean
the data and remove noise missing or
erroneous
elements it is also important to format
data using tools and methods before
using it for analysis they're
responsible for data mining as well the
data mined from various sources are
organized in order to obtain new
information from it some of the tools
you need to know for data cleaning and
wrangling are Excel power query and open
refine the fourth skill on our list is
mathematics and
statistics data andal lists often work
on data for higher Dimensions that are
greater than three in order to interpret
such data they need to be good at linear
algebra and calculus they also build
predictive models and statistical models
such as linear regression logistic
regression knif base and K means
clustering in in order to understand the
working of these algorithms they must
have knowledge about statistics and
probability coming to the fifth
important skill for a data analyst in
2022 we have programming data analysts
need to master at least one programming
language preferably python or R in order
to work with complex business problems
analysts need to write scripts and
userdefined functions to automate
tedious tasks Python and art language
provide a collection of different
libraries and pack packages such as
numai pandas deer matplot lip ggplot
which data analyst can use to discover
Trends and patterns from complex data
sets after this we have data
visualization as our sixth skill another
data analyst job role is to visualize
large volumes of data and prepare
summary reports and dashboards for the
leadership team and clients so that they
can make timely business
decisions to do this data analysts use
various data visualiz I ization tools
such as powerbi Tablo and click View
using these tools data analyst can
integrate various data sets apply joint
conditions sort and filter data as well
create different visualizations using
charts and graphs the seventh skill for
a data analyst is industry
knowledge data analyst should have good
knowledge and understanding of the
industry or domain they are working in
for example if you're working in a
healthcare domain you need to know how
Healthcare analytics can be applied to
improve patient care you should have
knowledge about the challenges faced in
healthcare and how you can leverage data
and analytics to solve the issues only
if you have strong industry knowledge
can you try to improve the business the
eighth skill that is important for a
data analyst in 2022 is problem
solving a business deals with several
problems on a daily basis data analysts
should be ready to face those challeng
challenges data analysts are expected to
use their problem solving skills work
with the team troubleshoot what went
wrong and provide an effective solution
via data
analysis a data analyst with good
problem solving skills can help a
business identify current and potential
issues and determine a viable solution
based on the data it
collects the ninth skill on our list is
analytical thinking data analysts need
analytical thinking ability to break
down a complex problem into simple
components and resolve these components
one by one it is a must-have skill for
data and lists analytical thinking
includes deciding the parameters that
need to be considered for defining data
sets analyzing them from different
perspectives and determining variable
dependencies coming to the 10th skill
among the top 10 skills for a data
analyst in 2022 we have
communication data analyst don't just
just interact with computers and
programs they also interact with team
members stakeholders and data
suppliers so good communication skills
are essential data analysts also present
their findings in front of an audience
who might not be familiar with the
analytical methods and processes so they
need to clearly translate their findings
and insights into non-technical terms so
those were the top 10 skills a data
analyst needs to possess in 2022 do you
think we missed out on any skills then
please put your answers in the comment
section
below now let's look at the salary of a
data
analyist according to glaso the average
annual salary for a data analyst in the
United States is
$69,500 rupees per random finally let's
look at the top companies that are
hiring data analysts in
2022 here we have the consultancy and
big four Giant deoy
and the pharmaceutical company cner
Corporation then we have the tech giant
IBM retail company Walmart and the
e-commerce leader
Amazon to achieve the goals of data
analysis we use a number of data
analysis tools companies rely on these
tools to gather and transform their data
into meaningful insights so which tool
should you choose to analyze your data
which tool should you learn if you want
to make a career in this field we will
answer that in this session
after extensive research we have come up
with these top 10 data analysis tools
here we will look at the features of
each of these tools and the companies
using them so let's start
off at number 10 we have Microsoft Excel
all of us would have used Microsoft
Excel at some point right it is easy to
use and one of the best tools for data
analysis developed by Microsoft Excel is
basically a spreadsheet program program
using Excel you can create grids of
numbers text and formula it is one of
the widely used tools be it in a small
or large
setup the interface of Microsoft Excel
looks like
this let's now move on to the features
of
excel firstly Excel works
with the windows version of excel
supports programming through Microsoft's
Visual Basic for applications VBA
programming with VBA allows spreadsheet
manipulation that is difficult with
standard spreadsheet techniques in
addition to this the user can automate
tasks such as formatting or data
organization in
VBA one of the biggest benefits of excel
is its ability to organize large amounts
of data into orderly logical
spreadsheets and charts by doing so it's
a lot easier to analyze data especially
while creating graphs and other visual
data
representations the visualization can be
be generated from specified group of
cells those were few of the features of
Microsoft Excel let's now have a look at
the companies using it most of the
organizations today use Excel few of
them that use it for analysis are the UK
based company Ernest and Young then we
have Urban Pro Whi proo and
Amazon moving on to our next data
analysis tool at number nine we have
rapid m
Miner a data science software platform
rapid Miner provides an integrated
environment for data preparation
analysis machine learning and deep
learning it is used in almost every
business and Commercial sector rapid
Miner also supports all the steps of the
machine learning
process seen on your screens is the
interface of Rapid
minor moving on to the features of Rapid
Miner firstly it offers the ability to
drag and drop it is very convenient to
just drag drop some columns as you are
exploring a data set and working on some
analysis rapid Miner allows the usage of
any data and it also gives an
opportunity to create models which are
used as a basis for decision making and
formulation of
strategies it has data exploration
features such as graphs descriptive
statistics and visualization which
allows users to get valuable insights
it also has more than 1,500 operators
for every data transformation and
Analysis
task let's now have a look at the
companies using rapid Miner we have the
Caribbean Airline leward Islands Air
transport next we have the United Health
Group the American online payment
company PayPal and the Australian
Telecom company mobilecon so that was
all about rapid Miner now let's see
which tool we have at number
eight
we have talent at number eight Talent is
an open-source software platform which
offers data integration and management
it specializes in Big Data integration
Talent is available both in open- source
and premium versions it is one of the
best tools for cloud computing and Big
Data
integration the interface of talent is
as seen on your
screens moving on to the features of
talent firstly automation is one of the
great Boon Talent offers it even
maintains the tasks for the users this
helps with quick deployment and
development it also offers open-source
tools Talon lets you download these
tools for free the development costs
reduce significantly as the processes
gradually speed
up Talent provides a unified platform it
allows you to integrate with many
databases SAS and other Technologies
with the help of the data integration
platform platform you can build flat
files relational databases and Cloud
apps 10 times
faster those were the features of talent
the companies using Talent are Air
France L'Oreal Cap Gemini and the
American multinational pizza restaurant
chain
Dominos next on the list at seven we
have nine constant information minor on
N is a free and open- Source data
analytics reporting and integration
platform it can integrate various
components for machine learning and data
mining through its modular data
pipelining concept Nim has been used in
pharmaceutical research and other areas
like CRM customer data analysis business
intelligence text Mining and financial
data
analysis here is how the interface of
nim application looks
like now coming to the nine
features nine provides an interactive
graphical user interface to create
visual workflows using the drag and drop
feature use of jdbc allows assembly of
nodes blending different data sources
including pre-processing such as ETL
that is extraction transformation
loading for modeling data analysis and
visualization with minimal
programming it supports multi-threaded
inmemory data processing nine allows
users to visually create data flows
selectively execute some or all analysis
steps and later inspect the results
models and interactive
views n server automates workflow
execution and supports team based
collaboration nime integrates various
other open source projects such as
machine learning algorithms from Becca
H2 Caris Park and our project n allows
analysis of 300 million custom addresses
20 million cell images and 10 million
molecular
structures some of the companies hiring
for n a United Health Group asml fractal
analytics atos and LEGO Group let's now
move on to the next tool we have SAS at
number
six SAS facilitates analysis reporting
and predictive modeling with the help of
powerful visualizations and dashboards
in SAS data is extracted and categorized
which helps in identifying and analyzing
data patterns as you can see on your
screens this is how the interface looks
like
like moving on to the features of
SAS using SAS better analysis of data is
achieved by using automatic code
generation and SAS SQL SAS allows you to
access through Microsoft Office by
letting you create reports using it and
by Distributing them through
it SAS helps with an easy understanding
of complex data and allows you to create
interactive dashboards and
reports
let's now have a look at the companies
using SAS we have companies like genpact
iqvia accenta and IBM to name a
few that was all about SAS so for all
those who joined in late let me just
quickly repeat our list at number 10 we
have Microsoft Excel then at number nine
we have rapid minor at number eight we
have talent at number seven we have n
and at number six we have SAS so far do
you all agree with with this list let us
know in the comment section below let's
now move on to the next five Tools in
our
list so at number five we have both R
and python yes we have two of them in
the fifth
position R is a programming next up is
the interface of the Python jupyter
notebook let's now move on to the
feature of both R and
python when it comes to the availability
of R and python it is very easy both R
and python are completely free hence it
can be used without any
license R used to compute everything in
memory and hence the computations were
limited but now it has changed both R
and python have options for parallel
computations and good data handling
capabilities as mentioned earlier as
both R and python are open in nature all
the latest features are available
without any
delay moving on to the companies using R
we have Uber Google Facebook to name a
few python is used by many companies
again to name a few we have Amazon
Google and the American photo and video
sharing social networking service
Instagram that was all about RN
python
at number four we have Apache
spark Apache spark is an open source
engine developed specifically for
handling large- scale data processing
and
analytics spark offers the ability to
access data in a variety of sources
including Hadoop distributed file system
htfs openstack Swift Amazon S3 and
Cassandra it allows you to store and
process data in real time across various
clusters of computers using simple
programming
constructs Apache spark is designed to
accelerate analytics on Hadoop while
providing a complete Suite of
complimentary tools that include a fully
featured machine learning library a
graph processing engine and stream
processing so this is how the interface
of a Pare spark looks
like now let's look at the important
features of Apaches
spark spark stores data in the Ram hence
it can access the data quickly and
accelerate the speed of analytics spark
helps to run an application in a Hadoop
cluster up to 100 times faster in memory
and 10 times faster when running on
disk it supports multiple languages and
allows the developers to write
applications in Java Scala r or python
Spar comes up with 80 high level
operators for interactive querying Spar
code for batch processing join stream
against historical data or run ad hoc
queries on stream
State analytics can be performed better
as spark has a rich set of SQL queries
machine learning algorithms complex
analytics Etc Apache spark provides fall
tolerance through spark rdd spark
resilient distributed data sets are
designed to handle the failure of any
worker node in the cluster thus it
ensures that the loss of data reduces to
zero conviva Netflix iqvia Loi ke Martin
and eBay are some of the companies that
use a party spark on a daily
basis at number three we have another
important growing data analysis tool
that is Click
view click view software is a product of
Click for business intelligence and data
visualization click view is a business
Discovery platform that provides
self-service bi for all business users
and
organizations with click view you can
analyze data and and use your data
discoveries to support decision making
click viw is a leading business
intelligence and analytics platform in
gner Magic
quadrant on the screen you can see how
the interface of Click view looks
like now talking about its features
click viw provides interactive guided
analytics within memory storage
technology during the process of data
Discovery and interpretation of
collected data The Click view software
helps the user by suggesting possible
interpretations click viw uses a new
patent in memory architecture for data
storage all the data from the different
sources is loaded in the ram of the
system and it is ready to be retrieved
from there it has the capability of
efficient social and mobile data
Discovery social data Discovery offers
to share individual Data Insights within
groups or out of it a user can add
annotations as an addition to some
someone else's insights on a particular
data report click view supports mobile
data Discovery within an HTML F enabled
touch feature which lets the user search
the data and conduct data Discovery
interactively and explore other
server-based
applications click view performs olap
and ETL features to perform analytical
operations extract data from multiple
sources transform it for usage and load
it to a data
warehouse the companies that can help
you start start your career in Click
view a Mercedes-Benz Cap Gemini City
Bank cognizant and Accenture to name a
few at number two we have
powerbi powerbi is a business analytic
solution that lets you visualize your
data and share insights across your
organization or embed them in your app
or
website it can connect to hundreds of
data sources and bring your data to to
life with live dashboards and
reports powerbi is the collective name
for a combination of cloud-based apps
and services that help organizations
collate manage and analyze data from a
variety of sources through a
userfriendly
interface powerbi is built on the
foundation of Microsoft Excel and has
several components such as Windows
desktop application called powerbi
desktop and online software is a service
called powerbi service mobile mile
powerbi apps available on Windows phones
and tablets as well as for IOS and
Android
devices here is how the powerbi
interface looks like as you can see
there is a visually interactive sales
report with different charts and
graphs moving on to the features of
powerbi it has an easy drag and drop
functionality with features that make
data visually appealing you can create
reports without having the knowledge of
any programming language powerbi helps
users see not only what's happened in
the past and what's happening in the
present but also what might happen in
the
future it offers a wide range of
detailed and attractive visualizations
to create reports and dashboards you can
select several charts and graphs from
the visualization pan powerbi has
machine learning capabilities with which
it can spot patterns in data and use
those patterns to to make informed
predictions and run what of
scenarios powerbi supports multiple data
sources such as Excel Tech CSV Oracle
SQL Server PDF and XML files the
platform integrates with other popular
business management tools like
SharePoint Office 365 and Dynamics 365
as well as other non-microsoft products
like spark Hadoop Google analytics sap
Salesforce and
MailChimp
some of the companies using powerbi are
Adobe AXA carlsburg capture mini and
Nestle moving on to the next tool so any
guesses as to what we have at number one
you can comment in the chat section
below finally on the top of the pyramid
we have
Tablo Gartner's magic quadrant of 2020
classified Tapo as a leader in business
intelligence and and data analysis
Tableau interactive data visualization
software company was founded in Jan 2003
in Mountain View
California tblo is a data visualization
software that is used for data science
and business intelligence it can create
a wide range of different visualization
to interactively present the data and
showcase
insights the important products of Tabo
are tblo desktop tblo public tblo server
tblo online and tblo reader
this is how the interface of Tableau
desktop looks
like now coming to the features of
tblo data analysis is very fast with
tblo and the visualizations created are
in the form of dashboards and worksheets
tblo delivers interactive dashboards
that support insights on the
fly it can translate queries to
visualizations and import all ranges and
sizes of data writing simple SQL queries
can help join multiple data sets and
then build reports out of it you can
create transparent filters parameters
and
highlighters tblo allows you to ask
questions spot Trends and identify
opportunities with the help of tblo
online you can connect with Cloud
databases Amazon dread shift and Google
big
query the companies using tblo are deoe
Adobe Cisco LinkedIn and the American
e-commerce giant Amazon to name of few
and there you go those are the top 10
data analysis Tools R is a statistical
programming language and environment
that integrates statistical Computing
and Graphics R is powerful and stable
software python python can also be
called as a general purpose programming
language for data analysis and
scientific Computing python can be
considered as the best player in machine
learning python is an expressive
language with many built-in function
both are open- Source software and
platform
independent and they are platform
neutral and also compatible with all
major operating systems including Unix
Windows and Mac next we will be covering
different
parameters we will be covering learning
preferability mathematical
fundamentals speed of both the languages
visualization and
Graphics data handling
capacity
demand community and customer
support employment possibility in both
the
languages let us cover it one by one
first one is learning preferability or
ease of
learning python is Renown for its ease
of use Python's notebooks offer
excellent tools for sharing and
documenation
despite the fact that there are
currently no gois for them programmers
find R as difficult language as a
beginner this implies that the
programmers must devote a significant
amount of time to learn and
comprehending our
coding coming to mathematical
fundamentals
required coming to python understanding
descriptive analysis is very important
in layman's terms the descriptive
statistics often refers to the process
of explaining using certain
representative techniques such as charts
tables Excel files
Etc python statistics is a built-in
library for descriptive
statistics if your data sets are not too
big or if you can't rely on importing
other libraries you can use
python on the other hand R requires
basic statistics from basic statist stat
statistics what I mean is mean mode and
median are the terms used most
frequently in basic statistics it is
referred to as measures of central
tendency probability statistics plays an
important role in handling various types
of probability distribution it includes
binomial and normal
distribution next parameter is
speed python is an interpreted language
with Dynamic typing python always
executes slowly because the code is
executed line by
line compared to Matlab and python R is
our language is significantly slower our
packages are substantially slower than
those for other
languages now that we have covered speed
coming to data visualization and data
collection in
Python When selecting data analysis
tools bit visualization are crucial and
python has some incredible visualization
tool in Python to large and varied
skater plots using regression lines we
can use gz plot 2 and GZ plot
tools compared to draw values visualized
data is easier to comprehend therefore R
has many packages that offers
sophisticated graphic
features in R we can
use in R we can use tools like M plot
lip cbond
Etc data handling capability in both
Python and
R the new releases in Python have
resolved the issue with the python
packages for data analysis are R is
useful for analysis because of the
abundance of packages accessibility of
the test and benefit of employing
formulas however simple data analysis
can also be done using it the need to
install many
packages crucial part of parameter that
is tools and libraries in Python and
R as a python developer one needs to be
well vered in the best libraries because
python has a lot of libraries that have
many different
uses libraries like tensorflow pyit Lear
numai plays an important role in solving
many python related
problems libraries perform a wide
variety of task in are that are very
beneficial for data science operations
example for that is deer bioconductor
Etc community and customer support
support index offered by Python and
R compared to our python has a larger
Community for assistance we can contact
www.python.org
for any queries regarding Python and
help you can support uh you I repeat you
can visit support.realtor.com
queries R offers you with our studio
Community R provides assistance through
its official
website for queries and Community
related issues we can contact
www.r project.org
next is job opportunities in Python and
r a recent survey from indie.com
predicts that at least 55,000 python
jobs in the USA with exponential pay
rates are available big tech companies
like Google Amazon Twitter Facebook
requires python developer to handle
massive amount of data position provided
for a python developer is software
engineer data analyst data scientist and
many
more career in R is an excellent job
opportunity for you as a beginner big
tech company like Google Twitter
Facebook are using
R position provided by companies as a
our developer is data scientist data
analyst data visualization analyst Etc
moving on let us wrap up an important
topic which language to be used between
R and python there is no right or wrong
way to study both python or R both are
in demand skills that will will enable
you to complete almost any data
analytics work you come across It
ultimately depends on your background
interest and career objectives that
which one is better for you but compared
to R python is easy to learn let's
compare its strength and
weaknesses it is used to handle large
amount of data python performs
non-statistical functions and it is best
suitable for programming however python
is better when it comes to
coding whereas R is used in data
visualization
Graphics R is a widespread language in
the statistical
Community it is used to accomplish many
mathematical task so before concluding
the topic let me answer the query that I
have asked regarding R and python do you
guys remember the
question the query was
our language is superficially related to
which
language so the answer for the question
is C
language next question was which one of
the following is a python file extension
it was an easy question answer for that
question is do
py simply learn offers you with the the
best courses for both Python and R
certification offered by simply learn
regarding R is data science with our
certification course it is a skillup
course that contains 64 hours of Applied
training 10 real life industry projects
dedicated mentoring session from
industry experts and finally lifetime
access to self-based learning I will
provide the link for this course in the
description below data scientist for
python it is a best course for a
beginner it includes five courses in
collaboration with IBM at an affordable
price courses includes python for data
science after that we will be covering
appli data science with
python machine
learning as well as tblo
learning and data science Capstone and
finally receive a master's certificate
with individual certification for each
course I will provide the link for this
course in the description below want to
be a certified data expert then here we
have postgraduate program in data
analytics by simply learn take a glance
at the notable features and skills
offered in this course you will benefit
from exclusive IBM hackathons and ask me
anything sessions eight times more
interaction in live online class classes
with industry experts Capstone projects
across three domains and over 14 data
analytics projects using real data sets
from Google Play Store Lyft World Bank
and more master classes from puu faculty
and IBM experts along with simply lears
job assist for better job prospects
acquire skills in data analytics
statistical analysis using Excel data
analysis using Python and R and data
visualization using tab and powerbi
enroll Now using the course Link in the
description box since this is data
analysis with python we got to ask the
question why python for data analytics I
mean there's C++ there's Java there's
net from Microsoft why do people go to
python for
it so the number of reasons one it's
easy to learn with simple
syntax uh you don't have a very high
type set like you do in Java other
coding so it allows you to kind of be a
little lazy in your programming uh that
doesn't mean that it can't be set that
way and that you don't have to be
careful it just makes means you can spin
up a code much quicker in Python the
same amount of code to do something in
Python A lot of times is one two or
three or four lines where when I did the
same thing say in Java I found myself
with 10 12 13 20 lines depending on what
it was it's very scalable and flexible
uh so there's our flexibility cuz you
can do a lot with with it and you can
easily scale it up you can go from
something on your machine to using uh P
spark and the spark environment and
spread that across hundreds if not
thousands of servers across terabytes of
data or pedabytes of data so it's very
scalable there's a huge collection of
libraries this one's always interesting
because Java has a huge collection of
libraries C has a huge collection of
libraries Donnet does and they're always
in competition to get those libraries
out uh scalea for your spark all those
have huge collection of libraries this
is always changing uh but because
Python's open source you almost always
have easy to access libraries that
anybody can use you don't have to go
check your licensing and have special
licensing like you do in some
packages graphics and visualization they
have a really powerful package for that
so it makes it easy to create nice
displays for people to
read and community support because
python is open source it has a huge
community that supports it you can do a
quick Google and probably find a
solution for almost anything you're
working
on python libraries let's bring it
together we have data analytics and we
have python so when we're talking data
analytics we're talking python libraries
for data analytics and the big five
players are numpy pandas Matt plot
Library scipi which is going to be in
the background so we're not going to
talk too much about the scientific
formulas in scipi
andsit so numpy supports in dimensional
arrays provides numerical Computing
tools useful for linear algebra and
forer
transform um and you can think of this
as just a grid of numbers um and you can
even have uh a grid inside a grit or
data it's not even numbers because you
can also put uh words and characters and
just about anything into that array but
you can think of a grid and then you can
have a grid inside a grid and you end up
with a nice threedimensional array if
you want to talk three-dimensional array
you can think of images you have your
three channels of color four if you have
an alpha and then you have your XY
coordinates for the image we're looking
at so you can go x y and then what are
the three channels to generate that
color and numpy isn't restricted to
three dimensions you could imagine uh
watching a movie well now you have your
movie clips and they each have their X
number of frames and each of those
frames have X number of XY coordinates
for the pictures in each frame and then
you have your three dimensions for the
colors
so numpy is just a great way to work
with in dimensional
arrays now closely with numpy is pandas
uh useful for handling missing data
perform mathematical operations provides
functions to manipulate data pandas is
becoming huge because it is basically a
data frame and if you're working with
big data and you're working in spark or
any of the other major packages out
there you realize that the data frame is
very Central to a lot of that and you
can look at it as a Excel spreadsheet
you have your columns you have your rows
or indexes and uh you can do all kinds
of different manipulations of the data
within uh including filling in missling
data which is a big thing when you're
dealing with large pools or lakes of
data where they might be collected
differently from different uh
locations and Matt plot Library we did
kick over the scipi which is a lot of
mathematical computations which usually
runs in the background of the of numpy
and pandas um although you do use them
they're useful for a lot of other things
in there but the map plot Library that's
the final part that's what you want to
show people and this is your plotting
library in Python several toolkits
extend map plot Library
functionality there's like a hundred
different toolkits to extend matplot
Library which range from uh how to
properly display star constellations
from astronomy there's a very specific
one built just for that all the way to
some uh very generic ones we'll actually
add Seaborn in when we do the labs in a
minute several toolkits extend met plot
Library functionality and it creates
interactive
visualization uh so there's all kinds of
cool things you can do as far as just
displaying graphs and there's even some
that you can create interactive graphs
we won't do the interactive grph but
you'll see you'll get a a pretty good
grasp of some of the different things
you can do in matplot
library let's jump over to the demo
which is my favorite it roll up our
sleeves get our hands in on what we're
doing now there's a lot of options when
we're dealing with python uh you can use
pie charm is a really popular
one uh and you'll see this all over the
place um so it's one of the main ones
that's out there and there's a lot of
other ones I used to use net beans which
is kind of lost favor uh don't even have
it installed on my new
computer but the most popular one right
now for data science now py charm's
really popular for python General
development for data science we usually
go to Jupiter uh notebook or anaconda
and we're going to jump into Anaconda
because that's my favorite one to go to
because it has a lot of external tools
for us we're not going to dig into those
but we will pop in there so you can see
what it looks like so with Anaconda we
have our Jupiter lab we have our
notebook these are identical Jupiter lab
is an upgrade to the notebook with
multiple tabs that's all it is and we'll
be using the notebook and you can see
that pie charm is so popular with um
python that we even have it highlighted
here in Anaconda as part of the setup uh
Jupiter notebook can also be a
standalone uh so we're actually going to
be running Jupiter notebook and then you
have your different environments um I
have we're going to be under main Pi 36
there's a root one and I usually label
it Pi
36 the reason is is currently as a
writing this tensor flow only works in
36 and not in 37 or 38 for doing neural
networks but you can actually have
multiple environments which is nice
they're they separate the kernel so it
helps protect your computer when you're
doing development and this is just a
great way to do a display or a demo
especially if you're looking for that
job pull up your laptop open it up or if
you're doing a meeting get a broadc up
to the big screen so that the CEO can
see what you're looking
at and when we launch the notebook uh it
actually opens up a file browser in
whatever web browser you have this
happens to be Chrome
and then you can just go under new
there's a lot of different options
depending on what you have installed uh
Python 3 and this just creates an
Untitled uh version of this and you can
see here I'm actually in a simply learn
folder for other work I've done for
simply
learn uh and that's where I save all my
stuff and I can browse through other
folders making it really easy to jump
from one project to another and under
here we'll go ahead and change the name
of this and we'll go ahead and rename
it data analytics dat data analytics
just so I can remember what I was
doing which is probably about 50 of the
folders in here right or files in here
right now uh so let's go ahead and jump
in there and take a look at some of
these different uh tools that we were
looking
at and as we go through the demo let's
start with the uh numpy uh the least
visually exciting and I'm going to zoom
in here so you can see what we're
doing and the first thing we want to do
is import
numpy
and we'll import it as NP that is the
most common numpy
terminology and let's go and change the
view so we also have the line numbers um
I don't know why we probably won't need
them but like it for easy reference uh
and then we'll create a onedimensional
array we just call us array one and it
equals np. array and you put your array
information in here in this case we'll
spell it out uh you can actually do like
AR range and other ways there's lots of
ways to generate these arrays but we'll
just do about one two three so three
integers and if we
print our array
one we can go ahead and run this and you
can see right here it prints one two
three you can see why this is a really
nice interface to show other people what
you're doing uh with the Jupiter
notebook uh so this is the basic we've
created an array this is a
onedimensional array and then array is
one two three one of the nice things
about the Jupiter notebook is whatever
ran in the this first setup is still
running it's still in the kernel so it
still has the nump imported as NP and it
still has our variable um arr1 for array
one equal to NP array of 1 two 3 so we
go to the next
cell we can check the type of the array
we're just going to print we say hey
what's what what what is this um setup
in here and we want
type um and then we want what is the
type of array one let's go ahead and run
that and it says class numpy indd array
so it's its own class that's all we're
doing is is checking to see what that
class
is and if you're going look at the uh
array class uh probably the biggest
thing you do I don't know how many times
I find myself uh doing this uh because I
forget what I'm working on and I forget
I'm working with a three-dimensional or
four-dimensional array uh and I have to
reformat somehow so it works with
whatever other things I have and so we
do the array shape uh the array shape is
just three because it has three members
and it's a one-dimensional array that's
all that
is and with the numpy array we can
easily access um stick with the print
statement if you actually put a variable
in Jupiter notebook and it's the last
one in the cell it will the same as a
print statement so if I do this where
array one of two it's the same as doing
print array of two that's those are
identical statements in our Jupiter
notebook we'll go and stick with the
print on this one and it's three so
there's our print space two and we have
0 1 2 2 = 3 we can easily change that so
we have array one of place
2 equals
5 and then if we print our array
one uh you can see right down here when
it comes out it's one two and five and
there I leftt the print statement off
because it's the last variable in the
list um and it'll always print the
variable if you just put it in like that
that's a jupyter notebook thing don't do
that in by charm I've forgotten before
doing a
demo and we talked about multiple
Dimensions so we'll do an array um
two-dimensional array and this is again
a numpy
array and in the numpy array we need um
our first Dimension we'll do one 2 3 and
our second dimension uh 3 4 five and you
can see right here that when we hit the
uh we'll do this we'll just do array
two and we can run that and there's our
array two 1 two 3 3 45 we can also do
array
two of uh
one and then we can do let's do zero
doesn't really matter which one actually
let's do uh two there we go and if I run
run this it'll print out five uh because
here we are this is zero uh 0 1 2 3 is
under our zero Row 3 four five is on our
one row always start with zero and then
the two 0 one two goes to the
five and then maybe we forgot what we
are working with so we'll go do array 2.
shape and if we do array two of
shape uh we'll go and run that we'll see
we have two rows and each row has three
elements a two-dimensional array two
three if you looked up here when we did
it before it just had three comma
nothing when you have a single entity it
always saves it as a tupal with a blank
space uh but you can see right here we
have 2 comma
3 and if you remember from up here we
just did this array two of oh let's go
what is it one comma
we run that we get the five you can also
count backwards this is kind of fun and
you'll see I just kind of switch
something on you because you can also do
one comma two to get to the same spot um
now two is the last one 0 one two it's
the last one in there we can count
backwards and do minus one and if we run
this we get the same answer whether we
count it as uh let's go back up here
whether we count this as
012 or count backwards as min-1 -2 -3
and you can see that if I change this
minus one to a min-2 and run
that I get four which is going backwards
minus one minus two so there's a lot of
different ways to reference what we're
working on inside the numpy
array it's really a cool tool it's got a
lot of things you can do with
it and we talked about the fact that it
can also hold things that are not values
and we'll call this array ask for
Strings equals uh np.
array put our setup in there brackets
and let's
go
China
um
[Music]
India
USA uh
Mexico doesn't matter we can make
whatever we want on here and if we print
that
out we run this you can see that we get
our numpy of Ray China India USA Mexico
Co it even gives us our D type of a
U6 and a lot of times when you're
messing with data we'll call this array
R for range just to kind of keep it
uniform np. a range so this is a command
inside numpy to create a range of
numbers and if you're testing data Maybe
you want maybe you have equal time
increments um that are spaced a certain
point apart but in this case we're just
going to do
integers
and we're going to do a uh a setup from
0 20 skipping every other one and we'll
print it out and see what that looks
like and you can see here we have 0 2 4
6 8 10 12 14 16 18 like you expect it it
skips every one and just a quick
note there's no 20 on here uh why well
this starts at zero and counts up to 20
so if you're using to another language
where explicitly says uh less than or
less than equal to 20 like 4X = 0 um X+
plus uh X is less than 20 that's what
this is it just assumes X is less than
20 on
here and if we want to create a very
uniform uh set you know 0 2 4 6 what
happens if I want to create numbers uh
from 0 to 10 but I need 20 increments in
there uh we can do that with line space
SP so we can create um an R uh we'll
call this
L equals I don't think we'll actually
use any of this again so I don't know
why I'm creating unique um identifiers
for it uh but we'll do
NP uh Lin
space and we're going to do
0o to 10 or 0 to 9 uh remember it
doesn't it goes up to 10 and then we
want to let's say we have
20 different uh
increments in there so we're creating a
we have a data set and we know it's over
a certain time period and we need to
divide that time period by 20 and it
happens to just have 10 pieces in it um
and here we go you can see right here we
have TW or has 20 pieces in it but it's
over 10 years we got to divide it in the
middle and you can see it does it goes
0.52 remember yeah there's our 10 on the
end so it goes up to
10 uh and then we can also do random
there's np. random if you're doing
neural
networks uh usually start it by seating
it with random
numbers and we'll just do np. random and
we'll just call this array we'll stop
giving it unique numbers we'll print
that one out and run it and you can see
we have random numbers they are 0o to
one so you'll see that all these numbers
are under one and you can easily alter
that by multiplying them out or
something like that if you want to do
like 0 to 100 um you can also round them
up if its integer 0 to 100 there's all
kinds of things you can do but it
generates a random float between 0o and
one and you have a couple options you
could reshape that um or you can just
generate them uh in whatever shape you
want and so we can see here uh we did
three and four and so you can see three
rows by four variables same thing as
doing a reshape of 12 variables to three
and
four and if you're going to do that you
might need an empty data set
um I have had this come up many times
where I need to start off with zero and
I don't know you know because I'm going
to be adding stuff in there or it might
be zero and one or one is uh if you're
removing the background of an image you
might want the background is zero and
then you figure out where the image is
and you set all those boxes to one and
you create a mask so creating mask over
images is really big and doing that with
a a numpy array of
zero and we can also
uh give it a
space and we'll just do this all in one
shot this time and we'll do the same
thing like we did
before zeros and in this case we'll do
uh 2 comma 3 and so when we run
this forgot the asteris around it I knew
I was forgetting something there we go
so when we run this uh you can see here
we have our 10 zeros in a row
and maybe this is a mask for an image
and so it has uh two rows of three
digits in it so it's a very small image
little tiny
pixel and maybe you're looking to do
something the opposite way uh instead of
uh creating a mask of zeros and filling
in with ones uh maybe you want to create
a mask of ones and fill them in with uh
zeros and we'll just do just like we did
before we'll do three comma 4 and when
we run this you'll see it's all ones and
we could even do this even U we'll do it
this way let's do
10 10 x 10 icon and then you have your
three
colors so creates quite a large array
there for doing pictures and stuff like
that when you add that third dimension
in um if we take that off it's a little
bit easier to
see we'll do 10
again and you can easily see how we have
10 rows of 10
ones and you can also do something uh
like create an
array and we'll do 0 one
2 and then in this array um we actually
print it right out we want a repeat so
you can actually do a repeat of the
array and maybe you need this array um
let's repeat it three
times so there's our repeat of an array
repeat three times
times and if we run this you'll see we
have 00001
111222 and whenever I think of a repeat
I don't really think of repeating being
the first digit three times the second
digit I really always think of it as um
012 012 012 it catches me every time uh
but the actual code for that one is
going to be tile uh and again if we do
AR range three
and we run this you can see how you can
generate 012 012
012 and if you're dealing with um an
identity Matrix um we can do that also
if you're big on your doing your
matrixes and we'll just
identity I guess we'll go and spill it
out today
Matrix and the command we're looking for
is um I e and we'll do three and then
we'll just go ahead and print this
out there we go there's our identity
Matrix and it comes out by a 3X3 array
because there's our Matrix uh and then
it puts the ones down the middle and for
doing your different Matrix math and we
can manipulate that a little bit too um
we talk
about uh
matrixes
we might not want ones across the middle
in which case we now have uh the
diagonal so we can do an np.
diagonal and we do a diagonal uh let's
put in the
diagonal 1 2 3 4 5 and when we run
this again this generates a value and by
just putting that value in there is the
same as putting print around it or
putting array equals and then print
array and you can see it generates a
diagonal 1 2 3 4 5 and there's your uh
your beginning of your Matrix array for
working with the
matrixes and we can actually go in
reverse uh let's create an array equals
remember our
random random. random and we'll do a 5x5
array uh oops there we go five by
five and just so you can see what that
looks
like helps if I tpe don't mistype the
numbers which in this case I just need
to take out the the brackets and there
you go you have your your 5x5 array set
up in there and we can now because we're
working with matrixes we might want to
do this in reverse and extract the
diagonals which would be the 79 the 678
and so
on and we simply type in np.
diagonal and we put our array in there
um and this will of course print it out
because it returns it as a variable and
you can see here here's our Di going
across from our
Matrix and we did talk about shape
earlier if you remember you can do um
print the shape out you can also do the
dimensions uh so in Dimensions very
similar to shape it comes out and just
has two Dimensions we can also look at
the size so if we do size on here we can
run that and you can see has a size of
25 two dimensions and of course 5x5 and
that was from the shape from earlier
that we looked at uh there's our 5x5
shape
shape and if you remember earlier we did
random well you can also do uh random I
talked a little bit about manipulating
zero to one how you can get different
answers you can also do straight for the
integer part and we'll do minus uh 10 to
4 and so we're going to Generate random
integers between minus 10 to 10 uh we're
going to generate four of those and so
when we run that we have 7 - 3 - 6 - 3
three they're all between minus 10 and
10 and there's four of
them and now we jump into some of the
functionality of arrays uh which is
really great because this is where they
come
in here's your array and you can add tin
to it and if I run this um there takes
my original array from up
here with the integers and adds 10 to
all of those values so now we have oh
this is the decimal that's right this is
a random decimal I had stored in
Array um but this takes a random decim
the random numbers I had from 0o to one
and adds 10 to them and we can just as
easily do uh minus
10 uh we could even
do times
two and we could do divide by
two and it would it'll take that random
number we generated and cut it in half
so now all these numbers are under 0.5
uh another way you can change the
numbers to what you need on
there and as you dig deeper into numpy
we can also do exponential so as an
exponential function uh which should
generate some interesting numbers off of
the random so we're taking them to the
power I don't even remember what the
original numbers in the um array were
because we did the random numbers up
there here's our original numbers and if
you build an exponential on there uh
this is where you get e to the X on this
and just like you can do e to the X you
can also do the log so if you're doing
logarithmic
functions that reinforced learning you
might be doing some kind of log setup on
there and you can see the logarithmic of
these different array
numbers and if you're working with uh
log base
2 you can do you can just change it in
there NP log 2 you have to look it up
because this is not log 1 2 3 4 5 um it
is Log and log two uh so just a quick
note that's not a variable going in that
is an actual command there's a number of
them in there and you'll have to go look
and see uh what the documentation is but
you can also do log 10 so here's log
value
10 uh some other really cool functions
you can do with this is your sign so we
can take a sign value of all of our
different uh values in there and if you
have sign you of course have
cosine we can run that
uh so here's a cosine of those and if
you're doing activations in your numpy
array and you're doing a tangent
activation uh there's your tangent for
that and the tangent activation is
actually uh from uh neural networks
that's one of the ways you can activate
it because it forms a nice curve between
uh from whether you're generating one to
negative one uh with some discrepancy in
the
middle just jumping a little bit in
there into neural networks
and then we get into let me just put the
array back out there so that we can see
it uh while we're doing this as we're
getting into this you can also sum the
values so we have NP
sum and you can do a summation of all
the values in this array and you'll see
that if you added all these together
they'd equal
12519 so on I don't know what the whole
setup is in
there uh but you can see right here the
the summation of this one of the things
you can also do is by axes so we could
do axis equals zero and if we run the
summation of the axis equals
zero and you can think of that uh in
numpy as the rows so that would be uh or
you can think of that in numpy as being
the columns we're summing these columns
going across and you can also change
this to
one and now we're summing the
rows
and so that is the summation of this row
and so forth and so forth going
down and maybe you don't need to um know
the summation maybe what you're looking
for is the
minimum uh so here's our minimal you
you're looking for and this comes up a
lot because you have like your errors we
want to find the minimal error inside of
this array and just like um the other
one we can do X is equal
Z and you can see see here
0.645 is the smallest number in this
First Column is 0645 and so
on and if you have a minimum well you
might also want to know the max maybe
we're looking for the maximum profit and
here we go you can see maximum 79 is a
maximum on this first column and just
like we did before you can change this
to a one on axes you can take the axis
out of here and just find the max value
for the whole array and the max value in
here was 8344 so on so
on and since we're talking data
analytics uh we want to go ahead and
look at the mean uh pretty much the same
as the average this is the mean across
the whole thing and just like we did
before we could also do axis equals
zero and then you'll see this is the
mean of this axis and so
on and we have mean we might want to
know the
median and there's our median are most
common numbers uh if we have median we
might want to know the standard
deviation or if we have the average a
lot of times you do the means in the
standard deviation um we can run that
and there's our standard deviations
along the axis we can also do it across
the whole
array uh if we're going to do standard
deviations there's also uh
variance which is your
V and there's our variance across the
different levels
and so if we looked at that we looked at
variance we looked at standard deviation
the median and the means there's more
but those are the most common ones used
with data analytics um and then going
through your data and figuring out uh uh
what you're going to present to the
shareholders and some other things we
can do is we can actually take slices uh
you'll hear that
terminology and a slice might be um like
we have a 5x5 array but maybe we don't
want the whole array maybe we we want uh
from one on we don't want the zero in
there so we got up to four and maybe on
the second part we just
want two to row three and see this
notation right here says one to the end
and if we run this you can see how that
generates uh a single row to the end and
then row two and three now remember it
doesn't include three that's why we only
get the one column so if you wanted two
and three you would need to go ahead and
go two to four so goes up to four we
could also do this in Reverse just like
we learned earlier we can go minus one
oops and when we go to minus one it's
the same thing because we have 0 1 2 3 4
this is the same thing as 2 to four goes
two to the last
one also very common with arrays is
you're going to want to sort them so we
still have our array up here that we
randomly generated and we we might want
to
um sort it and we'll go and throw an
axis back in there uh axis equals one if
we run this you can see from the axes
that it sorts it uh the point 2 being
the lowest value to the highest value by
the row we can also change this of
course to axis zero if you're sorting it
by columns so maybe your values are
based on columns and then of course you
can do the whole array
and we can sort that don't usually do
that but you know I guess sometimes you
might that might come
up and so you can see right here we have
a nice sorted array uh something else
let's just go ahead and reprint our
array so we can look at it again
starting to get too many boxes up there
uh something else you can do with an
array is we can take and transpose it
this comes up more than you would think
when you transpose it you'll see that um
the rows and the column are transposed
so where
7957 064 is the column now we' switched
it and we have 79.4 2 as the
index you can see this really more
dramatic if we take a
slice and we'll just do a slice of the
first couple and then we'll just do all
the other um the full rows and if we run
this you can see how it comes up a
little bit different and we'll just do
the same slice up here see see how those
two look next to each
other there we go there's our slice run
uh and so you can see the slice comes up
and it has uh one two 3 four five
columns now we have 1 2 3 four five rows
and three columns versus three
rows and the original version when they
first started putting this um together
uh was a function so the original
version was transpose and this still
works you can still see it generates
this the same value as just a capital T
so many times we flip this data because
we'll have an XY value or we'll have an
image or something like that and it's
being read one way into the next process
and the next one needs it the opposite
uh so this actually happens a lot you
need to know how to transpose the data
really
quick and we can go ahead oh let's just
take um here's our transpose we'll just
stick with the transpose on here and
instead of doing it this way we might
need to do something called flattening
why would you flatten your data uh if
this is an array going into a neural
network you might want to send it in as
one set of values instead of two rows
and you can see here is all the values
as a single array it just flattens it
down into one
array so we covered our scientific uh
means transpose median um some different
variations on here some of the other
things we want to do is what happens if
we want to Pinn to our array uh so let's
create a new array I'm getting tired of
looking at the same set of random
numbers we generated earlier um so we'll
go and create a new array here something
a little simpler so it's easier to see
what we're
doing and four five six
78 uh that's good enough we'll just do
four five six
S8 and if we print this
array there it is 4 five 6 7
8 and we might want to Pinn something to
the array so we have our array we need
to extend it you got to be very careful
about appending things to your array and
there's a number of reasons for that uh
one is runtime because of the way the
numpy array is set up a lot of times you
build your data and then push it into
the numpy array instead of continually
adding on to the array um and then it
also usually it automatically generates
a copy for protecting your data
so there's a lot of reasons to be
careful about a pending this way uh but
you can certainly do it and we can just
take our array we're going to create a
new array array one and if we print
array one and we append eight to it
you'll see four five six s and then
there's our eight appended on to the
end and if you want to appin something
to an array um you'd probably also want
to
whoops array one let's try that again
there we go now we have the eight
appended on to the end
um so you can see four five six seven
eight and then we pinned another eight
on
there and if you're going to Ain
something you might want to um go ahead
and insert instead of appending it might
be you need to keep a certain order and
we can do the same thing we do our
array um and we're going to pin or um
insert at the beginning and let's go
ahead and insert uh one two 3 one two 3
and we go ahead and print our array to
we run it and you can see 1 2 3 a pin is
inserted at the beginning uh inserts a
lot more powerful and that you can put
it anywhere in the array we can move it
to the one spot and there we go one two
three uh we can do a minus one just for
fun and you'll see it comes up uh one
two 3 we're counting backwards by one I
imagine you can do minus
0 and run this and it turns out that
minus 0 puts it back at the beginning
because that's why it registers a zero
just takes a minus sign
off and just like we add numbers on we
might want to delete numbers and so uh
let's do an np. delete well let's let's
keep it a little bit make it a little
easy here um to watch we'll go ah and
create an array three and we'll do NP
delete we were just working with array
uh
two and we want to do is delete zero
space uh so if you look at this here's
our array two array two starts with one
and when we delete the space on
here and print that out uh we deleted
the one right out of
there and we can also do something like
this or we can do it as a slice and we
can do let's do one comma 3 and if we
run one comma 3 you'll see we've deleted
the one space and the three space out
which deleted our two and
four now keep in mind when you're
messing with um adding lines and
deleting
lines uh you have to be really careful
because there's a time element involved
um as far as where the data is coming
from and it's really easy to delete the
wrong data and corrupt what you're
working on or to insert stuff where you
don't want it um so there's always a
warning when we talk about manipulating
numpy
arrays and just like anything else we're
doing uh we'll create an array C which
equals we'll just do our um our numpy
array that we just created our an array
three and we can do copy so you can make
a copy of it um maybe you want to
protect your original data or maybe
you're making a mask and so you copy the
array and then the new array make all
these alterations and change it from
values to zero to one to mask over the
first one and of course we if we do um
array C since it equals a copy of uh
array three it's the same thing 1 3 5 6
8 and now we're getting into uh combine
and split arrays I end up doing a lot of
this and I don't know how many times I
end up fiddling with this and having a
mess uh so but but you do it a lot you
know you combine your arrays you split
them you might need one set of data for
one thing another set of data for the
other so let's go and create two arrays
array one array two and I want you to
note and the terminology we're going to
look for is concatenate what that means
is we're going to take
um we'll call this AR Ray cat I like a
ray cat there we go um our array cat or
concatenated
array we're taking array one and two and
it's very important to really pay
attention to your axes and your counts I
can't merge two arrays that have like if
their axes are messed up and I'm merging
on axis zero it's going to give me an
error and I'll have to reshape them so
you got to make sure that what ever
you're concatenating together works and
what that
means as you can see here we have 1 2 3
4 1 2 3 4 and then 5 6 7 8 5 6 7 8 along
the zero axis these each are four values
um so it's a 2x4 value and if we go
ahead and switch this to one you can see
how that's that flips it a little bit so
now we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 it's interesting that we chose that
one if I did something like this
where this is
now there we go and we can catenate it
um run this and it gives me an answer
okay because I have two by two and I'm
using axis one but if I switch this to
axis zero where now it's got three and
five it gives me an error so you got to
be really careful on that to make sure
that your whatever axes you are putting
together that they match um so like I
said this one oops X's one axis one has
two entities and since we're going on
axis one or by row you can see that it
lets it uh merge it right onto the end
there and you could imagine this if this
was a XY plot of value or the x value
going in and the predicted y value
coming out and then you have another
prediction and you want to combine them
this works really easy for that and
we'll go back and let's just put this
back to where we had
it oops I forgot how many changes I made
there there we go we'll just put it Oops
I messed up on my concatenation order
[Music]
here there we
go okay so you can see that we went
through the different concatenation axes
is really important when you're doing
your concatenation values on here and
we'll switch this back to one just
because I like the looks of that better
there we go two
rows now there are as commands in here
um so we can do uh cap V equals
npv
vstack this is nothing more than your
concatenation uh but instead we don't
have to put the axes in there uh because
it's v stands for vertical and so if we
print out
cat V and we run this you can see we get
the 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 and that would be
the same as making this axis zero for
vertical stack and if you're going to
have a vertical stack uh you can also
have an H
stack so if we change this to from v
stack to oops here we go H stack and
we'll just change this from cat to cat
and I run
this it's the same as doing axis zero
the process is identical in the
background um this is like a legacy
setup uh your v stack and your hstack
most people just use concatenate and
then put the axes in there because it's
much uh has a lot more clarity and um is
more more commonly used
nowadays the last section in numpy we're
going to cover uh
is is kind of uh data exploration um and
that'll make a little bit more sense in
just a moment sometimes they call them
set operations but let's say we have an
array 1 2 3 4 5 6 3 whatever it is uh
you we generate a nice little array here
and what I want to go ahead and do is
find the unique values in that array uh
so maybe I'm generating what they call a
one hot encoder and so these values then
all become I need to know how long my
bit array is going to be so each word
how many how many each word is
represented by a number and then I want
to know just how many of those words are
in there if we're doing word count very
popular thing to
do um and you can see here when we
unique uh we have 1 2 3 4 5 six those
are our unique
values uh some of the things we can do
with the unique values is we can also
instead of doing just unique we can do
uniques or unique values and counts of
each unique
value and this is very similar to what
we just did up here where we uh we're
doing NP unique uh but we're going to
add a little bit more into there and
it's just part of the arguments in this
and we want to do return
counts equals true so in instead of just
returning the unique values uh we want
to know how many of those unique values
are in each one and we'll go ahead and
print our
uniques and
counts when we run that uh you can see
here we have our unique value 1 2 3 4 5
six just like we had before and then
there's two of the first of two On's two
twos two 3es two fours one five two
sixes and so on and you can go through
and actually look at that if you want to
count them um but a quick way to find
out your um uh distribution of different
values so you might want to know how
often the word the' is used versus the
word and if each word is represented as
a unique
number and along the set variables we
might want to know um let me just put a
note up here we're going to start
looking at
uh
intersection and we might want to also
know
differentiation and uh
neither so when we're whoops
neighbor neither um so what we're
looking at now is we want to know hey
where do these two arrays intersect and
we have 1 2 3 4 5 3 4 5 6 7 we might
want to know what is common between the
two arrays uh and so when we do that we
have um
NP
intersect and it's a ond array
onedimensional
array and then we need to go ahead and
put array uh one array
two and if we run
this we can see they intersect at 3 4
five that's what they have
common uh and because we're going to go
ahead and go through these and look at a
couple different different options let's
change this from intersect
1D and we'll do the same thing we'll go
and print this so we might want to know
the intersection uh where they have
commonalities another uh unique word is
Union of 1D uh so instead of uh
intersect we want to know all the values
that are in both of them so here's our
Union of 1D when we run that you can see
we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 so it's all the
different values in
there
and the last one of the last words we
have two more to go uh is we want to
know what the set difference
is uh and so that's where the you'll see
if you remember set we talked about that
being the what they call these things um
so the set
difference of a 1D array when we run
that you can see that one is only in one
array and two is only in one
array and if we want to know uh what's
in Array one but not in Array two we
might want to know what is in Array one
but not two and what's in two but not
one uh and this would be the set X or 1D
on here uh so we have the four different
options here where we can do an
intersection what do they both have in
common uh we can do a union what are all
the unique values in both arrays we can
see the difference what's in Array one
but not array two so set diff 1D and
then set X or what is not in one
but is in two and what is in not in two
but in
one so we dug a lot in numpy because we
were talking um there's a lot of
different little mathematical things
going on in numpy a lot of this can also
be done in pandas although usually the
heavy lifting is left for numpy because
that's what it's designed for let's go
ahead and open up another Python
3 setup in here and so we want to
explore uh what happens when you want to
display this this is where it starts
getting in my opinion a little fun
because you're actually playing with it
and you have something to show people
and we'll go ahead and rename this we're
going to call this uh
pandas uh and pip plot so pandas pip
plot just so we can remember for next
time and we want to go ahead and import
the necessary libraries we're going to
import pandas as PD now remember this is
a data frame so we're talking rows and
columns and you'll see how uh pandas
work so nicely uh when you're actually
showing to people and then we're going
to have numpy in the background numpy
works with pandas uh so a lot of times
you just import them by
default Seaborn sits on top of the map
plot Library uh so sometimes we use the
Seaborn because it kind of extends it's
one of the 100 packages that extends the
matplot library probably the most common
used because it has a lot of built-in
functionality um almost by default I
usually just put caborn in there in case
I need it and of course we have map plot
Library as pip plot as PLT and note we
have as PD as NP as SNS as PLT those are
pretty standard so when you're doing
your Imports I would probably keep those
just so other people can read your code
and it makes sense to them that's pretty
much a standard
nowadays and then we have the strange
line here uh it says uh amber sign
matplot library in line that is for
Jupiter notebook only so if you're
running this in a different package
you'll have a popup when it goes to
display the matplot library um you can
with the most current version of Jupiter
usually leave that out and it will still
display it right on the page as we go
and we'll see what that looks like and
then we're going to go ahead and just uh
do the um caborn the SNS do set and
we're going to set the color codes
equals true let them uh just keep the
default on so we don't have to think
about it too
much and we of course have to run this
um the reason we run this is because
these values are all set if we don't run
this and I access one of these um
afterward it'll it'll crash the cool
thing about Jupiter notebooks is if you
forgot to import one of these you forgot
to install it because you do have to
install this under your anaconda setup
or whatever setup you're in you can flip
over to Anaconda and run your install
for these um and then just come back and
run it you don't have to close anything
out and we'll go ahead and paste this
one in here real quick where we have car
equals pd. read CSV and then we we have
uh the actual path this path of course
will vary depending on what you are
working with uh so it's wherever you
saved the file at and you can see here I
have um like my one drive documents
simply Learn Python data analytic using
python SL car CSV it's quite a long
file when we open that up what we get is
we get a CSV file and we have the make
the model the year the engine fuel type
uh engine horsepower cylinders and so on
um and this is just a comma separated
file so each row is like a row of data
think of it as a um
spreadsheet and then each one is a
column of data on here and as you can
see right here it has the make model so
it has columns for a header on
here now your pandas just does an
excellent job of automatically pulling a
lot of this in so when you start seeing
the pandas on here you realize that you
are already like halfway done with
getting your data in uh I just love
pandas for that reason numpy also has it
you can load a CSV directly into numpy
um but we're working with pandas and
this is where it really gets cool is I
can come down here and I can print uh
you remember our print statement we can
actually get rid of it and we're just
going to do car head cuz it's going to
print that out the head is going to
print the top values of that data file
we just ran in and so you can see right
here it does a nice print out it's all
nice and inline because we're in jupyter
Notebook I can scroll back and forth and
look at the different data uh and just
like we expected we have our column and
it brought the header right in one thing
to note is the index it automatically
created an index 0 1 2 3 4 and so on and
we're just looking at the head so we got
01 2 3
4 um you can change this you might want
to just look at the top two
we can run that there's our top two
BMWs um another thing we can do is
instead of head we can do
tail and look at the last three values
that are in that data file and uh you
can see right here numbered them all the
way up to
11,933 oh my goodness they put a lot of
data in this file I didn't even look to
see how big the file was uh so you can
really easily get through and view the
different data in here when you're
talking about Big Data
you almost never just print out car uh
in fact let's see what happens when we
do if we run this and we just run the
car it's huge uh in fact it's so big
that the pandas automatically truncates
it and just does head plus tail so you
can see the two um so we really don't
want to look at the whole thing I'm go
and go back to we'll stick with the head
displaying our data there we go so
there's ahead of our data gives us a
quick look to see what's actually in
there there um I can zoom out if we want
so you can actually get a better
view although we'll keep it zoomed in so
you can see the code I'm working
on and then from the uh data standpoint
we course want to look at um data types
uh what's going on with our data what
does it look like uh now this you know
you show your when you're talking to
your
shareholders they like to see these nice
easy to read charts they look like a
spreadsheet uh so it's a a nice way of
displaying pieces of the
chart when we talk about the data types
now we're getting into the data science
side of it what are we working with well
we have uh make model we have an integer
64 for the year uh engine fuel type is
an object if we go up here you can see
that there most of them are um like you
know it's a set manual rear wheel drive
uh so they might be very limited number
of types in
there uh and so forth you it's either
going to be a float 64 an integer or an
object is the way it's going to read it
on
here and the next thing you going to
know is like your
columns and since it loaded the columns
automatically uh we have here the make
the model the year the engine the size
all the way up to the
MSRP and um just out of something you'll
see come up a lot is whenever you're in
pan pandas you type in values it
converts it from a pandas uh list to a
numpy
array and that's true of any of these uh
so then you end up in a numpy array so
you'll see a little switch in there in
the way that the data is actually stored
and that's true of any of these uh in
this case so we went car.
columns you have a total list of your
car columns and like any good data um
scientist we want to start looking at
analytical summary of the data set
what's going on with our data so we can
start trying to um piece Mill it
together so we can do
car uh
describe and then we'll do is we'll do
include equals all uh so a nice Panda
command is to describe your data if
you're working with r this should start
looking familiar uh and we come down
here and you can see um count there's uh
make the model the year um how many of
each one how many unique values of each
one uh the top value of each one what's
most common the frequency the mean um
clearly on some of these it's an object
so it really can't tell you what the um
average is you it' just be the top one's
the average I guess um the year what's
the average year on there um all this
stuff comes down here your standard
deviation your minimum value your
maximum value uh what's in the lower
quarter 50% Mark where's that line at
and what's in the upper 75% the top 25%
going into the
max now this next part is just cool uh
this is what we always wanted computers
to be back like in the 90s instead of
5,000 lines of code to do this maybe not
5,000 all right I built my own plot uh
Library back in 95 and the amount of
code for doing a simple plot was um I
don't know probably about 100 lines of
code this is being done in one line of
code we have our car which is our pandas
we generated that it's our data frame
and we have hist for histogram that is
the power of caborn now it's still going
to generate a numpy graph but caborn
sits on top and then we can do the
figure size this is just um so fits
nicely on the paper on here and we do
something simple like this and you can
see here where it comes up and it does
say matplot library and does subplots
and
everything but we're looking at a
histogram of all the different pieces in
our database and we have our engine
cylinders um that's always a good one
because you can see like they have some
that are they had a null on there so
they came out at zero um maybe a couple
maybe one of them had a two-cylinder
engine a way back when four is a common
uh six a little less common and then you
see the 8 cylinder uh 12 cylinder
engines well that's got to be a
Speedster or something uh but you can
see right here it just breaks it down so
now you have uh how many many cars with
how many whatever it is cylinders
horsepower uh and so on and it does a
nice job displaying it you can see if
you're working with your uh um you're
going into your uh demo it's really nice
just to be able to type that in and boom
there it is I can see it all the way
across and we might want to zero in uh
and use like a box plot and this time
we'll go ahead and call the um caborn
SNS box plot and we're going to go ahead
and do um vehicle size versus um engine
horsepower XY plot and the data comes
from the car so if we run this we end up
with a nice box plot you see our midsize
Compact and large you can see the
variation there's our outlier showing up
there on the compact that must be a
high-end sports car uh large car might
have a couple engines and again we have
all these outliers and then your
deviation on
them very powerful and quick way to Z
zero in on one small piece of data and
display it for people who need to have
it reduced to something they can see and
look at and understand and that's our
caborn box plot or SNS dobox
plot and then if we're going to back out
and we want to quick look at um what
they call pair plotting uh we can run
that and you can see with the caborn it
just does all the work for you uh it
takes it just a moment for it to pull
the data in and compile
it
and once it does it creates a nice grid
um and this grid if you look at uh this
one space here which is might not be
able to see the small number says engine
horsepower this is engine horsepower uh
to the year it was built and it's just
flipped so everything to the right of
the middle diagonal is just uh the
rotation of what's on the left and as
you expect um the engine horsepower um
gets bigger and bigger and bigger as
time goes on so the the year it was
built further up in the year the more
likely you are to have a heavy
horsepower
engine and you can quickly look at
Trends with our pair plot coming up uh
and look how fast that was that was it
took it a c you know moment to process
uh but right away I get a nice view of
all these different um information which
I can look at visually and and kind of
see how things group and
look now if I was doing a meeting I
probably wouldn't show all the data
um one of the things I've learned over
the years is um people myself included
love to show all our work you know we
were taught in school show all your work
prove what you know the CEO doesn't want
to see a huge U grid of of graphs I
guarantee it uh so we want to do is we
want to go ahead and
drop um the stuff that might not be
interested in and we're going to I'm not
really a car person guing the back is
obviously so you have your engine fuel
type we're going to drop that we're
going to drop Market category vehicle
style popularity number of doors vehicle
size um and we have the axes in here if
you're member from numpy we have to
include that axis to make it clear what
we're working on that's also true with
pandas and then we'll look at just the
what what it looks like um from the head
and you can see that we dropped out
those categories and now we have the
make model year uh and so forth um and
we took out the engine fuel type Market
category Etc
uh and this should look familiar to you
now when you start working with pandas I
just love pandas for this reason look
how easy it is it just displays it as a
nice um uh spreadsheet for you you can
just look at it and view it very easily
uh it's also the same kind of view
you're going to get if you're working in
spark or P spark which is python for
spark across Big Data this is the kind
of thing that they they come up with
this is why pandas is so
powerful and we may look at this and
decide we don't like these columns and
so you can go in here and we can
actually rename the
columns simple command car equals car
rename uh columns equals engine
horsepower equals
horsepower this is just your standard
python
dictionary um so it just Maps them out
and you know instead of having like a
lengthy here we had um engine horsepower
we just want horsepower we don't need to
know it's the engine horsepower engine
cylinders we don't need to know that
it's for the engine because there's only
one thing we're just describing if we're
talking about cars and that
cylinders uh we'll go ahead and just run
this and again here's our car head and
you can see how that changed we have
model year and horsepower versus model
year engine horsepower engine cylinders
just
cylinders again we want to keep reducing
this so it's more and more readable the
more readable you get it the better um
and of course we can also adjust the
size a little bit so that when it prints
out instead of splitting it on two lines
we get like a single line we can do that
also that's just your control mouse up
or plus sign you use in Chrome that's a
chrome
command and if you remember from numpy
we had shape well pandas works the same
way uh we can look at the shape of the
data so we now have um
11,914 rows and 10 columns uh so you see
some similarities because pandas is
built on
numpy and questions that come up just
like you did in numpy we might want to
know duplicate rows and so we can do car
and look at this switch here um we're
doing a selection this is a panda
selection with the brackets but we want
to select it based on car. duplicated so
how many duplicates on
there so it's starting to look a little
bit different as far as how we access
some of the data on here this can be a
logical statement and we get the number
of duplicate rows we have 989 rows by 10
columns
again and this is one of those
troubleshooting things that we end up
doing uh a lot more than we really feel
like we should uh we might go ahead and
do like a car count uh just to see how
many rows we're dealing with and then
right after that we might want to go
ahead and say hey um let's drop
duplicates so remember we did all the
duplicates on there so car equals car.
drop duplicates and then we can print
the head again we'll just do car head
here and you can see the data on there
um looks the same as before
uh and just note that we did car equals
car draw
duplicates there are commands in here
where you can do where it changes the
actual value and it works on some of
them and not on others depending on what
you're doing but by default it always
returns a copy so when we do this we're
reassigning it to car and you can see
it's the same header but we want to go
ahead and do count and see how the count
changes let's go ahead and run this and
you can see here instead of 11914 we
have
10,925 uh so we've removed about 100
cars that were duplicated just slightly
under 100
there and then as we're prepping our
data we might want to know um car is
null uh so it's going to count the
values of null and then we want to sum
that up and when we do that uh we do the
car is null function. suum uh we end up
with uh HP the horsepower is 69 have
null values and 30 have cylinders have
null values now if you don't put the sum
at the end it's just going to return a
mask with the true false of is it null
or is it not by zero and one so you're
summing up the ones underneath each
column and this of course uh then you
have to decide what you're going to do
with the uh null values there's a lot of
different options it might be that you
need to put in the average or mean means
uh maybe you want to put in the median
value um there's a lot of different ways
to fill it usually when you first start
out with the data a lot of them you just
drop your null values and you can see
here car. drop na which is equal to all
and then we're going to go ahead and
count it and you can see that we've
dropped almost another 100 values so
from
10925 to
10827 maybe 75 or so values uh so we
cleaned the this is really a big part of
cleaning data you need need to know how
to get rid of your null values or at
least count them and what to do with
them and of course if we go back to um
uh counting our null values we should
now have uh null null values there we go
and you'll see there's zero null values
I don't know how many times I've been
running a model that doesn't take null
values and it crashes and I just sit
there and look at it trying to get why
did that crash it should have worked uh
it's because I forgot to remove the null
values so we've been jumping around a
lot we're going to go back to uh finding
outliers and let's go ahead and bring
that back into our Seaborn and if you
remember we did a box plot earlier uh
this time we're going to do a box plot
just on the price and you can see here
um our price value and we have the
deviation with the two thinner bars on
each side of the main value and then as
we get up here we have all these
outliers um in fact we have one way out
here that's um probably a really
expensive high-end car is what we're
looking at if you were doing um fraud
analysis you would be jumping on all
over these outliers why are these
deviation from the standard what are
these people doing again this is
probably like I said a really high-end
expensive car out here that's what we're
looking at and we can also look at the
um box plot for the
horsepower we'll put that in down
here and run that and you can see again
here's our horsepower and it just jumps
and there's these really odd huge muscle
cars out here here that are
outliers and we're going to jump into
making this a little bit more um as you
start displaying your data or your
information to your shareholders uh
we're going to look at plotting a
histogram for the number of cars per
brand and the first thing we want to go
ahead and do is we have with our car go
back over here here we go uh we have our
make value counts largest plot um and we
want to do a kind equals bar uh f size
105 and right off the bat we jump up
here we see Chevrolet it's going against
what was it it's um figure the value
counts and we want the largest value so
here's our value counts and compared to
what the different cars are Chevrolet
puts out a lot of different kinds of
cars I didn't realize that they made
that many cars or different types and
then for readability uh let's go ahead
and add a title number of cars by make
number of cars and make if you had
looked at this the first time you would
have been like well what the heck am I
looking at well we're looking at the
number of cars by make and then you can
see here now we're talking about the
type of cars and the different uh ones
were put out Lotus I guess only had a
few different kinds of cars over there
very high-end
cars and then as a doing data analytics
and as a data scientist one of the
things I am most interested in is the
relationship between the
variables uh so this is always a place
to start we want to know what's going on
with our variables and how they connect
with each other uh so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to go
ahead and set a figure size because we
want to make sure it fits our graph um
we'll just go ahead and set this one
plot Figure Set to figure size 2010 if
you never used the map plot Library
which is sitting behind Seaborn uh
whatever is in the PLT this is what's
loaded like a canvas you're painting on
so the second you load that uh pip plot
as PLT anything you do to that is
affecting everything on
it uh and then we want to go ahead uh
since we're using
caborn we'll go ahead and create a
variable C for uh relationships or
correspondence and car doc RR that's a
correlation in caborn on top of pandas
again one line and you get the whole
correlation on there and because we're
working with caborn let's put it into
nice heat map if you're not familiar
with heat maps that means we're just
using color as part of our um uh setup
so we have a nice
visual and we can see here that the
Seaborn connected to the pandas prints
out a nice chart we'll talk a little bit
about the color here in a second it
prints out a nice chart this is a chart
I look at as a data scientist these are
the numbers I want to look at uh and
we'll just highlight one of them um
here's cylinders versus horsepower the
closer to one the higher the correlation
so 788 pretty high correlation between
the number of cylinders and how heavy
the horsepower
is I'm betting if you looked at the year
versus uh horsepower we just look at
that one here's year and horsepower 314
not as so much but if you combine them
uh you don't actually add them but if
you combine them you'll start to see an
increase in Horsepower per year and
cylinders you could probably get a
correlation there and just like 78 is a
positive correlation uh you might notice
if we look at
cylinders and or let's look at
horsepower and mileage uh so if we go
here to horsepower to mileage you get a
nice um negative we'll do cylinders
that's a bigger number with cylinders to
the miles per gallon it's a minus. 6 so
it's a negative correlation the closer
to minus one the more the negative
correlation
is and then the chart you would actually
show people is a nice heat map this is
all our color and it's just those
numbers put into a heat map the darker
the color the higher the correlation you
can see straight down the middle um
obviously the year correlates directly
with the year horsepower with horsepower
and so on that's why it's a one the
closer to the one the higher the
correlation between the two pieces of
data now this is a good introduction uh
pandas goes Way Beyond this most the
functionality in numpy since Panda sits
on it is also in pandas and then it even
has additional features in it and we use
torn pretty extensively sitting on top
over our pip plot uh so keep in mind
that our pip plot has a ton of other
features in it that we didn't even touch
on in here uh we couldn't even if you
had a sole course in it uh there's just
so many things hidden in there depending
on what your domain you're working on uh
but you can see here here's our Seaborn
and here's our Matt plot Library that's
all our Graphics that we did and then
the Seaborn worked really nicely with
the pandas uh we really like that so
that wraps up our demo part for today
let's learn about data manipulation in R
and here we will learn about deer
package and when we talk about this deer
package it is much faster and much
easier to read than base R so deer
package is used to transform and
summarize tabular data with rows and
columns you might be working on a data
frame or you might be getting in a
inbuilt r data set which can then be
converted into a data frame so we can
get this package deer by just calling in
library function and this can be used
for grouping by data summarizing the
data adding new variables selecting
different set of columns filtering our
data sets sorting it selecting it
arranging it or even mutating that is
basically creating new columns using
functions on exist existing variables so
let's see how we work with deer now here
I can basically get the package here so
I can just say install. packages deer
now we already see the the package here
which is showing up so I will just
select this one I can do a control enter
and that will basically set up the
package package deer successfully
unpacked so that is done now you can
start using this package by just doing a
library deer and this was built it shows
me my version of R so let's also use a
inbuilt data set that is New York
flights 13 so we can do install.
packages and that will search and get
that relevant data set I can again Call
It by using Library function now once
that is done we can look at some sample
data here by just doing view flights and
that shows me the data in a neat and a
tabular format which shows me me year
month day departure time schedule
departure time and so on now we can also
do a head to look at some initial data
which can help us in understanding the
data better so what is this data about
how many columns we have what are the
data types or object types here it shows
me how many variables we have so this is
fine now we can start using deer and in
that we can use Save filter function if
we would want to look in for specific
value now here we have the column as
month so I will do a filter now I'm
creating a variable F1 I'm using the
filter function on flights which we
already
have and then what we can do is we can
basically look at the month where the
month value is
07 so let's look at that
and this one you can do a view on F1
which shows me the data wherein you have
filtered out all the data based on month
being seven so this is a simple usage of
filter we can take some other example we
may want to include multiple columns so
we can say F2 filter flights and here we
will say month is equal to 7 day is
three and then look at the value of FS2
if you are interested in seeing this
and that tells you the month is seven
and day is three you could also look
into a more readable format by using
view on F2 and that gives me my selected
result so we are just extracting in some
specific value we can keep extending
this so here we can say flights is what
we would want to work on I'm using the
filter function so I can straight away
instead of creating a variable then then
doing a view I can also do a view in
this way I can just pass in my filter
within the view and within this I'm
saying filter I would want to look at
the flights month being 09 day being two
and origin being
LGA and then that shows me the value
here and obviously you can scroll and
look at all the columns and if you see
the origin column it shows the selected
value so now we have filtered our our
data based on values in in three
different columns now what we can also
do is we can use and or we can use or
operators so I could have done this in a
a little different way so I could have
said head which shows me initial result
I will do a flight So within my head
function I'm passing in this and what
does that contain so you are saying
flights and in this flights data set you
would want to pick up the month being
the column so we use the dollar symbol
here we give in a value and I'll say and
and I'll again say flights wherein I
will select the day being two and and
and remember when you talk about and it
is going to check if all the values are
met true so then you say flight's origin
LGA and you look at the value so in this
way I can filter out specifically
multiple values by specifying columns
now we could have done it in this way we
could have created a view or we could
have assigned this to a variable and
then done a view on that where we could
have selected month being day and origin
or you can be more specific in
specifying all the columns it makes the
code more readable so let's look at the
values and here you are looking at head
which shows me based on month day and
then you get we can look for further
columns for other variables that is
origin being LGA now what we can also do
is we can do some slicing here to select
rows by particular position so I can say
slice and I would want to look at rows
one to five and I can do this so you can
always assign or look at the view of
this I can just do here so when I did a
slide 1 is to 5 it shows me my entries
for 1 to five now similarly we can do a
slice 5 to 10 and now you're looking at
5 to 10 values so you can always look at
the complete data and then you can slice
out particular data now mutate is
usually a function which is used when
you would want to apply some variable on
a particular data set
and then you would want to add it to
your existing data frame or you would
want to add a new column so this is
where you use mutate which is mainly
used to add new variables so let's see
how you you work on mutate so it's
pretty simple so you create a variable
over delay now I would want to do a
mutate so that it adds a new column so
I'm selecting my data which is flights I
will call the new column as over all
delay and then
basically I can look at overall delay
being arrival delay minus departure
DeLay So let's create this and let's
look at view of this which shows me or
which should show me my new column which
is overall delay which was not in my
original data set so you can anytime do
a head on this one to compare the value
so this one shows me arrival delay and
then there are many other other
variables what you can also do is you
can do a view and you could have just
look at flights if you would want to
compare so you can look at the flights
and this one would not have any overall
delay column so it basically shows me 19
columns only what we see here and if
you do a view on overall delay then that
basically shows me 20 column so we know
that the new column has been added to
this overall DeLay So if you would want
to work with 20 columns you will use
overall delay if you would want to work
with your original data set you will use
flights now you can also use a transmute
function which is used to show only the
new column so we can do a overall delay
and at this time we will say transmute
we will say flights overall delay the
computation remains same but at this
time if I look at view on overall delay
it only shows me the new column so
sometimes we may want to compute result
based on two variables or two columns
and just look at the new value and then
we can decide if we would want to add it
to our existing structure now you can
also use summarize and summarize
basically helps us in getting a
summary based on certain criteria so we
can always do a
summarize and what we can do is we can
look at our data and we can say on what
basis we would want to summarize this
particular data so we can do a summarize
function now summarize on flights I will
say average a time and I would want to
calculate an average so for that I'm
using inbu function called mean I will
do that on airtime
column so let's look at flights once
again and here we can see there is
arrival time not air time sorry arrival
time and we would want to do some
average on this particular data we would
want to summarize this so what I'll do
is I will use the summarize function I
will say average air time and this one I
will look at mean of air time so let's
see if there is a air time column I
might be let's look at this one and I
will delay and yes we have an air time
so we were actually looking at
summarizing based on air time not the
arrival time so air time is how much
time it takes in air for this particular
fight and we will want to use the trans
summarize function not the transmute so
summarize flights average air time and
this one we will calculate the mean of
average air time and I will also do a na
removal which is I'm saying true so
let's do this and that basically shows
me the average air time is
151 I can also do a total air time where
I'm doing a summation of values or I can
get the standard deviation or I can
basically get multiple values such as
mean I can say total air time where I'm
doing a summation and then I can look at
other values which is if you would want
to put in standard deviation here you
could do that so let's look at the
result of this summarize and this
basically allows me to get some useful
information which is summarized based on
a particular function such as mean sum
standard deviation or all three of them
now let's look at grouping by so
sometimes we may be interested in
summarizing the data by groups and
that's where we use the group by
function so we can always
use the group by Clause now here we are
taking a different data set so we will
say for example let's look at head of
empty cars and that is basically my data
set on empty cars now that shows me the
model of the car it shows me mileage
cylinder P this and your horsepower and
various other characteristics or
variables in this particular data set so
here we can say let's do a grouping by
gear so there is a column called gear so
I will call it by gear I will look at my
data set and then what I'm using here
which you see with these percentage and
greater symbol is called piping so that
basically feeds your previous data frame
into next one so this is sometimes
useful and you can get this by just
saying control shift and M and and you
can then use this so we are going to
have piping so I'm saying empty cars now
this is my original data set where I did
a head or I could have done a view on
this one if you would want to see it in
a more readable format and that
basically shows me the data so we are
using a different data set so I want to
group it by the gear column so I'm going
to call it by gear and this one takes my
data that is empty card I'm using the
piping and then I'm saying group the
data based on gear column that's done
now let's look at the value of by gear
or you can always do a view so remember
whenever you're doing a group by it is
giving you a internal object where your
data is grouped based on a particular
column so we can look at the values here
you can do a view that shows you your
data grouped based on a particular
column now I can again use the
summarized function where I would want
to Now work on the new one where it was
grouped based on gear so I'm doing a
summarize and here I'm going to say gear
one which will be having the value of
summation on the gear column and then
I'm saying Gear 2 which is mean well you
could give some meaningful names to this
and let's look at the value of this one
where we are basically now looking at
the values which is sum and mean values
based on the
gear similarly we can use look at
different example so we can say by gear
and I'm again using
piping but earlier we had taken gear we
had grouped the data and we called it by
gear so we took our original data set Mt
cars but now within this particular data
which was grouped by gar I will take
this this data set I will use the piping
and I will summarize it where I am
saying within this particular data set I
would want to get the sum or I would
want to get the mean and then you can
look at the values so what you're doing
is you are either looking at your
original data set or you're looking at
the data which was already grouped and
then you can look at the values now here
what we can do is we can Group by
cylinder say might be you are interested
in looking at data which is summarized
based on the cylinder column you can do
that and then for this by cylinder I'm
doing a piping where I'm using the
summarize function and summarizing will
then be done based on the mean values of
the gear column or the horsepower so
let's do this and then you can basically
look at the value at any point you may
want to look at the data set again so
just do ahead
and you can look at what does the value
contain and by cylinder or by gear and
do AE and it gives you the value so you
can always do some summarizing or
grouping in these ways now here we are
going to use sample uncore n function
and Sample
underscore fraction for creating samples
so for this let's take the flights data
set again and and we would want to get
15 random values now that is done and it
shows me 15 rows with some random values
from the data what you can also do is
you can do a portion of data by using
sample underscore fraction and here I'll
say flights I'll say 0 4 which will
return 40% of the total data so this can
be useful when you are building your
machine learning where you would want to
split your data into training and test
might be you are interested in some
portion of the data so you can do this
which is very useful function and then
you can look at the value of that
now what we can also do is we can use AR
range function so like we were doing a
grouping by or we were trying to pull
out a particular column so in the same
way we can use AR range which is a
convenient way of sorting than your base
are sorting so for rrange function
let's do a view based on arrange so we
will work on the flights data set which
we have and here what we would want to
do is we would want to arrange the
flights data set which is based on ear
and departure time and we are doing a
view out of it so that basically gives
me the data which is arranged based on
your year and departure time now I can
do a head to give me some highlighting
of that data now the piping operator
what we are using can be used in these
ways also so here I will say DF I will
just assign the data set Mt cars to it
let's look at the DF which has basically
your different models you can obviously
look at the head or view of it to look
at useful information we can also go for
nesting options which can be useful so
we are creating a variable called result
here now that has the arrange function
so what does this arrange function do so
when we would want to use arrange to
sort the data so I would want to sort
the data but what data would I sort so I
will use sample n which will give me
some portion of the data or some sample
data now what is that sample data so
here we are using nesting that is a
earlier when we did a sample we just
said data and how many random samples we
want but instead of giving that what we
are going to do is we are going to use
filter here now this filter will work on
DF so filtering will happen based on the
mileage which is greater than 20 I will
say size is five and I would want to
basically arrange this in a descending
order so I'm using the desk on this
particular mileage column by default it
is always ascending so let's get the
result out of this which will basically
show me the mileage details in a
descending order so this is my data
frame and now we can look at the result
what we have created so just do a view
or do a head and look at the view so
here you see mileage where the highest
value is on the top
and we were only interested in five
values in a random sample so that's why
when you did a view it shows your five
values and it shows in a descending
order based on mileage so we have not
only used an inbuilt function we have
not only arranged the data that is we
have sorted the data but we have sorted
the data based on a descending order on
a particular column we have said the
value should be greater than 20 and we
have also said we just need five random
samples now let's look at some other
examples so you can always do a multi
assignment so I can say filter wherein
I'm going to use DF which was assigned
empty cars I'm going to say mileage
should be greater than 20 then I say B
which is going to get a sample out of a
and I just want five random values so so
let's look at that so we have B which is
going to get a set of five values from a
now I will create a result variable
which will arrange B which is sample
data in a descending order now let's
look at the result of this and that
basically shows me what we were seeing
earlier so you can do a multi-
assignment where you can create a
variable get a sample out of it and then
basically whatever is that result you
can change that or sort that in a
descending or by default descending
order so same thing we can do it using
pipe operator so piping so here I will
say result I'm passing in my DF that's
the data set I'm using piping and which
basically tells what you need to do on
this particular data set so I'm going to
filter out the data based on mileage 50
sorry mileage 20 then I'm going to push
that or forward it to to get the random
sample and whatever is this random
sample is going to be pushed so you are
arranging this in a descending order so
this is one more way of doing it and
then basically you can look at the
result so these are some simple examples
where you can use your deer with
multiple assignments or using your
nesting to filter out the data you can
also do a a range which is to sort the
data you can get some random samples out
of it you can SU sumarize the data you
can also summarize the data based on one
or two or multiple columns and you can
use some inbuilt functions to summarize
the data based on some functions which
are applied on the variables or on the
columns you can transmute it where you
would be interested in only looking at
one column you can mutate it where you
want to add a new column you can slice
it and you can give the condition where
you can say and or or to filter out the
data so what we can also do is on this
particular data set which we have say
for example DF where I have my data
let's look at this one and if I just do
a DF at this point it shows me my data
set and if you would be interested only
in particular column then your deer also
allows you to either we can do a filter
or we can simply do a select SE now for
selecting we can
choose uh our data so for example I'll
say DF underscore I'm interested in
mileage I'm interested in Horsepower
might be I'm interested in your
cylinders in this and for this one what
I can do is when I would want to do a
select I can basically say selected DF
let's call it some name I can say crol
shift M which is for piping and then
basically what you can do is you can do
a select and you can choose your columns
so I was interested in mileage I was
interested in
Horsepower I was interested in cylinder
and here what I'm doing is I'm using a
select where I can look at the new data
frame so let's do this and
uh I'm sorry here we will have to give
it DF this is where you are passing in
your data yeah now this one is done and
we can look at the value of this one by
just doing a DF or head on
DF uncore mileage horsepower cylinder
and look at the selected result so you
can be looking at selective columns I
could have done this filter but filter
will always look for a condition say
your mileage is greater than 20 or might
be your cylinders are more than four or
something else but when you do a select
you are selecting specific columns so
view always gives you all the columns
head gives you highlight but then select
can be useful when we are interested in
looking at only specific data so this is
how you can use deer for manipulation
for your data transformation for
basically filtering out the data by
selecting particular data and then
working on it so similarly there is one
more package called tidd and we'll see
how we can use data manipulation done
using your tidd package Let's uh learn
about the tid package it makes it easy
to tidy your data and this basically
helps you creating a more cleaner data
so which is easy to visualize and model
now this comes with the mainly four
functions so you have gather which makes
your data wide or it makes wide data
longer so that is basically used to
stack up multiple columns you have
spread function which makes long data
wider that is stacking the data together
or stack if you would want to unstack
the data to data and you are talking
data which has same attributes and then
your spread can spread the data across
multiple columns you have separate which
is function which splits single column
into multiple columns and to complement
that you have one more function which is
unite and that combines multiple columns
into single columns so these are four
main functions which are used in your
tidd R packet so let's look how we work
with this so let me bring up my r Studio
here now for this first is let me just
clean up my screen here doing a contr l
so I will install the package it is
already installed but we can just do a
control enter and then I can say do you
want to restart R prior to reinstall to
install I'll say
okay and it is basically going to get
the
package now it says package T TI yr that
is IDR has been successfully unpacked
let's use that package with using our
library
function and that was built under R
version
3.6 now I can basically start using
these functions so for example here we
are creating a data frame so let's say n
is
10 and then we basically would say we
will call it wide now that's the
variable name I'm using the data. frame
function I'm saying ID which will be 1
to n so that will take the values from 1
to 10 and then these are the values
which
have 10 entries so this is a vector
Phase 1 Phase 2 phase three let's create
a data frame out of it now that's done
we can have a look at our data frame by
just doing a view wide and that shows me
the ID column and it has ph. one ph. 2
and ph. 3 now we can use our function so
for example we can work with gather that
is reshaping the data from wide format
to Long format and basically you can say
stacking up multiple columns so let's
see how we do that here I'll call it
long I'm working on wide I'm using the
piping functionality and then I'm using
gather so this one I will say what will
be the data which I will use so we are
using wide as a data frame then I'm
saying response time so that will be
basically
one more column and then you have your
columns which you would want to
basically stack so I'm saying from face
one to phase three so let's do this and
once this is done let's have a look at
our variable long so this one shows me
that I have an ID column I have the
response time column and I have the face
column which we mentioned and that
basically has all the values stacked in
so you have ph. one pH do2 and ph. 3 so
have all the columns are being stacked
here so all my data so now I have
totally 30 entries in this one so this
is basically using your gather function
now sometimes we may want to use a
separate function now separate function
is basically splitting a single column
into multiple columns so which we would
want to use when multiple variables are
captured in a single variable column
okay so let's look at an example of this
one so let's say long separate that's
what we will call we will work on this
long which has all the data stacked in
as the columns we selected then I'm
saying separate I want the face column
and then I would say when I separate the
columns what are my column names now I
could also give a separator by giving a
comma and then mentioning the separator
if that is required so let's do this now
once this is done let's have a look at
our long separate so what we see here is
the column which we used so we were
doing a face column and that was to be
split and we wanted to split it into
Target and number so that's what we see
here so you have face being split into
Target and number and then you have the
response time so this is how you use the
separate function now there is also
something called as unite function which
is basically a complimenting of of
separate function so it takes multiple
columns and combines the elements to a
single column so for example here we
will call it long unite and we will take
long separate which was separating the
data we want to unite so we will take
phase Target number and we want to have
a separator between them so let's
basically do this and now let's look at
the result of this unite so you see you
have the face and Target merge together
so you have face dot one the separator
is dot as we have mentioned and we have
United multiple columns so this is one
more function of your tidd which helps
you basically uh tidy up your data or
put it in a particular way now then you
have your spread function and this is
basically for unstacking so that is if
you have if you would want to convert a
stack to data or if you would want to
unstack the data which is of same
attributes spread can be used so that
you can spread the data across multiple
columns so it will take two columns say
key and value and spread it into
multiple columns so it makes long data
wider so we can look at this one we will
say long unite I'm using the piping I
will use the spread function I'll work
on the face column and response time and
let's do this and and then let's do a
view on this so it tells me our data is
back in the shape as it was in the
beginning so these are four functions
which are very helpful when we work with
tid our package if you're are a
professional with minimum one year of
experience and an aspiring data analyst
looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities in collaboration with
leading experts to enhance your
credibility then search no more simply
Lars postgraduate program and data
analytics offered by P University in
collaboration with IBM is just what you
need for more details head straight to
our homepage or simply click on the link
in the description box below now without
further delay over to our training so
let's learn about
visualization and here we will learn
about R which can be used for your
visualization now one thing we which we
need to understand is because of our
ability to see patterns which is highly
developed we can understand the data
better if we can visualize it so the
efficient way or effective way to
understand what is in our data or what
we have understood in our data we should
or we can use graphical displays that is
your data visualization so there are
actually two types of data
visualizations so you have exploratory
data visualization which helps us to
understand the data and then you have
explanatory visualization which helps us
to share our understanding with others
so when you talk about r r provides
various tools and packages to create
data
visualizations and which can be used for
both kind of data analysis or both kind
of visualizations so when you talk about
exploratory data visualization the key
is to keep all the potentially relevant
details together now the objective when
we talk about explor data analysis is to
help you see what is in your data and
the main question is how much details
can we
interpret now when you talk about
different functions which we see here
such as plot which is more for a generic
uh plotting you have bar plot which is
is used to plot data using rectangular
bars or you can say creating bar charts
you have histogram or hist function to
create histograms where you look at the
frequency of uh the data or basically
used to look at the central tendency of
the data you have box plot which is used
to represent data in the form of
quartiles you have ggplot which is a
package which enables the user to create
sophisticated visualizations with the
little code using the grammar of
graphics and then you have plotly or
plot ly it creates interactive webbased
graphs via the open-source JavaScript
graphing library now before we see some
examples here let's also talk about when
you talk about plotting let's also try
to understand what kind of plots you can
have and what kind of techniques you
have so let me open up my R Studio here
now for example I can pull out a
particular data set and let's look at
this one so here I can look at all the
panes and that shows me the information
now what I can do is I can
install and get the inbuilt data sets
and then I can simply do a plot wherein
I am doing a plot on chiwa data set so
let's see what does that show it
summarizes the relationship between four
variables in chick weight data frame
which is in ours buil-in data set
package now from these plots we can see
for example weight VAR is systematically
over time you can also see that chicks
were assigned to four different diets
now when we talk about explanatory data
analysis or visualization that shows
others what we found in the data this
means we need to make some editorial
decisions what features we would want to
highlight for
emphasis what features are distracting
or confusing and you want them to be
eliminated right so there are different
ways of doing it now when you talk about
your graphics or visualizations you have
I would say three different types or you
can say four so you have the base
Graphics which is easiest to learn now
here we are having an example of Base
Graphics where I can use the base
Graphics I can get a um data set using
library then I can simply create using
plot function to a generate a simple
scatter plot of calories with sugar from
us serial data frame in the mass package
and then I can give it a title so this
is basically a simple example of Base
Graphics now you also have what we call
as grid graphicss which is powerful set
of modules for building other tools now
you also have latest Graphics which is
general purpose system based on grid
graphics and then you have your GG plot
2 which implements grammar of graphics
and is based on grid Graphics so you
have different ways now here since I
already have used library and I have the
data set I can just do a x so I can
assign the sugar related values to X and
calories related value to Y then I can
use one more which is Library function
and calling in Grid now I can basically
use functions such as push view Port if
I would want to create a plot using your
grid Graphics to create the similar kind
of plot which we created using base
Graphics but this will give you much
more power than base Graphics it will
have uh a steep learning curve but it is
usually useful so I can do this where
I'm saying push view Port then I can
basically say I would want to have a
data view Port I would say different
functions of your grid package so I'm
saying rectangle you have xaxis y axis
given some points here and then
basically you can add details to the
graph by giving the names to the columns
and you can basically create a simple
grid Graphics based plot here now there
are different other options which we can
use to create plots now before we go
into understanding how you create plots
let me just give you a brief on what are
the different kind of plots and how they
can be used so here we will look at
these different plots now for example we
have a bar chart which is a graph which
shows comparisons across discrete
categories so you have x-axis which will
show the categories being compared and Y
AIS which represents a measured value
and height of the bars are proportional
to measured values Now to create
different kind of charts you can use
ggplot which is a package for creating
graphs in R it is basically method of
thinking about and decomposing complex
graphs into logical subunits and that is
a part of Tidy worse ecosystem system so
it takes each component of graph aises
you can give scales you can give colors
you can give the objects and you can
build graphs on particular data you can
modify each of those components in a way
that's more flexible and user friendly
you can if you are not providing details
for the components then ggplot will use
sensible defaults and this basically
makes it a powerful and a flexible tool
now here are different options when you
use your GG plot such as you can use Gom
or what we call as geometry objects to
form the basis of different type of
graphs for bar charts you have for line
graphs you have Scatter Plots that is
underscore point you have underscore box
plot for box plots you have quartile for
continuous X wlin for richer display of
distribution and Jitter for small data
so here is some simple example where I
would not go into too many details here
but you can just have a look at this one
where we are using Library function to
get the ggplot to package then basically
we would want to look into the mileage
data we would want to look at the
structure of it and then we can
basically get the Tidy worse package
finally we can create a bar chart using
gomore bar and we can basically also
mention what would be in x-axis now you
can also give different colors to
basically add more meaning to your data
you could also go for stacked bar charts
so here we are actually telling GG plot
to map the data in the drive column to
fill the aesthetic so here I am giving
aesthetic exess class and I'm saying
what is the data we need to have and
then we are using gomore bar so you can
also have dodged bar
in your GG plot that is not bar charts
which are stacked but next to each other
and you can create that by using your
position as position _ Dodge okay now
you can obviously use your different
packages which are inbuilt and you can
create your bar charts and you have
other kind of graphs such as line graph
which is basically a type of graph that
displays information as a series of data
points connected by by straight line
segments such as this one and for this
one we are using if you see gomore line
now you can also create a scatter plot
which is a
two-dimensional data visualization that
uses points to graph the values of two
different variables one in on x axis one
on Y axis like what we saw in base
Graphics example and they are mainly
used if you would want to assess the
relationship or lack of relationship
between two variables and you also have
histogram which I mentioned is mainly to
look at the distribution of a data to
look at the central tendency of the data
basically looking at your um large
amount of data or for a single variable
you would be interested in saying where
is more data found in terms of frequency
where is lesser data found in the graph
how close the data is towards its uh
midpoint or what we call as mean median
mode so you can use histogram where you
can categorize the data in what we call
as bins so these are some Basics on
different kind of graphs now we can look
at some examples and see how that works
so what we were seeing is some quick
examples of Base Graphics or grid
Graphics now here let's do an example of
pie chart for different products and
units sold so you want to create a graph
for this first let's create a vector and
pass in the value here now I can also
create labels which I would want to
assign to these values and then
basically I can plot the chart by saying
Pi so that's the kind of chart which I
would want to create and I would say the
data would be X and labels so let's do
this and that shows me a simple pie
chart now I can also give main details
here so instead of just doing a pi x
comma labels I can say what is the main
and then what kind of coloring it should
follow so this is the way you can create
a
simple uh plot now I can also find out
what is the
percentage and then basically I would be
interested in plotting the pie chart
which takes X which takes the labels
which will be the percentage which we
are calculating here by doing a round
function and then you can basically give
details to your graph you can say what
color it follows you can basically look
at the legend where it needs to be in
your
chart what are the values and then
basically fill up the colors so let's
run this one and that shows me the
percentage which was calculated and it
gives me the details and we can always
have a look at our plot now if you would
want to go for a 3D pie chart then you
can get
the package which is plot Trix let's use
that by calling in the library function
let's pass in some data to X and let's
give some values or labels which will
make more meaning to the data and then
let's plot the 3D graph so I'm saying Pi
3D here where I'm using X and labels
then I'm basically doing an explode
which will basically control how your
graph looks like and basically give the
values so it also takes the title when
you say Main and P chart of countries
now let's create data for graph so again
we are having a variable here we are
create using the C function creating a
vector and then let's create a histogram
for this one where I would say xlab what
would be your data around x-axis what is
the color what is the border and here
I'm creating a simple histogram which as
I discussed earlier will always show
your values on the x axis and y AIS is
more of frequency and then you can look
at the set of values and what is their
frequency and we can basically use this
histogram for exploratory data analysis
look at the data try to understand what
is the central tendency of your data
values now we can also give some limits
by using the X limb and Y Lim and then I
can also Al specify what is the limit so
we have given some values here wherein
we have said your X limit is 0 to 40 and
Y limit is 0 to 5 now if you compare
this with the previous one which we had
created this one based on the frequency
had taken the limits but we can assign
limits explicitly by giving this and
then create a histogram which makes more
meaning now let's take another data set
that is air quality let's view this to
see what does that data contain so you
have ozone solar wind temperature month
and the day so this is the kind of
information we have in the air quality
now let's use the plot function to draw
a scatter plot where as I mentioned you
would be interested in analyzing
variables and see what is the
relationship between them so to plot a
graph between ozone and wind values so
we will say plot we will say the data
which is air quality from that I would
be interested in the ozone column or
ozone field and the wind field I can
create a plot based on this now I can
also be saying what should be the color
what is the type of the data which you
would want to create and you can look at
the in information so you can create a
histogram you can create a a scatter
plot to basically understand the data
better and and then infer some
information from that data so let's take
the air quality data set itself without
specifying any particular column and you
can create a plot which shows me all the
different values which you have in the
data and it basically shows you the
difference this is more of an example
like what we did for chick weight where
we did a base Graphics now you can
assign labels to the plot so that is
when you are creating a plot you can say
air quality you will say ozone and then
that's your ozone concentration you have
your ylab which is the number of
instances you have what is the title
ozone levels in New York City what is
the color so these are the details what
we have given with our plot function and
let's look at the data so it just tells
me that this is the ozone
concentration uh the number of instances
what you have and you looking at the
data now we could also create a
histogram by picking up a particular
column that is such as solar from your
air quality and that basically shows me
the frequency of solar values and we can
then try to find out what is the mid
what is the mean what is the standard
deviation and so on you can also look at
your histogram and try to understand if
it is left skewed and right skewed so we
can do that now here let's get the
temperature out from this particular
data set let's create a histogram on
temperature and that basically shows me
the frequency of the temperature values
and what values have the most frequency
or most occurrence now you can create a
histogram with
labels so let's do that with the limit
and then let's also use text to
basically given the values which also
takes the values and for each set of
frequency or each set of values it gives
me the labels now you can have a
histogram with nonuniform width so you
could do that by doing a hist function
and then passing in your temperature you
can say what will be the main what is
the title what will be your
xlab it will tell you a limit around
x-axis what is the color what is the
Border what are the brakes you would
want to have for your bars and you can
simply create a histogram using this so
This basically takes the breakes which
we have given such as 55 to 60 60 to 70
70 to 75 and so on so this is basically
creating a histogram with non-uniform
width and it purely depends on the kind
of values what you have now you can also
create a box plot which sometimes helps
us in understanding the the data
quartiles also understanding our
outliers so you can create multiple box
plots based on the data from air quality
so we'll select all the data and then
we'll do some slicing on the data so
let's create a box plot which tells me
the values and if you look at these
points here like single dots these are
basically your outliers we can learn
about that more in later sections so you
can use your GG plot 2 Library to
analyze a particular data set so for
that we will first use the install.
packages and get ggplot
2 so it says do you want to restart R
and I can say yes so let it get the
package I think the package was already
there and now let's look at using ggplot
2 so for that I have the library
function and let's do a attach where I'm
getting the data set which is empty cars
now then I will create a variable P1 I
will use ggplot I will pass in my data
I'll give the Aesthetics what is the
columns which you would be interested in
and then you are using gomore boxplot to
basically create a plot which gives me
the box plot for the values here and
this is based on the cylinders which is
there in your data
so we can always look at what does our
data contain and what kind of values or
features are available in the data now
let's create a box plot we will also use
the coordinate function and that
basically gives me based on the data so
I've changed the coordinates now if you
look at the previous one where we
created a plot we had mileage on the Y
AIS and cylinders on the
xaxis now I did coordinate flip and
that's like your transpose function so
you have created the box plot but you
have just flipped the coordinates you
can create a box plot and then say fill
which is the factor of cylinder so that
can be used to fill up the values in
your box plot now what we can also do is
we can create factors so we have learned
about factors earlier which is usually
used to work on categorical variables so
here let's create a factor which is
empty cars gear you have am you have
cylinder and if you look at the factors
which we have created we have passed our
data what is the field or the column we
are interested in what is the level of
values there and what are the labels for
those values right so we have learned
about factors you can always look into
the previous section and learn more
about factors now let's create a a
scatter plot by using the GG plot
function again we will use the data as
empty cars I will go for mapping option
and then I will give my Aesthetics that
is what would be x what would be your Y
and you also would want to use what kind
of function you are using so let's go
for gome point point and that basically
helps me in creating a scatter plot now
you can create a scatter plot by factors
so here we will say GG plot so notice in
all of these cases depending on the kind
of data you have depending on the kind
of plot you are interested in you will
use the GG plot and then basically a
function with that or the inbuilt
package so here I'm saying data is empty
cars I'm going for mapping which
basically will take the values for your
X and Y what is the color and the
coloring will be done based on the
factor values now if you remember
factors will obviously have some levels
and uh those levels will basically help
you in differentiating between your
categorical variables so I'm saying as.
Factor on cylinder and then I'm using
geome point to basically create this
scatter plot so let's do this and I can
look at the values of this one so it
says must be there is an error which
says must at least one color from the
hue
pallet so let's look at that one so the
error which we were facing when we gave
color as the factor values was because
when you look at these factors which
were created with some labels if we look
at the values of these it tells me there
are any values in that particular column
similarly your gar or similarly you can
completely look at the complete data set
it tells me cylinder you have am you
have gear now these have some we have
created some labels but these have any
values so what we can do is we can
create a scatter plot as we did earlier
by giving the Aesthetics and that's a
simple scatter plot wherein I'm also
using geom point so that I can have
these points by defaults or with
defaults you can also give a color
specific basically if you would want to
have different kind of data in the same
plot or I can create Scatter Plots by
different sizes by giving a size or I
can give a color and size and that's
again one way in which you can create
your Scatter Plots now let's also see
how you can visualize one more data set
which is
MPG so I can also do it in this way
where I said GG plot 2 and then pass in
look at the data set what we have here
you can just do a view on this to see
what my data contains if the field have
any na values if that's going to affect
your plotting so now what we can do is
we can create a bar plot or a bar chart
so I'm saying ggplot the data would be
as we have given in previous lines that
is ggplot to MPG then I will say what
should be in my Aesthetics and what kind
of chart are you going to create so I'm
saying gomore bar so that's my bar chart
and that has basically your CL pass and
count now you can create a stacked bar
chart where your information is stacked
in the same bars and we are still using
the same data we are going for
Aesthetics which is class and then when
you say geome bar which creates your
stack bar we will use fill which is
drive and we can always go back and look
at our data for example you can always
look into this so you have the drive
column here and you are also working on
this complete data set so let's go ahead
and create a stacked bar chart and that
basically gives me the information where
you have the drive information which is
stacked here now you can do a Dodge by
giving the position as Dodge so we are
still going to go for a stack chart but
this time the bars will be next to each
other and that can also be done which is
very useful you can use this by using
Gom point where you are mapping and you
specifying what are your Aesthetics so
we were creating a scatter plot now you
can also use or give more details where
you can say color can be based on the
class and we have different classes and
based on that my points have been
colored now you can also use a plot ly
or plotly Library so let's install this
one I will say yes for example let it
basically restart so that all my
packages are
updated then I can access that package
using Library function and then create a
variable to which you are assigning your
plot unor ly plot so data is empty cars
what will be your xais what will be your
y AIS and details on your marker which
we have given wherein I will give a list
which is size color which is a
combination and then you have your line
what kind of color it will have and what
will be the width so this is where I'm
going to use plot
ly and let's look at this
plot so it basically gives me some
information now we see some warnings
which are getting generated but there is
you don't need to worry about that so
you can look at the packages what you
have and what options you're using so
similarly we can create one more plot
using plot l Y and look at the values of
those so that's a plot with a trend
which explains me about my data so this
is a simple small tutorial on
understanding or uh how you can have
your graphics or
visualization used to understand your
data obviously there are much more
examples much more ways in which you can
pass into your plot functions or your GG
plot and the inbuilt packages which are
available in R for your visualization
now that could be for explorate data
analysis or explanat data analysis so
try these graphs and see if you can
change these options and try or create
new
visualizations good morning and good
evening everyone so welcome to this
session where we will learn on time
series analysis using our programming
language so this is basically a a mini
project where we will look at time
series data and how we can analyze it
visualize it to basically find some
important information or gather insights
from the data now when you talk about
time series analysis time series is
basically any data set where your values
are measured at different points in time
so when you talk about time series data
data is usually uni formly spaced at a
specific frequency for example hourly
weather measurements you have daily
counts of website visits monthly sales
total and so on so when you talk about
time series that can also be irregularly
spaced and sporadic for example time
stamp data in computer systems event log
or history of 911 emergency calls now
when we work with time series data for
example here I'm taking a energy data
set said we can see how techniques such
as time based indexing resampling
rolling windows can help us explore
variations in electricity demand and
renewable energy Supply over time now
here we will look at some aspects of
this data set which I'm considering so
there is this is open Power Systems data
set and here is the data set I have we
can look at the data set now this is in
a simple format it has time it basically
has values for consumption and then you
have data for wind and solar and wind
plus solar so in certain cases you have
only the date and the consumption but
then if we scroll down we will also find
data for wind solar wind plus solar and
so on so this is a Time series data set
which we would want to work on sometimes
you may also have the data collected
which just does not have the time but it
may also have time stamp that is it
would have say hour minutes and seconds
and that can also be worked upon so
let's consider this data set and let's
work on this project where we will
Analyze This Time series data set now
here we can work on this time series
data we can basically create some data
structures out of it such as data frames
we can do some time based indexing we
can visualize the data we can look at
the seasonality in the data look at some
frequencies and also do some Trend
detection now when you talk about this
data set it has electricity production
and consumption which is reported as
daily totals in gigawatt hours and here
are The Columns of the data which I was
just showing you so you have data you
have consumption you have wind you have
solar and wind plus solar so this is the
data we have and we will will basically
explore say electricity consumption and
production in Germany which has varied
over time so some of the questions which
we can answer here is when is
electricity consumption typically
highest and lowest how do wind and solar
power production vary with seasons of
the year what are the long-term trends
in electricity consumption solar power
and wind power how do wind and solar
power production compare with
electricity consumption and how has this
ratio changed over time we can also do
wrangling or cleaning of this data or
pre-processing of data and create a data
frame and then we can visualize this now
let's see how do we do that so I will
open up my R studio and let's look at
the data set so here is the data set now
I'm picking it up from my machine you
can also pick it up from GitHub so all
the data sets or similar data sets can
be find in my GitHub repository and here
I can look in the data sets you will
find lot of different data sets here
there are some time series data sets
such as power I can search for power or
you have basically
coal or you have
this
opsd Germany daily data set and there
are many other data sets which you can
work on now to get the documentation on
this project you can also look in my
GitHub repository and you can search for
repositories and then basically you can
look in data science and R and here
there is a project folder where I've
given the documentation sample data set
and also your time series analysis
related document this is also the code
which you can directly Import in your R
studio and you can practice or work on
this project so let's see how does that
work so first thing is we will create a
data frame from this data set now here
if you see I using header as true so
that it understands the heading of each
column I'm also giving row. names and
I'm specifying date so there is this
date column in the data set as I showed
you earlier let's look at it again so
you have date consumption wind solar
wind plus solar so you can suggest that
date should become the index column
which can be useful so you can do this
now let's just create this let's look at
what does this data frame contain and
here if you see it shows me some data
which has
being now as a part of this data frame
structure it starts with consumption
wind solar wind plus solar and if you
see this one is becoming my index column
so I can always do a head and look at
part of the data frame using head or
tail so look at the first records so
let's see this now that shows me the
head data I can also do a tail and look
at the ending values so if you closely
see here we have wind solar wind do
solar and that basically has na values
so there are missing values but let's
look at the tail and that tells me that
there is some data available for wind
and solar and wind solar now we can
always look in a tabular format using
View and we can look at the data so this
shows me that there are values in these
columns we see na values but if I really
scroll down I can see some values which
would be available for wind and solar
and wind solar so I can just use view
now I can look at the dimensions of this
particular object and that tells me that
there are 400 uh
4,384 rows and four columns you can
always look at the structure that is
check the data type of each column which
can be very useful so if I see here I
don't see the date column because date
column was considered as an index which
can be useful but I also look at my
other columns they are of the num types
so that's the data type for each
attribute or each column here now we
would be interested in looking at this
date column so let's look at the data
type of this date column now if I try to
do this this will show me that this is
null because date as a column does not
exist because we created it as an index
so if I look at row names and then I
search for my data show me the index
column or row. names it tells me these
are the values that's the date column
which we are seeing here now we can
access a specific row by just doing a my
data and give the index value or row
name value so let's look at that and
that shows me based on this index you're
looking at the value you can obviously
search for a different date something
like this you can also pass in a vector
and you can give range of values so that
is
01 2006 to 4 of January and we can look
at this one so it shows me these are the
values so here actually I'm not giving a
range but I'm just selecting multiple
values from row. names now we already
know that in R you have a summary
function so you can always do a summary
and that gives you for each column it
gives you minimum first quartile median
mean third quartile and maximum values
so we are looking at consumption we are
looking at wind solar and wind. solar
now this is good but then if I would
want to really visualize the data access
the data do some analysis then it would
be good to take all the columns and then
we can later decide to change the data
type of say date column if we want to
use it so earlier I was using date as
row. names or the name of the rows or
index what you call in any other
programming language so here I will just
use my data set and I'll say header is
true I'm calling it my data 2 let's look
at the data and this one shows me five
columns where in My First Column is the
date consumption wind solar and so on
now looking at the structure so let's
look at the data type so it tells me
that if now I'm interested in looking at
the date column from my data two data
frame it tells me it is a factor with 4
384 levels and these are the values so
it is not in a datetime format it's a
factor now what we can do is we can
convert this into a date format how do
we do that so let's have a variable X
and I'm going to use as. date function
and I'm going to pass in my date column
so that's assigned to X now let's look
at the head of X and it shows me the
values we will also see what kind of
class it is and we will look at the
structure of X so class already says it
is date type and look at the structure
so it shows me the format now we have
converted this column or column related
value into X now how do I basically
extract values out of it or make it a
part of data frame so first I will use
so all once it has been converted in
date format I will go for as do numeric
and here I will create a variable called
ear and I will just do a format on X
which is basically of date type and then
I'm saying percentage y so that will get
me the ear component out of this let's
look at the values that shows me year
component now similarly we can get the
month out of this and then basically
look at the month values we can get the
day out of it and we can get the day
comp component now if I look at my data
2 which we had created earlier this
basically had date consumption wind
solar wind solar so what I can do is I
can add these extracted columns such as
year month Day to my data frame using a
cbind that is column bind and I will
assign it to my data 2 again so let's do
this and now if you look at head it
shows me date so so that should be date
format consumption now this one might
not be date format but we'll see you
have consumption wind solar and we have
extracted the year month and day which
can help us for group buy we can do some
aggregations we can do a plotting and we
can do various things by these
additional columns now let's look at
first three rows here so I'll say 1 is
to three for my data too and that shows
me some data here you can always do
ahead and look at the sample of data so
that basically shows me month day your
columns and then you have your date now
what we can do is we would want to
visualize this data we would want to
basically understand the consumption now
as I said if we want to visualize the
data say for example I want this which
is consumption of data over years and
this one is in terms of gigawatts per
hour as we were mentioning here G hours
so if I would want to create this visual
to basically understand the pattern of
the data how do we do it so we can you
create a line plot of full-time series
of Germany's electricity consumption
using the plot method now how do we do
that so here one of the option is I can
straight away use the plot method I can
then say what would be in my xaxis what
would be on my y AIS what would be the
type of graph I would want to plot what
is my name on x axis y AIS and this is
the simplest way so I'm saying my data 2
I'm extracting the year column and here
I'm taking the consumption so let's
create a plot and here if you see we are
looking at a plot we do see some tick
times and we see that the data has been
divided with every 2 years so from 2006
onwards to
2016 but then really this data does not
give me uh you know a very useful way of
looking at the data or understanding it
might be what I can do is I can use the
same way but I can give apart from x-
axis and y axis I can say the limits
that is X limit is 2006 to 2018 and Y
limit is from 800 to 1700 so we can do
this and let's look at this again this
is a plot but it really does not help me
in visualizing and understanding the
data so what are the better options I
can go for multiple plots in a window as
of now we are just sticking to one plot
in window so if you would want to have
multiple plots you can always change the
value here and make it two or three that
will say how many rows and how many
columns so as of now we will just keep
it as it is par MF row
now if I would want to plot I can
straight away give the column name so I
am interested in getting the consumption
now I can just do a plot I'll say my
data 2 and I will choose the second
column which is consumption which we saw
here from our data so consumption was
the second column so I can just do a
plot in a straightaway way without
mentioning your x axis y AIS limits and
so on and if you look at this this one
is giving me a pattern now here I am
looking at um x-axis Y axis which is not
really named we do not have a name to
this graph and we are looking at the
data it does show me some kind of
pattern but mightbe we can make it more
meaningful so I can do it this way where
I say my data second column let's give
axis as ear xaxis Y axis as consumption
now that has changed the xaxis and Y AIS
now I can also give some more details I
can say type should be line I have the
line width I'm saying color is blue and
let's do this so this looks more
meaningful mightbe shows a wavering
pattern of consumption over years I can
also give a limit of x that is 0 to 2018
and that basically shows me the range
now we can change that and we can be
more specific and saying X limit should
be 2006 to
2018 and let's look at this now this one
once you have given a proper limit it
shows the line graph and it shows what
was the consumption in 2006 and over a
period till
2018 I can then use any of these options
are fine but it depends on what and whom
you are presenting the data or what kind
of analysis you're doing so I get can do
a plot I can choose column second xlab
which is x axis Y axis type is line
width giving a x limit y limit and then
I'm giving a title to this which is
consumption graph and then basically
you're looking at the line graph now
those are the options which you can do
either you could be very specific or you
could just give your column which you
want to plot or obviously make it more
meaningful by giving all the details now
what we can do is if we would want to
look at this data and understand it
better rather than just looking at a
simple line I can take the log values so
here I'm saying log of my data 2 second
column so I'm taking log values of
consumption and I'm taking the
difference of logs so I can say
difference and then you can basically
increase or decrease this by multiplying
it by some number so rest Remains the
Same I'm Chang changing the color and
let's look at this plot and you see this
basically is giving me a better pattern
which makes meaning here we see the log
values so this is you are using a simple
plot
function in R you can also use ggplot
now for that we can install the ggplot
package it's already there in my machine
so I'll say no I will access this by
using the library ggplot
2 and now I I can use GG plot to plot so
the way you specify here you can say my
data 2 that's the data frame I'm saying
type as o and when I'm saying line I am
basically going to use xaxis which is
year why is consumption and let's look
at this plot so again we are back to the
one which we were doing earlier really
does not make any sense gives us some
data but then really does not give me
enough information
I can in my Aesthetics I can say x as
ear y as consumption I can do a grouping
and then I can give line and plot so
again we have some information but
really does not help me right now let's
look at other example so I'm just doing
the same thing here and I'm looking at
line type being tached I'm using the GG
plots other methods such as gome line
and gome point to give me more
information and if I look at the plot it
does give me data it tells me what are
the different values it gives me some
kind of pattern but I would still prefer
the way we were doing with plot now we
can change the color and obviously add
details to it so what we see is when you
use the plot method which I did earlier
it was choosing pretty good tick
locations that is every two years and
labels the years for the x- axis which
was helpful right but with these data
points which we were seeing here or say
for example this
one or say this one or say this one we
are looking at some data but then that
really is quite crowded and it is hard
to read you can look at the values but
then it really does not give you enough
information so we can go for plot method
but then we will see how we can consider
different data now if I would want to
plot the solar and wind time series so
let's see how do we do that so wind
column is what I'm interested in so
first thing is it was always good to
find out the minimum and the maximum
values in every column so I'm saying
minimum I'm saying let's put in here my
data
2 and then let's look at the values so
we are looking at The Columns we know
consumption is the second column wind is
the third column and you have solar is
the fourth and this one is the fifth so
let's say let's find out the minimum of
each of these columns which we would
want to plot so let's say minimum of
data third column and here I'm also
saying remove the na values because we
do not want to consider the na values so
let's look at the minimum that shows me
5.7
757 what is the maximum value it is 826
so that also helps me in giving a limit
if I want to plot wind on Y axis I can
give a y limit from 5 to
850 consumption wise let's find out the
minimum from second column and maximum
and similarly for solar find the minimum
and maximum and wind plus solar minimum
and maximum so this will be helpful when
you would want to plot multiple graphs
or give some limits so that's fine now
for multiple plots as I said instead of
having one plot let's plot consumption
and wind and solar and try to see a
pattern so I can say par function and I
will say three rows and one column so
now when I start plotting you will see
you will have multiple plots in one
single window so let's see how we do it
so here let's look at at plot one so
this one is consumption as we did
earlier and let's look at the data so
that gives me some data you can always
do a zoom and you can look at the data
you can basically expand this graph or
you can reduce this graph to see what
kind of pattern we have in consumption
similarly we can basically choose date
being
xaxis my consumption being y AIS
right so this is being more specific
because here we have a range but it
really does not give me enough
information so I will basically give
x-axis Y axis I will give the name that
is daily totals and then I will
basically give consumption color and Y
limit based on my minimum and maximum
limits so let's do this and now we can
look at the data here so let's see this
data makes a little more meaning because
we are looking at the dates and let me
do a zoom so it shows me all the dates
it shows me the data points it shows me
how the data pattern is changing for
consumption now this is for consumption
so what we can do is we can also extract
specific data so if you see here I have
done some testing where I am saying okay
I would want to to get a date
specifically I would want to extract
some Valu so we are looking at the date
column but if you remember we did not
change the data type we just changed the
data type of date column we extracted
year mon month out of it it would be
good if we can convert a column into
date time format and put that in our
data frame now let's look at the plot
two this is mainly for your uh column
which should be consumption and wind and
solar so here I see it is solar data and
I can plot this one to see how it looks
like and that tells me from 2006 onwards
we have some pattern I can be more
specific where I say I would be giving
date and then the column for solar xaxis
y AIS what is the type what is the Y
limit and what is the color it is always
good to specify your X and Y AIS given
name rather than let it automatically
pick up now this makes more meaning
because it shows me some dates similarly
we can do for wind so either you do it
just by giving the
column or you give your X and Y AIS so
let's look at this one and this shows me
the data so we can choose plot three
this one we can choose plot two we can
choose plot one and we can put all that
data in one graph so that's when you are
putting in multi plots in one particular
graph you can always do a zoom you can
always look at the data right and this
is usually useful to look at the pattern
what kind of pattern we see what data we
have and so on now moving forward so we
have seen how you are creating these
plots all in one window let me reset
this back to one plot per window and
let's basically plot time series in a
single year so what we have seen is that
when you look at the plot method it was
quite crowded then we looked at solar
and wind and if you compare that you
will see your consumption pattern your
solar pattern your wind pattern and
basically we can see from this
particular data some kind of pattern so
electricity consumption is highest in
the winter when where we will see what
is the consumption is it highest in
Winter or is it in summer we can see
that by breaking a year further into
months we can see that but we see a
pattern which goes for every year or
every two years being highest at a
particular point of time and then it
drops down so electricity consumption is
highest in Winter and that might be due
to electrical Heating and increased
lighting usage and lowest in summer now
when you look at electricity consumption
appears to split into two clusters we
can always look at the consumption one
with oscillation centered roundly around
1,400 gaws so you can always look at
14400 gaws and you see all the values
here which are in that particular
consumption another with fewer and more
scattered data points centrally roughed
around 150 so if you really expand this
you can see you will have lot of data
points at this point now we might guess
that these clusters correspond with
weekdays and weekends which we can see
if you break that data into yearly
monthly weekly and so on now if you look
at solar production that is highest in
summer when sunlight is most abundant
and lowest in winter so obviously when
you're making or gathering some insights
when you're looking at the data you are
also using your domain knowledge your
business knowledge your you know
knowledge of business to understand how
this goes if you look at wind power
production that's again highest in
Winters and drops down in summer so due
to stronger winds and more frequent
storms and lowest in summer so there is
some kind of increasing Trend in wind
power production over years which we can
see here over the years and all the time
series data what we are looking at is
referring or showing us some kind kind
of seasonality that is we are looking at
seasonality in which a pattern is
repeating again and again at regular
times at regular intervals so if you
look at consumption solar and wind time
series that oscillates between high and
low values on a yearly time scale which
we can break down and see I'll show you
that it corresponds with the seasonal
changes in weather over the year so
seasonality does not have to correspond
with meteorological reasons
for example if you look at retail stale
sales data uh that will show you yearly
seasonality with increase sales in
particular months so seasonality when we
say can occur on other time scales so
the plots what we are seeing here they
are fine but if you look at those plots
they might show some kind of weekly
seasonality also so in your consumption
corresponding to week days and weekends
so let's plot for one single year now
how do I do that so first is I will look
at my data
2 that shows me the structure it shows
me date which is Factor other columns
which are all numerics now like we did
earlier I'll repeat this step where I'm
going to convert the date column into
date type look at head of it look at
class of it look at the structure of it
right and then what I want to do is I
want to add
this as to my data frame so I will
create a variable called mod data and
this one will have as data and I'm
formatting the value of x which is date
time into month day and year so let's do
that and now you look at the mod data
which I created like modified data so
this is the format I have it is in date
type if you carefully see here and then
I can look at the head of it so it says
me mod data now we are what we did here
is when I said my data
3 so my data 3 we did a cbind and I did
a mod data which is going to add this
column to my other Columns of my data
too so my new data frame is my data 3
let's look at the structure of it and
you see there is this date column I can
delete it I can remove it I can let it
be right so that depends on our choice
might be we want to once our analysis
done we want to remove the mod data
right so we can keep both of them now
let's basically extract data for a
particular year now how do you do that
so this is some wrangling so I will say
my data 4 let's call it my data 4 and I
will use subset function so subset will
work on my data 3 that's the data and
what I do is I will do a subset how do
how is the subset found so I'll say take
the mod data column the value should be
greater than or equal to 2017 and should
be less than 2017 December 31st so I'm
getting data for one year and I'm
storing it as my data
4 let's get the head of it and you see
we are specifically looking at 2017
related data now let's do a plotting of
this where I will only create a plot for
one year so I'm saying my data 4 that's
my
new data what we got so here I am going
to take the First
Column which is mod data I'm going to
take the third column which is
consumption so I'm looking at the date
format for one year consumption values
for it and then rest of the things as we
have done earlier let's look at the plot
and this makes more meaning right so
when you look at this plot it tells me
Jan to Jan it shows me some kind of
pattern where I have divided the year
into months right and it is broken down
into say two months so Jan and March and
May and July and so on but we still see
a pattern and that gives me good
understanding of pattern where I've
broken it down into months
so this is where you have taken time
series in a single year to investigate
further and this is what we see right
now we can clearly see there are some
weekly o
oscillations what one more interesting
feature is that at this level of
granularity that is when you're looking
at yearly data there is a drastic
decrease in electricity consumption in
early January and late December during
the holidays or probably we can assume
that this is holidays now I can zoom in
further and look at just Jan and Feb
data let's see how we do that and let's
see how we work by zooming in the data
further so to zoom in the data further
let's see how we do it now here we have
this my data 4 which is basically having
a subset right so let's work on this one
so I will say my data 4 which earlier I
was taking data 3 I was doing a subset
and I was giving the date but this time
I will make it more narrower so I'll say
my data 4 I will say subset from my data
3 and I will choose mod data column
which we have modified with the date
format I will choose the starting date
as
1701 that is Jan and then let's go till
Feb and let's create this
now let's look at the head of this so it
shows me we have the data which is Jan
and then you you can basically look at
more on this now again as I said earlier
let's find out the minimum of this from
the First Column so that is basically
your mod data so let's look into this
one and that
basically will give me minimum and
maximum let's look at the values so this
one tells tells me Jan 17 January 1 and
maximum is
your Feb 28th 2nd month 2017 so we are
actually looking at two months data here
let's look at the Y minimum so this is I
will look at column three now what is
column three consumption so let's look
at the minimum value for consumption
maximum value of consumption let's look
at the values which can be given as our
limits now this is the minimum and
maximum now let's do a plotting for this
data which has been narrowed down for
consumption based on my data so I'm
saying My First Column which is mod data
and then third column which is
consumption I'm giving some naming
convention for sorry namings for your x-
axis y AIS what is my
consumption or what is my title here
what is the color and then you see I'm
using X limit to give the minimum and
maximum limit and Y limit so let's look
at this data and if you look at this
data it is specifically for two months
and again I can look at the pattern here
what I can also do is I can add some
grid here so I can basically look at
this data and make more meaning out of
it so it is bi-weekly data you can see
now I can add a line here using AB line
and then I can basically choose what
lines I would want to add
horizontally so that basically allows me
to dissect the data and look at data in
a more meaningful way I can also add
vertical lines so vertical lines is I'm
saying sequence will be minimum maximum
and I'm saying an interval of seven so
let's do this and this basically has
added some lines every week and you can
see at the end of week it is dropping
and then it is starting again it Peaks
somewhere in the mid of the week and
again it drops down so this is you're
looking at your consumption data right
now what we can also do is we can create
some box plots so when we looked at
zooming in data for Jan and Feb you can
add some data points like this so
consumption is highest on the weekday as
I showed you here and lowest on the
weekends so this is what we are seeing
when we are breaking the data or zooming
it further for a couple of months so we
have vertical grid lines and we have
nicely formatted tick labels that is Jan
1st Jan 15 Feb 1st and so on so we can
easily tell which days are weekday and
weekends with use of these grid lines
and basically breaking it down so there
are many other ways to actually
visualize your time series data
depending on what patterns you're trying
to explore you can use Scatter Plots you
can use heat maps you can use use
histograms and so on now moving further
we would want to explore the seasonality
right so when you further explore the
seasonality of our data we can use box
plots basically to group the data by
different time periods and display the
distribution for each group now how do
we do
that let's come here and let's see how
box plot works so I can just do a simple
box plot and I can choose my consum
column and that gives me just the
consumption data but this really does
not give me any meaning I can look at
solar data I can look at the wind data
and we can also see some outliers here
so we can create box plots but if we
would want to do a box plot what is box
plot it is basically a visual display of
your five number summary that is you
want to look at your mean median you
want to look at your 25th percentile 50
percentile
or 75th percentile so we can use a
quantile function use the consumption
column and then you basically give a
vector which shows you five number
summary so that's your quantile and then
let's do a box plot so if you are
looking at quantile it tells me what is
the minimum what is 25th percentile 50
75th and 100 that's from my consumption
column so let's create a box plot for
consumption let's give it a name as
consumption let's give y axxis as
consumption and a limit for y AIS now
that's my consumption graph so I can
look at yearly data now that will make
more meaning rather than just looking at
the complete consumption data so how do
we do it yearly so we will say
consumption and then I will say the year
column so it is consumption but grouped
based on ear so here I can give xaxis y
AIS and I can give y limit so let's
create this and this makes more meaning
we can give some coloring scheme here
but now I'm looking at 2006 2007 8 9 and
so on and we can look at the data what
is the range right it gives me five
percentile or sorry five number summary
of the data per year and it basically
allows me to look at the seasonality of
this similarly we can create box plot
by just giving consumption yearly
grouped and here I'm giving the title as
consumption y AIS xaxis and Y limit
wherein I can also use lass so this is
one more feature which you can do and
that basically will give me the tick
points if you compare this one to the
previous graph so when I created this
previous graph I had 2006 2008 and I had
from 6 600 to 18800 and if I go for the
next one I am basically seeing more
useful information now let's look at
monthly data so I would want to group it
based on months and let's create that so
this gives me the monthly data where I'm
looking at
months and I could select a particular
year or I can just do a grouping based
on months so I can have multiple plots
to see a difference here so let's do
this now let's create a box plot for
consumption which is monthly data and
let's give it a color let's look at the
wind data which is again grouped monthly
and let's look at the solar data which
is grouped monthly now if I zoom in it
basically gives me the seasonality of
the data for your wind for your
consumption for your solar so what we
are doing is we are creating these box
plots which are giving us values now
what I can also do is I could look at
the day wise also but before we look
into this how do I infer some
information from these box plots which
are being created so this is what we
have done where we are looking at the
data for month and these box plots give
me ear seasonality which we were seeing
in earlier plots but give some
additional insights so if I look at the
data here it tells me the electricity
consumption is generally higher in
Winter now this is based on months so we
can see consumption is higher in Winters
and lower in summer so we can obviously
look at our plot we can see where it is
lower where it is higher and then we can
look at the median and lower two
quartiles are lower in December and Jan
January compared to November and
February so that is you look at the
quartiles and you will see that the
median and lower two quartiles are lower
in December and
January here Jan and December so you can
look at from my plot now this is giving
you some idea on
seasonality now that might be due to
business being closed over holidays now
this one we were also seeing when we
looked at time series for 2017 only and
boxplot basically confirms that there is
this consistent pattern throughout the
years now when you look at your solar
and wind power production both will give
you a year seasonality what we are
seeing here and if basically I look at
the data so it depends on what
parameters you are choosing but if you
look at solar it will reflect the effect
of occasional extreme wind speeds
associated with storms and other
transient and since we are grouping it
based on months we can see this pattern
is quite evident every year now what we
can do is we can group the data day wise
so here let me again reset this to one
plot per graph now I'll say box plot
I'll say consumption which is group
based on day now we know that there is a
day column and let's give a y limit and
let's look at the data so this is where
I'm grouping the data day wise so you
look at 31 days and you look at the box
plot so this is where you are plotting
it on a daily basis so you can look at
the data you can break it down to a
particular week so here I have given day
and I have chosen all the 31 days but I
can break it down to a week and I can
look at the data so if we look at the
the data per week or per day we can
basically infer that electricity
consumption where I'm doing a
consumption group by day is higher on
weekday than on
weekends so time series with strong
seasonality can often be represented
with models that can decompose signal
into seasonality and long Trend now this
is an easy way now how how do we look at
the frequency of the data that could be
interesting to see so let me uh look at
say the yearly
data which we were seeing
here now let's go further and here we
have looked at data so what we will do
is we look at the frequency now when you
look at the frequency when you talk
about frequency in your data so we have
the modified date column which gives me
a frequency and if we really look into
the data that will tell me that the data
is on a daily basis so for that let's
look at my data 3 again which gives me
data and you can just see all the datas
data or dates are in sequence so your 22
23 24 25 26 and so on I can look at I
can access a deer
package that is basically allowing me to
work in a better way now I can look at
the summary of this and for all my
columns I seeing what is a minimum five
number summary date and consumption so
date does not show me anything because
this is not in a date format it is just
a factor but other things have the fin
number summary so we are looking at wind
plus solar we are looking at year and
month and day and all these columns now
what we will do is we will want to find
out the sum of each column how many
entries does it have and we will say the
value should na value should not be
considered so let's look at this one so
it tells me for my particular columns so
let me run this
again and that shows me for each column
how many values you have and these
counts do not include the na values now
similarly I can find out specifically
for consumption I can find out is there
any na value so I'm saying is do Na and
let's find out if there is any na value
or missing value in consumption it says
zero okay that's good if you look in
wind it tells me there are, 1463 entries
which are na similarly solar similarly
wind do solar or wind plus solar so it
gives me a count of Na values that is
missing values and also values which are
not missing so to understand frequency
what we can do is we can find out the
minimum on the date that is the First
Column and I'm saying RM na. RM is true
that is get rid of Na values and find
out the minimum and let's look at the
minimum value this is the minimum from
my modified date now if if I would want
to get the frequency I can basically use
sequence function so I can say from X
minimum that is the minimum value I want
to look at the frequency that is day
wise and let's just look at five entries
and see if there is a day-by-day
frequency so let's look at the value of
this and obviously it tells me there is
day wise frequency so that allows me to
look at the frequency look at the type
of it it is an integer class is a date
so similarly we can say from X minimum
we can basically look at the frequency
month-wise
and I can again look at five records so
that shows me monthly data right so I
can extract the data for frequency
similarly yearly data and that's also
very useful now we can select data which
has na values for wind so how do I do it
I would want to find out the wind column
and I want to find out where the values
are na a so I will create a variable and
here I will say my data 3 and then I
give a conditional where I say is na in
the column so let's do this now once
I've done this once I've done this I
have said that my selected wi data from
my data 3 where we said na values and I
will give the names to this so names
should be in my data 3 I'm interested in
mod data consumption wind and solar so
these are the four columns I'm
interested in let's look at first 10
records here or first n rows so that
tells me these are the values where wind
has na or missing
values I can always do a view and that
gives me the complete dat
so it basically shows me
1,463
entries and here it shows me all na
values so you can look at all the way to
the end and it shows me wind has na
solar does have some value here in the
last row but then also if you see the
numbers
have a difference so you have 1 14 61
and then you have 2174 so there is a
difference so there is some data in
between where wind has some values so we
have found out na values now what we
will do is we will select data which
does not have any values so I will call
it cell selected wi two I'll again use
my data 3 I will say which but now I'm
saying not na from this column and I
will select the data for the columns so
I'm interested in looking at 10 records
and this shows me not any Valu so no
more missing value Val so if I really
look at this data as I saw earlier which
has Na and if I look at these values
which are not na for the wind column so
looking at these two result we will know
that in year 2011 wind
column has some missing values so let's
focus on year 2011 so how do I do that
let's call it a different variable I'll
say my data 3 I will say here when I say
which where we were saying na here I
will say the year should have a value of
2011 and I want all these
columns let's look at the data here and
this is showing me 2011 but we are not
seeing all the values so there are some
values but then there are some missing
values also for 2011 based on whatever
analysis we have done so let's look at
the class of this it is basically a data
frame to a view and this one will help
me in finding out where are the na
values so if you just scroll down
looking at all the data let's search if
wind column has a na or a missing value
and I will see if there is any missing
value in which column or which row it is
for the wind column so we have all the
values which are
existing I could select and search for
one specific value and I'll show you how
we can do that so here let's scroll all
the way down so it's like you're
exploring your data and seeing
is wind column having na or missing
value for a particular row and let's
scroll here and here you see there is a
missing value for one particular row so
13th December 2011 has wind value 15
December has wind value but your 14
December does not have right similarly
we can search so there was only one
entry which was missing now that could
be for some reason might be it was not
calculated mightbe it was not tabulated
so we have a missing value and that can
affect my plotting that can affect my
analysis so let's look at the number of
rows in this which will tell me how many
rows we have for 2011 so it tells me 365
so that is basically the number of days
in a year here now we will find out if
there were na values so we earlier
checked total number of Na values per
column that is in your row number 265 to
269 we can see here 265 to
269 so this is where we were seeing are
there any na values right so let's go
back
here and we want to find out the number
of Na values for a particular year how
do I do it so I can just do a sum I will
say is na now I'm interested in my data
3 wind column and I'm saying my year has
to be 2011 but I'm finding out the na
values so let's do this and it tells me
one and that's right that's what we saw
when we did a view let's see how many
non na values you have and that is 364
so that basically
satisfies my logic since 364 + 1 missing
so there are 365 let's look at the
structure of this it tells me you have
modified date and date format you have
consumption wind and solar now let's
create a variable selected wind four I
will say wind three that is which was
having all my Na and non na values for
2011 I will say let's find out the n a
value because I'm interested in finding
out that particular row so I'm saying
find out where the value is na and I
want all the columns let's look at this
one and this is my specific row which
has a na value now we know that data
follows a dewise frequency which we have
clearly seen now let's select data which
has Na and non na values so let's say
let's call it test one I will use wind 3
which has Na and non na values but now I
will say I want the modified date witer
than 12 12 12 2001 now remember we had
when we were doing a view we saw that
one particular day or what we see here
14th of December there is no date so I
will select a subset of data which
includes This na and non na that is
might be I can take 13th of December and
15th of December so let's start from 12
12 so the date should be greater than 12
12 that means 13th and it should be less
than 16 so that is 15th and the columns
right so now we have some data let's
look at this so I have a I've selected a
subset of data I could have done this
using subset also so I have Na and non
na values now why are we doing this so
some sometimes you might have some data
for a particular column and you may want
to find out if there are any missing
values might be you want to fill them up
or replace them with something so that
is usually useful when you are doing a
trend detection so say for example you
have data for every month and might be
in one one of the months you have missed
or might be you have data for every year
collected monthly and then in one of the
years for couple of months you don't
have the data like I can say 2, 2016 I
have data for all 12 months 2017 all 12
months 2018 might be I don't have data
for March and June 2019 I don't have
data for same months so I can forward
fill or backward fill them using the
previous year's same month data so we
can do that so here I have test data
where I've extracted a subset of data I
can look at the class of this it is a
data data frame structure of this it has
the columns now let's use the library
and function and use the Tidy r package
and what we will do is we will fill it
up so I will use test one I will fill
the wind column which has a missing
value now once you do this if you notice
it has done a forward fill so it has
taken the previous value and it has just
filled up that so you can fill up the
data using different directions such as
up and down left and right and so on so
we can take care of missing values in
our frequency data which allows us to
basically analyze the data in a better
way now here we will want to also look
at some more data so this is to deal
with frequency so fill column wherein
you can take care of missing values
forward filled so filling values can be
done in different directions as I said
and you may want to First convert your
time series to specified frequency if
your data does not have a frequency but
we had now if you do not have a
frequency might be you can convert it
into a frequency such as weekly daily
monthly as I showed you and then
basically you can do a forward fill for
the values so for example if I have my
data I can break it down into weekly and
then look at the value and if there are
any values missing for weekly data I can
use a forward fill so that can take care
of my frequency data then let's look at
the trends of the data which is the last
part of this project so basically let's
look at the trend So when you say Trend
what does that mean so in Time series
data you always have some kind of trend
so that will exhibit some slow gradual
variability in addition to higher
frequency variability such as
seasonality and noise now to visualize
these Trends what we do is we use what
we call as rolling means so we know how
our data is spread over year or month or
day but how about looking at a rolling
average and see what is the difference
so a rolling mean will tend to smooth a
Time series by averaging out the
variations and
frequencies so this can be high higher
than the window size so there is
something called as windowing where you
can choose a set of time frame you can
also average out any seasonality on a
time scale equal to window size so this
will allow you to look at lower
frequency variation in the data so when
we are looking at electricity
consumption time series we already saw
there is a weekly pattern there is a
yearly seasonality which we saw using
box plots so we can also look at the
rolling means of of the time scales how
do we do that so for this you can use
some package like zoo and then you can
basically use a rolling mean using the
zoo package and you can say what is
the frequency with which you want to
calculate the rolling mean now how do we
do this let's look at this data so here
I'm going to my look at my data three
which we have been using so far now
let's call it a three-day test you can
give it any name I'm going to use my
data 3 I'm using the PIP in
function now I will use deer and I will
arrange the data descending in ear now
you can always break it down step by
step and you can see the result of this
so I'm going to arrange this data in
descending order of year so obviously my
last one 2017 or 2018 will be on the top
you want to group the data by year so it
depends on how many years we have we'll
see so you can group the data by year
now this data is then used to basically
mutate so mutate function is going to
allow me to use this rolling mean so
I'll call it as says 03 day so I'm going
to calculate a rolling mean every 3 days
for my consumption column and basically
let's ungroup this so let's see how this
works
sorry yeah let's look at this and here
when I'm doing a 3-day test let's look
at the result of this and then I'll
explain this so if you see here we have
the test 3-day column now this has the
rolling average now what does that mean
so first value here what we see is
1367 is the average consumption in
2017 from the first date with a data
point on either side of it that is you
can look at this date so 113 0 then you
look
at you're looking at the value 1367 here
so you look at 1 13 0 1 1441 1 153 0 if
I take a mean of these so for example if
I would just do this
part and that is giving me mean okay
because I have a comment so let's
basically add anything as comment and
then let's do this so it saves me 1367
that's what we are seeing here right so
you're got getting a rolling average
every 3 days similarly if you want every
five days it takes the five values and
it gets the mid value right so you can
always find out the mean rolling mean
for a particular frequency now let's do
that for 7 days that is weekly data and
yearly data that is 365 days so how do I
do it same logic my data test now I'm
using my data 3 I'm arranging it in a
descending order I'm grouping by year so
when you do a group by year so earlier
when we did a grouping by and when we
looked at the data it was telling me how
many rows we had right so let's do a
grouping by year and let's say test 07
so that's a rolling average every 7 days
and I'm also saying take care of the na
values similarly I'm getting rolling
average every 365 days might be you can
do quarterly might be you can do half
yearly and let's do this so let's create
this my data test and let's look at the
result of this so I will use my data
test I will say arrange based on
modified date now we know there is a
column called modified date I want to
just look at 2017 data so I'm doing a
filter right and then I will choose what
are the columns I'm interested in so I
will look at the seven and 365 day and
let's look at say first seven records so
let's do this and that basically gives
me the consumption value modified date
year and my rolling 7day average or 7day
mean which is for first 7 days and then
365 you will not see the data here but
if I do a view on this I can basically
see the values so you can always select
a particular column to see the
values these are the values for every 7
Day rolling average this is for 365 days
every 365 days so you see all the values
are missing but every 365 entry you will
have basically some data now let's do a
plotting of this and basically visualize
this data which we are seeing rolling
average so let me first do a plotting
one plot per graph and let's do a
plotting I will take consumption
data x axis y AIS color and give a title
to this so let's create this and that's
my consumption data which is spread over
a period of time and that's fair enough
but now let's add some more plot to this
so I will add the 7day rolling average
to this so for second plot to be added
in the same one in R you can use points
so I will say points I will choose seven
data column type is line width x limit y
limit and color so let's do this and
that's my pattern 7day rolling average
which basically gives me some kind of
trend similarly I can add one more here
and this time I will choose the 365 day
and look at the pattern lines so now you
see some Dots here well you could do it
in a different way so I can just add
Legend to this and I can say Legend will
be where in x-axis and y axis so I'm
saying it will be
2,500 and Y is 1,800 so my Legend will
come in somewhere here I'm saying my
Legend will have consumption test and
this one I can give some names I can
give what is the color I can say what
kind of Legend it explains what is for
each color and then basically a vector
so let's add a legend to this and I've
added a legend now you can do a zoom and
look at the
data and here I see that uh my xaxis is
fine but Y axis is going a little about
of my plotting area so I can actually
change that so here I have 1,800 how
about making it
1,600 and let's look at this this one so
we can
basically uh go for this one and start
again here plot and points and line and
then add a legend right and you can
basically place your Legend anywhere in
the plot so this basically is giving me
me the trend what I'm looking at my
rolling average so similarly you can
look at the trend for wind and solar
data so what we are seeing here is when
you look at Trend this is one more way
of looking at it you can always create
plots in different ways so 7-Day rolling
mean has smoothed out all weekly
seasonality which we were seeing Here in
My Graph where you look at every 7 Day
preserving the yearly seasonality so
7day will tell that electricity
consumption is typically higher in
Winter and lower in summer so better is
you break it down uh yearly so here if
you look at every year you can see when
is winter when is summer what is the
seasonality what you're Trend what
you're seeing here and if there is a
decrease or increase uh for few weeks
every winter so similarly if you look at
365 now as you said as I said rolling
average basically uh reduces the
variation so if I look at 365 rolling
mean we can see long-term Trend in
electricity consumption is pretty flat
now that's what we are seeing it's kind
of pretty flat there is not much
variation over years if you really join
these dots
so we can basically see some highs and
lows and that gives me a trend now this
is how you can do a trend detection and
similarly we can do plotting for wind
and solar so this is a small project
which I demonstrated using R now all
this code which you you have here in the
form of a project. r file you can find
here in my GitHub page this is the
document which explains some things feel
free to download this and you can add
details to it this is the sample data
set which you can also find in my
repository in the data sets folder so
continue learning and continue
practicing are want to be a certified
data expert then here we have
postgraduate program in data analytics
by simply learn take a glance at the
notable Fe features and skills offered
in this course you will benefit from
exclusive IBM hackathons and ask me
anything sessions 8 times more
interaction in live online classes with
industry experts Capstone projects
across three domains and over 14 data
analytics projects using real data sets
from Google Play Store Lyft World Bank
and more master classes from puu faulty
and IBM experts along with simply learns
job assist for better job process
aspects acquire skills in data analytics
statistical analysis using Excel data
analysis using Python and R and data
visualization using tableu and powerbi
enroll Now using the course Link in the
description box Excel is a really
powerful tool for data analytics and
Reporting and pivot tables are one of
the features that Excel offers for
creating tabular reports to summarize
our data let's begin by understanding
what is a pivote table
a pivot table is a tool that summarizes
and reorganizes selected columns and
rows of data in a spreadsheet to obtain
a desired
report it does not actually change the
spreadsheet data it simply pivots or
turns the data to view it in different
perspectives pivot tables are espcially
useful with large amounts of data that
would be timec consuming to calculate
manually now let's understand the
different components of a pivote table
so there are four main components first
we have rows when a field is chosen for
the row area it populates as the first
column in the pivot table similar to The
Columns all row labels are unique values
and duplicates are removed columns is
the second component when a field is
chosen for the column area only the
unique values of the field are listed
across the top then we have values each
value is kept in a pivot table cell and
display the summarized information the
most common values are sum average
minimum and maximum finally we have
filters filters apply a calculation or
restriction to the entire table so let's
jump over to Microsoft Excel and let me
show you the data set that we will use
in this demo so with India being ready
for its 16th census in
2021 that is next year it is a good time
for us to analyze India's last census
data from 2011 and see where different
states and cities across India stood in
terms of population literacy and other
socioeconomic factors
we will analyze this data by creating
different pivot tables in Excel and
explore some of its features so let's
begin first I'll show you one of the
features that Excel offers us so suppose
I click on any cell and hit control+ Q
you can see our entire table is selected
and at the right bottom there's an
option of quick analysis now you can see
by default Excel has prompted certain
features such as formatting we have
charts to s and there's one more called
tables now Excel by default has created
some pivote tables for us now the first
one you say sum of district code by
state names next we have sum of sex
ratio by state name then we have sum of
child sex ratio some of male graduates
and some of female graduates by state
name and there are others before
creating our pivote table so let's have
a final look at our data set so First
Column you see is the city column so
there are different cities from
different parts of India then we have
the state code we have the state name
district code we have the total
population followed by male and female
population next you can see we have the
total literates from each City then we
have the male and female literates next
we have the sex ratio then we have the
child sex ratio next we have total
number of graduates and finally you can
see we have male and female graduates so
using this table we'll create several P
tables now first of all let's create a p
table to find the total population for
each state and sort it in descending
order so you can see here we have the
problem statement so our first P table
will have the total population for each
of the states in descending order so to
create a pavot table you can click any
cell in your data go to the insert tab
and here left you can see we have the
option to create a pivote table so let
me select pivote table now my range is
already selected the entire table and
here I'll choose existing worksheet
because I want to place my pivote table
in the same worksheet and I'll give my
location I'll point to cell Q5 now let
me click
okay you can see the P table Fields
appears here on the right now since we
want to find the total population for
each state so what I'll do is I'll drag
my state name onto rows so here in our
pivot table you can see we have the
different state names listed now we want
the total population for each of these
states so in the field list I'll search
for total population which is this one
and drag it under values you can see we
have a sum of total population for each
of these states by default Excel will
sum any numeric column you can always
change it to average minimum maximum
anything you want now we want to sort
this column in descending order so I
right click go to sort option and choose
Zed to a that is largest to
smallest you can see here in 2011
Maharashtra had the highest number of
population or the total population in
Maharashtra was the highest then it was
utar Pradesh we had Andra Pradesh and if
I come down we have nagaland and andan
and nicobar Islands towards the end so
this is a simple peot table that we
created now the next problem we have is
we want to find the total sum of
literates in each City belonging to a
certain state so let's see how to do it
I'll click on any cell go to insert and
here I can click on pavot table my range
is selected I'll choose existing
worksheet and give my location which is
Q5 I click on
okay now here we want to find the total
sum of literates so what I'll do is
first let me drag total literates column
to values you have the total sum of
literates from all the
states next I want to see the sum of
total literates based on states and
cities so let me first drag state name
onto rows and then will dra City on two
rows you can see here we have our P
table
ready to the left of the pivote table
you can see we have the state names and
the cities per state and on the right
you can see the total number of
literates from each City if I scroll
down we have we have Assam then you can
see we have
Bihar and if I keep scrolling we have
all the states harana Himachal prades
there Jammu and Kashmir which has now
become a union territory we have jarand
Karnataka and other states as well
moving
on okay so the next thing we want to see
is what is the average sex ratio and the
child sex ratio for each state with that
we also want to find the states that had
the highest and lowest sex show in
2011 so let's create a p table for this
I'll click on any cell go to insert
choose peot table click on existing
worksheet I'll select cell Q5 and click
on
okay now since we want the average sex
ratio and the child sex ratio so first
I'll drag those columns either you can
manually scroll and drag it or here you
have the option to search for it so if
if I look for child you can see we
have the same column listed can just
drag it from there let me delete this
and I also want the sex ratio so I'll
place it on top of child sex ratio next
we want to see it based on different
states so what I'll do is I'll take
state name and put it under rows so here
you can see we have our pivot table
ready on the left you can see we have
the different state names listed and on
the right we have the values now we want
to find the average Now by default Excel
will sum the numeric columns you can see
it tells you sum of sex ratio and child
sex ratio so what you can do you can
click on this drop down and go to Value
field
settings and here summarize
values by you can choose average you can
see the custom name it says average of
sex ratio click on
okay our entire column is now giving us
the average sex ratio similarly for this
column let me convert it into average
I'll again click on the drop down go to
Value field settings click on average
and click
okay and you can see here we have the
average of child sex ratio for each of
the states now the next question says
which states had the highest and lowest
sex ratio so we'll consider this column
so we'll sort it in any order you want
you can do it either ascending or
descending let me sort it in descending
order you can see we have our column
sorted
now so in
2011 Kerala had the highest sex ratio
and if I scroll down to the bottom you
can see Himachal prades had the lowest
which is around
[Music]
818 up next let's explore one more
feature of P table so suppose you want
to see the top or bottom few rows of a
peoe table you can do that as well so
here we have a question at hand we want
to find the top three cities with the
highest number of female graduates so
let's see from the entire pivot table
how we can filter the top three cities
so I'll go to insert click on the pavot
table option go to existing worksheet
click on Q5 and hit
okay now since we want to find the top
three cities I'll drag City column onto
rows and then we want the female
graduates so in the search bar I'll look
for
female and I'll choose this column that
is female graduates and drag it
here onto values so I have the sum of
female graduates for each of the Cities
now since we want to find the highest
number of female graduates in the top
three cities so let me first s this
column I'll sort it in descending order
now we have it sorted now from this you
can see that Delhi greater Mumbai and
bangaluru are the top three cities but
it's displaying all the cities for us so
let's filter only the top three so what
you can do is right click and go to
filter under filter you have the option
of top 10 I'll select this here I only
want the top three so either you
can go down like this or you can
directly type
three your column is already selected
let me just click on okay there you go
we have the required pivot table ready
and it only displays us the top three
cities with the highest number of female
graduates now the next thing we want to
see is how to use a Slicer in a peot
table so we have a question here What's
the total population for all the cities
in Rajasthan and Karnataka so let's
create a poot table for this and see how
you can use a slicer to filter the
table click on existing I'll click on a
location the this time
q6 click okay now since I want the total
population so I'll drag total population
onto values and then I'll select the
city onto rows and then the state name
also I'll place it on top of City so you
have in the pivot table all the states
and their cities and on the right you
can see the total population for each of
these cities but our question is we want
to find only for Rajasthan and Karnataka
now for that what you can do is go to
insert and create a slicer either you
can create from this option or you can
go to pivote table analyze option and
here you have the option to create or
insert a slicer and click on this and
since we want to slice the table based
on state that is Rajasthan and Karnataka
I'll choose state name as my slicer
field you can see this is my slicer here
now you only want the data for Rajasthan
and Karnataka so I'll search for these
two so here we have Karnataka so let me
select Karnataka
first and I also want for Rajasthan
so let me select Rajasthan also you can
see in our pivote table we only have
data for Rajasthan and
Karnataka so this pivot table shows you
different cities from Karnataka and the
total sum of population from each of the
cities and similarly we also have for
Rajasthan moving ahead now we will see
another very interesting feature of
pivot that is how you can create
percentage contribution of a
table for example we have a question
here what's the percentage contribution
of male and female literates from each
state now we want to see in terms of
percentage and not as sum or average
let's do that I'll create my pivote
table click on
existing and I'll select an empty
cell okay now here since we want to find
the percentage contribution of male and
female literates so first I'll
drag male literates onto values followed
by female literates onto values by
default it has summed up the male
literat and female literat value and
also I want to drag State
column to
row so here you can see the sum of male
literates and female literates per state
I want to convert this as percentage
contribution so what we can do is I'll
select any cell and I'll right click and
I'll go to so value as and here I have
the option to select percentage of grand
total so I'll select
this you can see we have the percentage
contribution of male literates through
the total now if I sort this you will
get to know which state contributed or
has the highest percentage
contribution so we have Maharashtra for
male
literates then we had utar prades in
2011 if I come
down we had migala nagaland and Andaman
and nicobar
Islands as two states which had little
or minimal contribution to male
literates similarly let's do it for
female literates
I'll go to so value as and select
percentage of grand
total so you can see here also
Maharashtra utar Pradesh then Gujarat
and all had the highest percentage
contribution to female literates so this
is another good feature to convert your
data and SE in terms of
percentage now moving ahead let's say we
want to find the bottom three cities
from each state that had the lowest
female graduates we can do that as well
I'll go to insert click on
pivot go to existing worksheet select an
empty worksheet and click on
okay now since I want to see based on
States as well as cities so let me drag
the state name first onto rows and let's
drag the city column onto
rows
next we want female graduates so let me
look for female graduates in the field
list I'll drag it onto
values now we have the list of states
and the respective cities and to the
right of the peot table you can see the
sum of female graduates from each
City now first I'll sort this column
I'll right click go to sort and click on
sest to largest now we have sorted our
female graduates
from shortest or smallest to largest now
since I want to find the bottom three
cities from each state I'll come to the
cell right click go to filter and select
top 10 now
I'll replace top 10 with bottom and I
want the bottom three cities from each
state I have my column selected that is
some of female graduates if I click on
okay you can see here some of the states
don't have three cities so you can see
andan and nicobar islands has only one
city that is Port player while the
remaining you can find the bottom three
cities with the lowest number of female
graduates so Andra Pradesh had these
three in Assam we had Naga then there
was diar and Sila similarly if I come
down in harana we have pwal kathal and
zind
if I come further here you can see for
Karnataka this gangavati this ranii
benur and this scholar similarly you can
see for Kerala as
well now moving
ahead now in the next example I'll tell
you how you can create a calculated
field or a calculated column in Excel
with the help of a peot table so in a
peot table you can create or use custom
formulas to create calculated fields or
items calculated fields of formulas that
can refer to other fields in the pivot
table calculated Fields appear with
other value fields in the pivot table
like other value Fields a calculated
Fields name May proceed with sum of
followed by the field name so here we
have a sales table that has columns like
the items which has different fruits and
vegetables and those have been
categorized as fruits and vegetables we
have the price per kg and this is in
terms of rupees
and we have the quantity that was sold
now let's see if you want to find the
sales for each item in the table you can
create a calculated field so your sales
column is going to be the product of
price per kg and quantity so let me show
you how you can do that with the help of
a p table I'll create a p table
first click on an empty cell hit okay
now if you see on the top under P table
analyze and under calculations we have
the option Fields items and sets if I
click on this drop down I get the option
to create a calculated field or insert a
calculated field I click on this I'll
give my field name as
sales and I'll select my
formula I'll first click on price per kg
and hit insert field and I'll give a
space hit shift 8 to give the product
symbol and then I'll double click on
quantity now this is my formula for
sales that is price per kg multiplied by
quantity I click on ADD and I click on
okay if you see here there's a
calculated field that is present in the
pivote table fields which is seals but
it did not add it to our original table
or original table is the same but here
we have added a calculated field which
is present only in the pivot table list
now we can use this it has already taken
it under values now let's say I want to
find the sum of sees for each item under
each category you can see it here we
have our category fruit and we have our
category vegetable and under that we
have different items like apple apricot
banana similarly in vegetables we have
br Ki The scrots Corn eggplant and
others so this is how you can create a
calculated field in a pivote table now
this's one more good feature that Excel
offers us in pivote table is to create a
pivote chart so you can use your pivote
table and create different charts so
I'll show you how to do that if I go to
insert here I have the option of
recommended charts if I click on this
Excel gives me some default charts which
you can use let's say I'll select
this let me drag it a bit to the right
here you can see I'll close this poot
field list this is a nice bar chart that
Excel has created this is called a
pivote chart now here you can see the
category fruits and vegetables and the
different fruits and vegetables are the
items in the y- axis you can see the
total sales if you see from the graph
guava meet the highest amount of sales
now if I sort this let's sort this
first you can see it here fruit guava
meet the highest amount of sales now
since I sorted and changed my pivote
table the pivote chart also
automatically gets updated similarly
there are other charts also that you can
create let's go to the insert Tab and
and let's click on recommended charts
again let's look for a pie chart so this
is a pie chart that you can create let
me click on okay so here is our PI chart
and each Pi represents a certain item
and the pi that has the highest area
represents it had the highest amount of
Sals in this case you can see it is
quava and similarly we have other items
as well this is fruit
banana that's
scn and we have spinach and
others let's explore a few other charts
so first I'll click on my pivot table go
to insert and under recommended charts
let's now select a line chart if I hit
okay move it to the right so this is a
line chart you can see it starts from
guava which had the highest amount of
sales then it
drops and in the x-axis you can see the
different items similarly when it starts
with the vegetables broli made the
highest amount of sales with 2,800 rupe
and our lowest was eggplant at 900
rupees for fruits papaya sold the least
at 700 rupees let's take another chart
I'll go to insert under recommended
charts let's
see this time we'll see a bar chart now
this is a
horizontal bar chart and not a vertical
one we just saw a vertical column chart
like this this is an horizontal bar
chart now you can always increase and
decrease the size of these
charts let's explore a last chart let's
take the area chart for now so this is
an area chart again it looks similar to
the line chart it starts with guava
which had the highest am ount of Sals
similarly papaya under fruits had the
lowest amount of Sals under vegetables
it was broccoli and finally eggplant
made the lowest amount of sales and of
vegetable now let's go to our first
sheet and summarize what we have done in
this demo for pivot taes in Excel so we
had our
data this is a 2011 Census Data from
India we had the different cities the
state names and we had the two total
population total literates female
literates male literates we had the sex
ratio total graduates and other
information so we began by understanding
how to create a simple pivote table
where we calculated the total population
for each state and sorted it in
descending order we found that
Maharashtra utar Pradesh had the total
population in
2011 then we saw another preo table
where we calculated the total sum of
literates in each City belonging to a
certain state so you can see we had the
different state names and the cities
under each
state then we saw another feature where
you could calculate the average of a
certain numerical column so here we
calculated the average sex ratio and the
child sex ratio for each state and found
out which one had the highest and lowest
sex
ratio after that we saw how you could
find or filter
tables we saw how to find the top three
cities with the highest number of female
graduates we found out that Delhi
greater Mumbai and bangaluru were the
top cities with highest number of female
graduates next we saw how to use Slicer
in a poo table so we sliced our table
based on Rajasthan Karnataka State and
saw the total population for all the
cities in Rajasthan and
Karnataka in the next sheet
we explored another feature that was to
find the percentage contribution of male
and female literates from each
state then here we saw how to find out
the bottom three cities for each state
having lowest female graduates now one
thing marked that some of the states did
not have three cities for example
Andaman had only one city that was Port
player but the others we found out the
bottom three cities that had the lowest
Fe fale graduates finally we looked at
how to create a calculated field in a
pivote table so we saw how to create a
calculated field called Sals and then we
explored how to create different charts
and graphs so this was an area chart
that we saw there a column chart we also
saw or looked at a bar chart that was a
horizontal bar chart similarly we saw
how to create a pie chart as well
in this video we'll be creating two
dashboards using a sample sales data set
so if you want to get the data and the
dashboard file that we'll be creating in
this demo then please put your email IDs
in the comment section of the video our
team will share the files via
email now let's begin by understanding
what is a dashboard in
Excel a dashboard is a visual interface
that provides an overview of key
measures relevant to a particular
objective with the help of charts and
graphs dashboard report s allow managers
to get a high level overview of the
business and help them make quick
decisions there are different types of
dashboards such as strategic dashboards
analytical dashboards and operational
dashboards an advantage of dashboards is
the quick detection of outliers and
correlations with Comprehensive data
visualization it is time-saving as
compared to running multiple
reports with this understanding let's
jump into our demo for creating our
dashboards we'll be using a sample sales
data set let me show you the data set
first so here is the sales data set that
we'll be using for our demo so this data
set was actually generated using a
simulator and is completely random it
was not validated though we have applied
certain transformations to the data
using power query features so this data
as you can see has thousand TRS so using
the simulator we had generated thousand
rows of
data similarly if if I go on top you can
see this data set has 17 columns now let
me give you a brief about each of the
columns so first we have the region
column so we have Middle East and North
Africa there North America Asia
subsaharan Africa and others similarly
we have the country names from which the
item was ordered the third column is the
item type so we have different items
Cosmetics vegetables there's baby food
cereal fruits Etc then we have the
representatives name or you can see this
as the customer name who ordered the
product then we have a sales Channel
column so there are basically two
channels whether the item was sold
offline or online next we have the order
priority column now here C stands for
critical then we have H which is for
high priority orders then we have M for
medium priority orders and finally we we
have L which is for low priority orders
you can see the order date column then
we have the order ID the ship date next
we have units sold which is basically
the total number of units sold for each
item then we have the unit price column
this is the price at which each product
was sold then we have the unit cost
column which is basically the production
cost for each of the items next we have
the total revenue the tottal revenue is
actually the product of unit sold and
unit price then we have the total cost
column now the total cost column is
actually the product of unit sold and
the unit cost similarly we have the
total profit column so total profit is
the difference between total revenue and
the total cost and finally we have
created two more columns that is order
year and then we have order month now
these two columns were actually
generated using the power query features
so we use the order date column which is
this column and extracted order year and
Order
month so first we are going to create a
revenue dashboard where we'll focus on
generating reports for Revenue by order
year Revenue by year and region Revenue
by order priority and much more we'll
create separate P tables and po charts
and format them to make them look more
interesting and presentable We'll add
slices timeline to our dashboards in
order to filter it based on specific
Fields now let's create our first report
to see the total revenue generated each
year so we need to create a peot table
for this I'll click on a cell in my data
set and then I'll go to the insert tab
here we have the option to select the
pivote table I click on this you can
see my table range is
selected next I want to place my pivote
table in a new worksheet and let's just
click on okay there you go so we have a
new sheet where I can place my PO
table so first I need to find the total
revenue generated by each year so what
I'll do is I'll drag my order ear column
under rows and then I'll select the
total revenue column under
values you can see I have my pwo chart
ready now if you want you can sort this
so from the data you can see we have
order Year from 2010 to
2017 now based on this data let's create
our pivote chart so I'll click on any
cell go to insert and here you have the
option to select recommended charts I
click on this now actually I want a line
chart so I'll click on line here and and
select
okay there you go so we have
successfully created our first pivote
chart now let me show you how you can
format this chart to make it more
readable so first let me delete these so
I'll right click and select hide all
field buttons on the chart so this will
delete the buttons present on the chart
now let me go ahead and edit the chart
title so so the title I want is total
revenue I'll type it
down by
Year all right next let's do a few more
Transformations so if I click on this
plus sign which is actually for chart
elements we have some options like to
add access access titles chart title
data labels this grid lines Legend and
others okay so let's remove the legend
now you can see the total Legend is gone
now let me add axis titles so we'll
label our x-axis and y axis so here
under
xaxis I can write it
as
ear similarly on the y axis I'll put
Revenue okay now you can move a bit all
right
now let me select this chart Style
option and go to Colors
first here I'll select yellow color okay
and then let me go back to style let's
select a new style from this
list I
want this style okay now you can also
add
data labels so I'll just click on data
labels you can see we have the revenue
for each of the years now this is not
readable at all so we'll format this a
bit if I click on this Arrow here I have
more
options if I scroll down you can see we
have something called as number here
I'll expand this and under category I'll
select
custom now here we'll give a format
code which is a bit
different so this is actually a kind of
a formula so I'll write if my Revenue
value is greater than let's say 9 lakh
999,000 let me make sure there are six n
here so 1 2 3 4 5 and six okay we are
good to go I'll close the
bracket I'll give a
hash give two
commas so if the revenue is greater than
9 lak
99,000 I'll put it in the format of
millions So within double Cotes I'll
write
M I'll give a
semicolon followed by another hash
and if the value is less than the
desired
number it should be 0 million let me
click on
add all right you can see how nicely we
have formatted our data and you see here
we
have added the new format which is in
millions all right now if you want you
can go ahead and adjust
the boxes let me me move this a bit up
I'll delete this now if you notice this
line chart you can make a few
conclusions for example if you see here
in
2010 the total revenue generated was
nearly 175 million now this came down to
150 million in
2011 then the revenue constantly grew
from 2011 till
2014 it reached 195 million and after
200 14 it again came down to 180 million
and the revenue dropped significantly
between 2016 and 2017 in 2017 the
revenue was just 96
million now before moving ahead to my
next chart let me just rename this sheet
so I'll write it as
Revenue by Year all
right now
now let's analyze the revenue generated
each year in different regions so for
this we'll create another peot table let
me close this I'll click on any cell go
to insert and select pivote table I'll
just click okay so that my P table is
placed on a new sheet all right now this
time we want the revenue by each year
and region so first of all let's drag
region to
columns
then let's drag the order ear column
under rows and then I'll select total
revenue onto values so here you can see
we have the pivote table ready so for
2010 you can see in Asia this was the
revenue generated similarly if you see
for
2013 this was the total revenue
generated in Europe and we have for
other years as well now let's create a
line chart based on this pivote table so
I'll select any cell in the pivote table
I'll go to insert and I'll click on
recommended charts from this list I'll
select my line chart and click on okay
there you go so we have our next pivote
chart
ready so on the right you see the
different regions that are present in
different colors let me just expand it
so that you can see all the regions we
have so in total we
have 7
regions and each of the regions have
been represented in different
colors so if you notice this
graph for the subsaharan African region
in
2012 subsaharan Africa meet the highest
amount of
sales now from the sample data you can
also tell that the revenue for North
America has been significantly low
compared to other regions similarly if
you
see for
Europe This was the revenue Trend
between 2010 and
2017 so if you see here in 2011 the
sales where at this level then it
significantly dropped in
2012 then in 20
3 there was a huge Spike and then in
again came down in 2015 and so on so you
can make your own conclusions by looking
at these line charts now let's format
this chart so first of all let's delete
the field buttons present on the chart
and we'll
also delete the Legend all right now let
me just reduce the size of the chart
next we'll add a chart title
so
we'll give the title as
Revenue
by year and
region
okay you can also format the y axis in
terms of
millions so I'll right click on this
axis and I'll select format
access I'll scroll down and here we have
the number drop down let me scroll again
under category I'll select custom and
will use this format that we created for
our previous chart there you go you can
see our access labels have been changed
in terms of millions now so let's close
this and let me save it now you can
reduce the f font size or increase the
font size let me just show you suppose
you want to increase the font size of
the chart title so you just select it
and from here you can either reduce or
you can increase you can see now it's 12
if you want you can make it 16 similarly
you can also edit the access labels also
by selecting the chart title you can
also move it to left or right or you can
place it in the center as well for the
time being let me just keep it to the
left all right
now we'll see the revenue and total cost
by each region and we'll create a combo
chart for this so let me show you how to
do it I'll go to my data sheet I have my
cell selected go to insert and click on
pivote table let me just click on okay
all right so for
this I'll select my region onto
rows and then
I'll
have two columns under values the first
one is going to be total revenue and the
next column will be the total cost
column all right so here we have the
pivote table ready now based on this
pivote table let's create our pivote
chart so I'll go to recommended charts
and if you see below at the bottom we
have combo chart so this is the preview
of the combo chart
all right now let me just click on
okay there you go so we have a nice
combo chart ready here now the way to
look at it is the bars represent the
total revenue which is this
column now the line
represents the total cost so let me go
ahead and edit this chart a bit so first
of all let's delete the field buttons
all right and let's also remove the
legend from
here next we'll add data labels so I'll
click on data labels here okay so these
are the data labels
for the bars or the revenue column now
let's format the data labels in terms of
millions so I'll click on this Arrow go
to more options if I scroll down I have
number from here I'll select custom
and I'll choose my type that is in
millions all right so you can see we
have formatted our data next thing we'll
add a chart title so here I'll write as
Revenue
by
region it's actually revenue and total
cost by
region before moving ahead let me rename
the sheets as well I'll write revenue
and total
cost
similarly sheet three also I'm going to
rename it as
Revenue
by year and
region so this makes your sheet more
readable all right now moving
ahead next we are interested to get the
revenue generated by order priority and
for this we are going to create a pie
chart so let's go to the data sheet and
create our P table first I click on okay
now I'll select order priority under
rows and under values I'll select total
revenue so this is a very simple pivote
table so you have your order priority so
C is for critical H is for high L is for
low and M is for medium now based on
this let's create a pie chart so I'll go
to recommended charts and here you have
pie chart I want to select this 3D type
of pie chart and I'll click on okay all
right so we have our pie chart ready let
me just resize it and from here I'll
remove the field buttons and I also
don't need the legend so I'll delete
this as well all right now let's give a
chart title so this is going to be
Revenue
by order
priority now let's add our data labels
I'll check this
option okay now let's again format this
in terms of
millions so
here I'll click on the last option I'll
go to numbers under category I'll select
custom and my type is going to be in
terms of millions there you go let me
close
this I will just move this to the
center
all
right now if you want you can change the
color of the text as well so let's have
it in white color and see how it looks
okay so this looks pretty decent
cool now moving to our next report so
this
time we are going to find the total
revenue by countries so we have multiple
countries present present in our data
set we want to visualize the revenue
generated in each country so for this we
are going to create a horizontal bar
chart so let me show you how to do it
but before moving ahead let me just
rename this sheet so I'll write
Revenue
by I'll just put op which stands for
order priority all right now let's
create our horizontal bar chart I'll go
to insert click on pivote table and
select
okay so I want my Revenue based on
different countries so I'll select
country and put it under row and then
I'll choose total revenue and place it
under values so here you have the
different country names we have
Afghanistan this Albania let me scroll
down you have
Bangladesh there
are a number of countries you have Czech
Republic there's Estonia France Gabon
similarly if you scroll down we have
India there's Jamaica Italy and all the
way to the bottom if you go we have New
Zealand the Netherlands Philippines
Portugal we also
have
Singapore lots and lots of
countries we have the UAE United States
of America Zimbabwe and
others all right let me go up so based
on this pivote table let's create our
pivote chart so I'll go to insert and
select recommended charts from here I'm
going to select the column chart you can
see the preview here and let me click on
okay all right so here you can
see the different country names at the
bottom and the revenue for each of the
countries let's go ahead and edit this
chart so first of all I'll
delete the field buttons okay and let me
also remove the
legend here I'll write
Revenue
by
countries this going to be my chart
title
okay let's format this chart a little
more so I'll click on this option and
we'll select a new style let's
say I'll
select style six okay and let me now go
under colors and we'll select the color
of the bars so let's choose this color
okay so you have a horizontal column
chart ready and at the bottom you can
see the different country names and we
have
the revenue
cool now let me go ahead and rename this
sheet so I'll write Revenue
by
countries and hit enter
okay and finally we'll create another
report which is going to be part of our
Revenue dashboard and this is revenue by
items so we'll visualize our revenue for
different items present in the table so
if you see this we have Cosmetics
vegetables cereal fruits the cloths
snacks households and other products as
well so let's check the revenue for each
of these
items so we'll continue the same drill
I'll create my poot table on a new
worksheet and this time I'm going to
drag item type under row
and we'll have the total revenue under
values so here on the left of the table
you can see we have the different item
names and then we have the total revenue
so let me just s this total
revenue from largest to smallest so you
can see here office supplies meet the
highest amount of Revenue followed by
household then cosmetics and fruits meet
the lowest amount of
Revenue I'll click on this go to insert
and select recommended charts this time
I'm going to create a bar chart so this
is how my bar chart is going to look
like I'll select okay all right now
let's format this chart a
bit I'll delete the field buttons and
I'll delete the legend as
well and
let's edit the chart title so this is
going to
be
Revenue by items
cool we also want to change
the color of the bars so I've have
selected all the bars I'll go to my home
Tab and here let's say I want to select
green color all
right
I've edited my chart a bit
now
let's make
it
14 and I'll remove the
Bold okay here if you want you can
change the font Also let's keep it in
blue color all
right finally let's rename this sheet so
I'll write Revenue by items
cool finally now it's time for us to
merge all the charts that we have
created to our dashboard so let me show
you how you can create the dashboard
I'll create a new sheet and first thing
I'm going to do is I'll click on The
View Tab and uncheck grid lines so this
will remove the grid lines present in
the
worksheet next I'm going to insert an
image so we'll have a background image
on our dashboard so the way to do is
I'll go to the insert Tab and under
illustrations I have the option to
select pictures or insert pictures so
I'm going to insert picture present on
the device that is my
computer I'll go to desktop and here I
have a folder called Excel dashboard
files
and I'll select this dashboard
background and hit
insert so this is going to insert an
image now let me just drag this image so
it covers a Fen of
portion so I'll hit shift and I'll drag
it all
right so you can see I have success y
added a background image if you want you
can
still expand this background image a bit
to the right
cool now the next
thing is going to be the title of the
dashboard so I'll click on insert and
here I have the option to select a text
box so I'll click on a text box
and I'm going to place a text box in the
middle and I'm going to name this text
box as
Excel Revenue
dashboard on
sales
I'll centraline
it let's do some more format so I'll
select this text box on the top you can
see shape
format here I'm going to expand this
shape fill and I'll select no fill so my
text box is transparent now and I'll
also remove the outline all right now
let me just double click on the title of
my dashboard and I'm going to
select a font you can select whichever
font you
want let me stick to britanica bold and
I'll increase the size to let's say
30 all right I'll just drag the text
box I'll make the text as white instead
of black all right so we have
our title of the dashboard ready now if
you want you can also insert some icons
to this dashboard so I'll go to insert
and I'll click on illustrations again
and select
pictures I'm going to
add this two pictures which is of a
store and a
cart to make it
look visually appealing so I'll place
the
icons here and similarly let me just
copy it
it and I'll place
the cart and the
store to the right as
well all
right
next the idea is
to bring in all the charts that we have
created and place it on the
dashboard so let me
copy each of the chart
and place it on the dashboard so I'll
hit control V to paste
it and we'll resize this as
well all
right similarly let me bring in all the
other charts as
well all right so now you can see I have
added all my charts and graphs to this
dashboard so you can see here here we
have our line charts our column charts
the combo charts the Spy chart and
others now let me go ahead and format
these charts a little more so you can
see this looks a bit cluttered so let's
adjust the labels let me bring this down
similarly I'll bring 190
million a little
below all right this looks fine
now one more thing we are going to do
is we'll remove the white background
from each of the charts and make it
transparent so let me show you how to do
it so I'll select this chart then I'll
right click and go to format chart
area here on the right you see we have
an option called No fill so if I select
no fill you can see the white background
is gone now similarly let me also remove
the grid lines so I'll select the grid
lines and hit delete so you have also
removed the grid lines from here now
let's also remove the white outline that
we have so I'll select this chart go to
format and here I'll go to shape outline
and I'll select no outline you see this
so we have our total revenue by year
which is a line chart and this is
completely transparent now now what I'm
going to do is I'll place this chart
over a box so I'll go to insert and in
insert we have the option to create a
shape so I'll click on illustrations and
here I'll choose a shape and let me
select a rectangle so I'll just create a
rectangle
here all right and now what I'll do is
I'll select this and bring this to to
front I'll right click and choose bring
to front and I'll place this
shape below it all right now the next
thing is to edit the shape so first I'll
change the color of this box so let me
select this blue color and and let me
increase the transparency so I'll right
click and go to format shape here I'll
increase the transparency let's keep it
to
25% or let's say 20% all right next
thing we'll just convert all the font to
white
color including the access labels the
chart
title will
also convert all
the access labels to white color so it
looks better now we'll just adjust
our chart over
here next thing let's just remove the
outline so I'll go to shape outline and
I'll select no outline you see we have
now formatted our chart let's just pull
this a little
up all right now we'll add this blue
background to all the other charts so
we'll first add the background make it
transparent and then we'll convert the
font text to white color to make it more
readable and visible so for the time
being I'll just pause the video and come
back
again all right so now you can see on
your screens we have nicely formatted
our dashboard so I have added a few
logos for each of the charts you can see
the logos here so for Revenue by
countries we have a globe then if you
see here this is kind of a map or a
location similarly we have all formatted
the color of the bars then we have also
formatted the labels in terms of
millions if you look on the Y AIS even
the revenue for year and region are all
formatted in terms of
millions if you want this you can also
format the total year by Revenue in
terms of millions so the way to do is
you can select this graph right click
and go to format
access here if I scroll down you have
numbers and under category I'll select
custom then I'll select my type as this
format which is in
millions and you see here we have
successfully formatted our y AIS
labels all right so the next thing is to
add slicers and timelines to a dashboard
now slicers are used to format your data
based on a particular column suppose if
you want to see Revenue by certain items
you can add item as a slicer and you can
view the
entire dashboard similarly for timelines
you can add date columns so if you want
to see what was the amount of s or
revenue generated on a particular year
or a particular month you can do that
using a timeline so I'll select one of
the charts and then either you can go to
the insert Tab and here you can see
under filters we have slices and
timeline or if you go to the pivote
Chart analyze tab here also you have
insert slicer and timeline option so I
select insert slicer here first now it's
giving me the the list of fields present
in the data set so I'll select country
region and let's say we want to know by
item type and sales channel so these are
going to be my four slicers I'll click
on
okay you can see it here we have our
four slicers here and these are the list
of values under region we have Asia this
Europe North America and others
similarly we have the different country
names for Country slices and then for
item type also we have all the items
that were present in our data set
now moving ahead we need to connect all
the slicers to a dashboard so what I'll
do is I'll right
click on this option and I'll go to
report connections okay so under report
connections you have all the pivote
tables that we
created you currently see only one of
the pivot table is selected so we need
to select all the pivot tables so let me
check all the poot tables present in
this workbook and click on okay all
right now that we have connected one of
our slicers we now connect the other
remaining slicers so I'll right click on
this go to report connection s and I'll
check all the pivote tables present in
this worksheet click on okay similarly
let's do it for the country slicer I'll
go to report connections and let me
select all the pivote
tables and finally we have the item type
so I'll right click go to report
connections and then I'll select all my
P
tables and let's hit okay all right now
let me just organize this a bit so I'll
place my Pivot
tables to the
right I'll just reduce the
size let me scroll
down I'll
add my region slicer
here
similarly I'll add my final slicer that
is sales Channel now in our next
dashboard which is going to be the
profit dashboard I'll show you how to
add a
timeline all right now I have arranged
all my
slicers so let's say you want to find
the revenue that was generated for an
item type let's say beverages so you can
just select beverages here and all your
charts show the respective revenues so
you have the total revenue by year for
beverages
only similarly here you can see the
revenue by year and region only for
beverages item type if I scroll
down now this chart represents the
revenue that was generated in each of
the countries only for item type
beverages
let me just uncheck
it all
right let's say you want to
see the revenue generated for a country
like India so I have selected India here
and now you can
see my graph has changed only for
country
India you can see here it is showing
only for India now
now now similarly you can also filter
your revenues based on the different
regions let's say you want to know the
revenue generated based on sales channel
so we have two sales channel that is
offline and online suppose you want to
know the revenue generated offline so
I'll just select offline you can see the
values have changed so these were the
revenues generated for each of the items
only for
offline if you
see here now these were all the offline
sales for the different
regions
so this is our entire Excel Revenue
dashboard on sales we created multiple
charts and graphs then we applied
different formatting we added different
icons then we formatted the labels also
next we added slicers and finally we saw
how we could filter our data based on
these
slicers likewise now we are going to
create a profit dashboard based on the
same data so before moving ahead let me
rename this sheet as Revenue dashboard
I'll write
R dashboard
okay now we'll move to our data sheet
and start creating our P tables and P
charts for the profit
dashboard all right so let me go ahead
and create my first pivote table
so I'll create a new
worksheet this time I'm going to create
a line chart to visualize the profit for
each year so I'll drag my total profit
column to values and my order year two
rows so here you can see we have
our pivote table ready now you can sort
this data to get an idea as to
which year had the highest profit and
which year had the lowest profit so from
this pivote table you can see since I've
sorted this data in descending order so
2014 had the maximum amount of profit
and 2017 had the least amount of profit
I'll just do control Z to do it all
right now based on this P table let me
go ahead and create my P chart so I'll
go to recommended charts and click on a
line chart so this is the preview of the
chart I'll click on okay let me close
this
similarly we are going
to edit this chart now so first I'll
hide all the field buttons present on
the chart and I'll rename the chart
title as
total profit
by
year next I'm going to remove the legend
so I'll delete
this let's do some more
formatting so I'll go to
style
and this
time I'm going to
select my style type okay and if you
want you can choose the colors as well
for the time being let's have this
yellow color next let me add the data
labels so again if you see here this is
not formatted properly so let's go ahead
and format
the data labels so I'll click on
number and I'll select custom
here and the type I'm going to select is
in millions and I'll click on close so
here you can see we have
our line chart ready which shows total
profit by year let's rename this sheet
as
profit
by Year all right now let's move back to
our data sheet
again next we are going to show the
total profit by countries for this I'm
going to create a map so let me first
create my pivote table so I'll go to
insert and I'll click on on pivote
table let me click on
okay since I want the country name so
I'll select country under row and then I
have my total profit under
values the next thing I'm going to do is
I'll just rename the r labels as
countries and then I'm going to delete
the grand total which you can see at the
bottom so here we have the grand grand
total let me just delete the grand total
so I'm going to select this P table go
to the design tab here we have sub
totals and Grand totals I'll switch off
the grand total let me just verify it
again I'll scroll down you see the grand
total has gone now all right now we want
to create a map out of this the way to
do is I'm going to select my
data copy it
I'll go on top and I'll paste it here
using this data I can create my field
map now so I'll go to insert here we
have the option to create a field map
there you go you can see we have our map
ready I can expand this now as you can
see our map has a color scale which
comes from light gray color to dark blue
color so the countries that are in Gray
or you can say light blue have the
lowest amount of profit while the
regions or the countries that have been
shaded
in dark color a dark blue color have
highest amount of profit I will go ahead
and delete this
scale okay next we need to connect this
map to the original data source so what
I'm do is I'll right click on this map
and I'll go to select data here instead
of the previous range I'll give my new
Range now so my new Range will be my
original P table that I had created I'll
go on top and click on okay so we have
our map ready now now if you want you
can change the color of the shade so
I'll just go to colors and let's say
we'll keep green
color so the countries that are shaded
in dark green have the highest amount of
profit while those which are highlighted
in light green color are are the
countries that made least amount of
profit okay now moving
on next we want to create a pivote table
that will show us the profit by year and
sales channel so for this we are going
to create another line chart so I'll go
to insert and click on pivote table so
I'll select new worksheet here since I
want to know the profit by year first of
all I'll drag my order year column to
rows and then I'll choose my total
profit column under values next I'm
going to select my sales Channel under
columns there you go so we have our P
table here based on this P table let me
create my peot chart so I'll go to
recommended charts and I'm going to
create a line chart I close
this you see here based on this chart
you can tell the profit generated with
online sales were actually lower than
that of offline so here the Blue Line
represents offline profit and the Orange
Line represents Online Profit if you
Mark Clearly in year 2012 the Online
Profit was actually higher than the
offline profit so let me go ahead and
edit this chart a bit so we'll delete
the field buttons I'll also delete the
legend for now let me go ahead and add a
chart title so I'll
write
profit
by year
and sales
Channel
okay so this is my
second report before moving ahead let me
just rename this sheet so I'll write
profit
by
countries similarly let me rename this
sheet as
profit by year and let's say SC for
sales
Channel
okay moving
ahead now want to create a pie chart
based on a pivot table that will show
The Profit by sales Channel only so this
is going to be a simple pie chart so
I'll first go to insert click on pivote
table and click on okay so I'll drag my
sales Channel under rows and then we'll
have the total profit column under
values so this is my simple pivote table
now let's create our pivote chart which
is going to be a p chart let me
explore the other types of pie charts we
have okay so I'm going to select a donut
chart here I'll click on okay let's edit
this chart I'll remove the field buttons
let me now remove the legend as well
I'll just resize it and this is going to
be
profit
by sales
Channel
okay let's also
add data
labels and here again I'm going
to format this
label I'll select the category as custom
and my type will be in millions okay let
me just move
this to the left and and this to the
right
okay let's also delete the lines
cool now let me just rename this sheet
so I'll write profit
by let's see which stands for sales
Channel cool finally I'm going to create
a report that will show the revenue and
profit by items so I'll go ahead and
create my pivote table
first this time I'll choose my total
profit under
values and we'll also have the revenue
column so I'll put my Revenue at the top
then I'm going to
select item type under rows so here is
my pivote table based on this pivote
table let me now create a combo chart so
you can see the preview of the chart
the blue bars represent the total
revenue and the Orange Line represents
the total profit I'll click on okay let
me close
this first let's remove the field
buttons let's also
remove the legend
here then we'll add a chart title I'll
name it
as
revenue and
profit by
items okay if you want you can also go
ahead and change the color of the
bars so let me just
select one of these colors
okay all right so we have our five
reports ready that we are going to use
for our profit
dashboard next let's create a new new
sheet and we'll get started with
building a dashboard so I'll click on a
new sheet let me just rename this as
profit
dashboard all right we'll continue with
the previous drill so first of all let's
go to the view Tab and remove the grid
lines now we'll insert a background
image like we did for our Revenue d
dashboard so I'll go to insert under
illustrations I'll click on pictures and
select this device I'm going to have the
same background I'll click on
insert all right so you can see we have
a picture of a company or you can say an
organization let's just drag
this a bit to the
right we'll adjust the size also all
right now let's copy the title of my
profit dashboard so here you can see I
have brought my Revenue
dashboard and I'll copy the title and
the logos that we used for the revenue
dashboard I'll paste it on my new
dashboard let's just align
it in the
center all right the next step if let me
now go ahead and edit the title so this
is actually going to
be
Excel profit dashboard instead of
Revenue now we'll copy each of the
charts that we just created for example
the revenue and profit by items then we
had profit by sales
Channel all this we are going to copy
one by one and put it on the profit
dashboard so let me just copy a few now
I'll paste it
here and later on we can make the
adjustment copy this as
well similarly I'll bring the other
three charts onto my sales
dashboard okay so here on my profit
dashbo I have added all the
charts and I have aligned and reshaped
it so that it looks good I've also made
some formatting for example I've have
reduced the size of the chart
title now let me go ahead and show you a
few more formatting that we also did for
the revenue dashboard first let's remove
the white background from all the charts
so I'll select the first chart I'll
right click and I'll click on format
chart area here under fill I'll select
no fill next I'm going to remove the
grid lines so I'll just delete it let me
close this now we also have a outline so
I'll go to
design actually format and I'll remove
the
outline next I'm going to
add a blue box at the back like how we
did for the revenue dashboard so let me
select blue box from here and I'm going
to paste it here okay and let me just
select the chart and I'll bring this to
front and I'll move
this to the
back next I'm going to change the font
color all to White so that it's clearly
visible and it's more
readable I'll do it for the x-axis as
well okay so here I have my
first chart ready the same I'm going to
do for the rest of the
charts okay so now you can see here I
have formatted all my charts I've also
added a blue
background you see here I have also
formatted the Y labels in terms of
millions which is actually the profit
similarly here I have added the data
labels this is for
Revenue some of the charts also have the
data Legends so here you can see the
blue color represents
offline and the red represents online
similarly here you have the Legends I've
also formatted the map as well okay now
the next thing is to make this dashboard
more interactive so we'll add our
slicers as well as timeline first let me
show you how to add a timeline so I'll
select one of the charts and I'll go to
insert under insert I have the option to
create a timeline so I'll
just click on
timelines so timeline is actually based
on date columns so since in our data set
we only have two date columns one is
order date and one is ship date so Excel
has only shown us two columns so I'm
going to create my timeline based on
order date so I'll select my order date
column and I'll click on okay you can
see here this is called a timeline I can
expand this now this timeline is based
on months now if I scroll this timeline
you can see here I have my order year
2010 and I have all the 12 months
similarly we have for 2011 then we have
for 2012 all the way till
2017 now you can filter this in terms of
years quarters months or days let me
just select year now so I have
years from 2010 till 2017 let me just
squiz this and I'll place it somewhere
here on the
right now let me go ahead and create a
few slicers for my profit dashboard so I
have selected one of the charts under
insert I'll click on
slicer you can see it gives me the list
of columns from which I want to create
slicers so I'll create region let me
also select
country let's say I
want the representatives name or the
customer's name and I'll click on okay
so here I have created three
slicers let
me first resize it and I'll place
it on the
right similarly I place the country
column
also
then we have the region
slicer I'll resize this and I'll bring
it here okay the next thing we need to
do is I have to connect all the slicers
and the timeline to the pivot tables for
the profit dashboard so I'm going to
click
on the multiple select option and go to
report connections here I'm going to to
select all the pivote tables that are
related to
profit so here I have selected four and
I need one more which is po table number
10 I click on okay similarly let's
create or connect my region filter to
all the pivote tables so I right click
go to report connections here I'll
choose all my pivote tables which are
based on
profit I'll click on okay let's do it
for the country slicer as
well click on okay and similarly I'll
connect my timeline as well I'll go to
report
connections and I'll
select all the pivote tables related to
profit then I'll click on okay let me
now go ahead and create another slicer
based on sales channel so I'm selecting
one of the P charts
I'll go to insert click on slicer and
I'll select sales Channel and hit
okay so I have my sales Channel slicer
now let me connect it to all the
respective P
tables that are based on
profit click on
okay now let me just bring it here all
right the next thing I want to show is
how are we going to use the timeline
first so you see we have all
the years here from 2010 till
2017 now suppose you want to know the
profit that was generated in the year
2012 so I'll just click on this range
and now you can see our charts only so
information for 2012 so this dot
represents there was 51 million profit
in the year 2012 similarly you can see
here the profit by sales channel for
2012 from the map you can see the
different countries and the profit each
of these countries made in
2012 if I scroll down you can see the
revenue and profit by items now if I
select another year let's say
2013 I can just drag this to the right
and now you can
see our profit by year and sales channel
for offline and online you can see the
map or the line chart for total profit
by year so in 2012 it was 51 million and
then it went up to 54 million in
similarly our map has also changed now
this is a sort of an information that we
have you can click on this
and check the information that Excel has
prompted all right so this is how you
can use a timeline now as I said we
checked by years you can also see it for
months and quarters as well let me just
uncheck
it I'll send it back to the place where
it was and I'll reduce the
size okay now suppose you want to check
the profit made by different
Representatives you can select them one
by one let's say Adam Churchill this is
the profit generated by Adam
churel similarly you can select multiple
persons as well suppose you want to see
the profit by different countries so you
can use the country slicer let me just
bring this to the middle and let's
expand our chart a
bit okay so here you have
the profit by different countries chart
I'll just bring this to the front so
that you can see it clearly okay now
here suppose you want to see the profit
generated in let's say United Kingdom
you can select United Kingdom so this is
the map of United Kingdom and it tells
you the total profit that was generated
in United Kingdom
and Below you can see the revenue and
profit for all the items that was sold
in United Kingdom so you had beverages
cloths household office supplies you can
see clearly office supplies item meet
the highest amount of profit in United
Kingdom now you can also select multiple
countries let's say I want to know for
France as well so my
map will change accordingly so now I
have United Kingdom and France selected
and the other charts present in my
dashboard change accordingly now I have
my country selected as India you can see
the map of India
here and these were the respective
profit values now one thing to note here
is this is actually not Millions this
should be in K that is Thousands so
please mark this as thousand and not in
millions even for this this is actually
K and not million all right so we have
successfully created our second
dashboard that is on profit let me just
resize this a bit and we'll place it
where it was
earlier
cool so we saw how to create different P
tables and poot charts and then we
formatted our P charts based on our
requirement we saw how to edit the
colors now let me show you one more
thing you can also change the look and
feel of the dashboard by going to the
page layout tab under page layout you
have themes so here you can select
different themes currently we are with
the office theme now let me just select
another theme let's say faet you see the
colors have changed and it
looks really
beautiful similarly let me try out
another theme let's say organic you see
our chart has changed let me just delete
this okay so now once you change the
theme the text also change a bit you can
see the slicers are in a different
font let me explore one One More theme
let's say this time I'm going to choose
depth and this is more of a green type
of
color you can play around and select
whatever theme suits the best all
right now let me just move back to my
Revenue dashboard and see how it looks
there you go so since we changed our
theme even our Revenue dashboard is also
impacted
so this is how it looks
now you can always go ahead and play
with different themes colors fonts and
effects all right so in this demo we saw
how to create a revenue dashboard so we
created line charts this combo chart pie
chart horizontal and vertical bar charts
and then we learned how to add slicers
and connected to different P tables and
we filtered our data to see Revenue as
well as profit by items by countries by
different regions sales Channel we
learned how to create a map and lots
more if you are a professional with
minimum one year of experience and an
aspiring data analyst looking for online
training and certifications from
prestige I universities in collaboration
with leading experts to enhance your
credibility then search no more simply
lears postgraduate program and data
analytics offered by per University in
collaboration with IBM is just what you
need for more details head straight to
our homepage or simply click on the link
in the description box below now without
further delay over to our training let's
quickly see some more examples of doing
data analysis using Excel and for that
we can use some inbuilt addins which can
be added to our Excel sheet so for
example if you would want to do a
descriptive analytics or descriptive
analysis on your data say for example
getting your descriptive statistics such
as your mean median mode and so on so we
can do that and we can use Excel for it
so for example you can if you are given
some data say I have temperature price
of ice cream unit sold and I would want
to have descriptive statistics on this
what I can do is I can click on file and
here in file you can click on options
and within options click on addin now
within addin you have Excel addin which
is selected here so click on say go for
example and that shows what addins are
available and you can choose which ones
are you interested in so for example I
have chosen analysis tool pack and
solver addin and click on okay now that
basically should add more options to
your Excel so if you click on data so
here you see data analysis and solver
and this is what we would want to use to
get our descriptive statistics for these
three columns so for example let's say
temperature or you can even give the
names later once you get your
descriptive statistics so for example
let's go for data analysis and here it
says what are you interested in there is
a two factor with replication you have
correlation
co-variance descriptive statistics you
have histogram so let's click on
descriptive statistics click on okay now
this one basically asks your input range
so while your cursor is blinking here
also it is said grouped by so let's give
it a range so for example I will say say
temperature now if I do this and I have
selected The Heading just look at that
and now you need an output range so
let's just select this and then you can
have your cursor blinking in here let's
select say Fields here and this is where
I would want the output now it also say
what options do you want so it has
output range we can then select summary
statistics confidence level so I will
say summary statistics is what I'm
interested in say okay and this says
input input range contains non numeric
data now why is that because we chose
temperature The Heading also so click on
okay and here we will alter the range so
this one is our range should be only the
values numeric values on which we would
want the descriptive statistics we have
output range already selected we have
summary statistics and now you can click
on okay and that basically gives your
descriptive statistics for temperature
so here I could basically given a value
for this so I can say
temperature and that's my descriptive
statistics for temperature might be I
can just do some
formatting and
that's it so that gives me descriptive
statistics for the values here now
similarly we can do it for price of ice
cream so what we need is we need to
basically go for
data data analysis descriptive
statistics say okay now you need to give
a range so here I will change my range
to these values output range is already
selected now we are interested in
summary statistics click on okay and
this says output range will overwrite
existing data press okay to overwrite
data in range I will say cancel no
that's not what we want to do we need to
give a new Range so let's select our new
Range which is here and now click on
okay so now we get the values which is
for your price of ice cream
so again we can basically select this
and say price of ice
cream and we got our descriptive
statistics for price of ice cream and
like we did earlier I can select this I
can basically do a merge and center and
that gives me descriptive statistics for
price of ice cream so we could also
basically change this now I can go into
data and I can go into Data
analysis descriptive statistics so we
know that we had selected this B2 to B8
and this one which is H6 to h19 we would
want to shift it might be two columns up
so might be I can just say
H5 and I can manually change it to
H17 and let's say
okay and we will basically get this and
I can get rid of this so I can have it
in the same range so similarly so this
one will have to be renamed and I can
basically say price of ice
cream and that's basically my
descriptive statistics for my price of
ice
cream and similarly we can do it for the
third column which is units sold so we
would want to have this now Let's see we
can click on data we can click on data
analysis descriptive statistics so we
need to give the range correctly so this
time our range changes to units sold now
we can also say labels in first row okay
if we were selecting The Heading so
let's do it in this way so in my range
in my range let me empty this I can
basically select this which we know has
non-numeric data in the first row say
for example I'll say labels in first row
I'm interested in summary statistics and
this range will now have to be changed
from H to basically something like J so
let's say J and let's select these
values so that should take care of
things and now you see you have your
units sold you not have to manually
rename it and you have basically got the
descriptive statistics so this is how
you can simply perform analysis using
data analysis here you can basically get
your descriptive statistics for your
columns and then you can do whatever
needed formatting you need to basically
make your data look in a good way now
let's look at one more example of data
analysis
where we may want to look at the
frequency of values or frequency of
values occurring in a range of values so
for example if you have been given
temperatures you have been given some
pins where you would want to identify
how many values fall into the range of 0
to 20 20 to 30 30 to 40 40 to 50 and the
easiest way to do that would be creating
histogram now histogram is usually used
for data analysis where you would want
to look at different variables or say
features for example temperature is one
such feature might be there might be one
more variable or feature such as sale of
ice cream and you would want to see if
the increase or decrease in temperature
affects the increase or decrease in sale
of ice cream might be sale of ice cream
is a is a response based on temperature
so it depends so sometimes you may want
to find a relationship between two
variables whether they are positively or
negatively related or you would want to
do different kind of analysis and in
certain cases we may want to First do
analysis on one single variable look at
the frequency of values might be also
look at the defects and for which we can
use something like paror chart so we can
go for histogram and that basically
gives us the frequency of values now how
do we do that so we have already added
the addin which is data analysis earlier
so we can just use the same thing again
here we would want to create a histogram
so let's say okay now I have already
selected input rure which is also with
the headings and I have bin range which
is basically the range of values so for
example I can select this and that's my
PIN range I am selecting or the option
labels because I'm using the first row
which has the heading such as
temperature and bins now we need to give
a output range so for example let's say
I would want my data here and that
becomes my output range so you can have
a sorted histogram or basically a par
chart so if that's what you're
interested in looking at the frequencies
for your different ranges and here I'm
also selecting chart output because I
would want to have a visual histogram
which gives us the frequency and it's as
simple as this just click on okay and
now you get your pins so it basically
tells you frequency of values which is
basically 20 but that does not mean it
is only talking about the values 20 it
is basically talking as a range of 0 to
20 so we have 0 to 20 that is 2 so we
can basically say there is one 12 here
with the 20 being the maximum value and
then there is one more 20 so that's your
0 to 20 then you have 20 to 30 which
shows three values so might be in that
case I can say
26 is one thing then I can say 30 that's
the second one and then basically I can
look at 22 so basically this one does
not select 20 as the lower range but it
basically selects 30 as the higher range
so I do see 20 to 30 there are three
entries similarly we can see values for
40 and 50 and since we have selected
Paro or sorted histogram that shows in a
descending order what is the highest
frequency of values within a particular
range so that shows me highest frequency
is five and then you have three and
three and then two so this is how we can
create a histogram and we can perform
analysis on a single variable now as
discussed earlier as I said sometimes we
may be interested in finding out the
coration between different variables
such as say here we have temperature
price of ice cream and units sold and we
may want to find out the correlation
between one variable to another varable
variable or we would want to find out
the relationship between variables are
they linearly related are they
positively related negatively related
and so on and for that we can use the
correlation of your data analysis add in
so for example you want to find out
correlation of temperature and units
sold and what we can do is we can find
out that using a formula so for example
if I search for something like
coration and let's search so there is a
function called correlation which we can
use and we can use this to calculate the
correlation of temperature and units
sold so for example let's select this
and that's the function so it says give
me an first array and a second array so
we are interested in finding out
correlation of temperature and units
sold so let's select the range of values
for temperature and then I'm interested
in finding out the correlation of
temperature and units sold so let's
select this and that basically gives me
a range of values it gives me the
correlation value which is
2859 say okay and that's your value so
similarly we can do it for temperature
and price ice cream so let's go
for correlation so that's the function
we are interested in you need to give a
range of values so here we are
interested in temperature and price of
ice cream so let's select temperature
and then the second array or list of
values is price of ice cream let's
select that let's close our bracket and
here we have the correlation value of
temperature and the price of ice cream
similarly you may be interested in
finding out temperature and units sold
like what we have done earlier so we can
do the same thing based on function so
this is same as correlation of
temperature and unit sold so I can get
rid of this one now how do I do it using
the data analysis add in so for that
what we need is we need to go into Data
we need to go click on data analysis and
here you have the option called
correlation let's select this now that
basically needs an input range so we
need the range now I might be interested
in finding out the correlation between
temperature and price of ice cream and
units sold so I've selected all the
columns here we will say Group by
columns obviously we need to select
labels in first row because that is
basically taking care of the first row
is heading now output range you can just
give one simple cell and that's where
your data will start from or you can
give a new workbook so click on okay and
that basically gives
you
that basically gives your correlation of
your different variables and what are
the values and we can check these values
based on the values what we have here so
we have basically temperature and price
of ice
cream and that basically shows me
96149 you have temperature and units
sold so you have
2859 now you can also look at units sold
and say for example price of ice cream
you can look at these particular values
so if I would be interested in finding
out what is the relationship between
these variables I can easily find using
correlation so I could be basically
writing in a formula here and selecting
what are the cells so here we were
selecting A2 and C here we were
selecting A and B now might be I'm
interested in price of ice cream and
units sold and if that's what I'm
interested in then I will give a range
of B2 to B8 C2 to C8 and similarly you
can get your analysis or correlation
values so it's very simple in Excel and
you can use either the data analysis Tab
and get your correlation or you can use
formulas and do that now one more
important part of data analysis is doing
your sampling now sampling could be
periodic sampling or random sampling so
sometimes you may want to look at a
variable and you may want to get some
values based on periodic data that means
might be I'm interested in range of
values I'm interested in seeing a sample
of values
for uh a particular period which could
be basically
uh a range of values or you could just
do a random sampling so for example if I
go for periodic sampling so out of these
values which I see here might be I want
to see say periodic sampling that is a
frequency of two values how many times
we have these values occurring here or I
would go for random sampling so
basically randomly I would want to pick
up say three temperature values now how
do I do it so for example here I have
seven values now if I go for periodic
sampling the sample or periodic sample
value which I need to give has to be
lesser than the total input
values so for example we can do this
let's go in here and let's go for data
analysis so we can go for sampling here
click on okay and that needs a range of
values so we will select A2 to A8 now I
could have selected all the values for
this one temperature and in that case I
can give labels which is going to take
care of the first row now here we can go
for number of samples which you are
interested in or giving a period so
let's go for period and say for example
I have seven values so what if I select
five so for example if I say five that
means I could just get one value so
basically when I'm saying five out of
seven so that's just giving me out of
five I want one value so I can then just
give an output range so here I can
basically select this cell I'll say okay
and now you see it just shows me one
value so out of the first range that is
I have said five it has given me the
fifth value that's your periodic
sampling so for example we want more
values so let's reduce this period to
might be two which basically gives me
every second value so I can basically
say for example two and say okay and
then say okay so that shows me
26 then you have 35 then you have 40 and
then well this one does not have any
more values so that's your periodic
sampling now if you go for random
sampling that's basically randomly
picking up values and you can choose how
many values you want so go for data
analysis go for sampling I'll go for
number of samples how many you want so
for example out of seven values randomly
I want three values and I can just give
this say okay and then
we will do a cancel because we need to
change that range so let's select this
and say okay and that gives me random
three values from this values of
temperature so we can use Excel to do a
simple sampling and we can choose
whether we would want to go for want to
be a certified data expert then here we
have postgraduate program in data
analytics by simply learn take a glance
at the notable features and skills
offered in this course you you will
benefit from exclusive IBM hackathons
and ask me anything sessions eight times
more interaction in live online classes
with industry experts Capstone projects
across three domains and over 14 data
analytics projects using real data sets
from Google Play Store lyt World Bank
and more master classes from puu faculty
and IBM experts along with simply learns
job assist for better job prospects
acquire skills in data analytics
statistical analysis using Excel data
analysis using Python and R and data
visualization using Tableau and powerbi
enroll Now using the course Link in the
description box hello everyone and
welcome to this interesting video
tutorial by simply loan today we're
going to perform two Hands-On projects
on covid data analysis using Python and
tblo this is going to be a really
interesting and fun session where I'll
be asking you a few generic quiz
questions related to Corona virus please
make sure to answer them in the comment
section of the video we'll be happy to
hear from you covid or Corona virus is
an ongoing Global pandemic of Corona
virus disease that emerged in 2019 and
was first identified in Wuhan China it
is defined as an illness caused by a
novel Corona virus called severe acute
respiratory syndrome Corona virus 2
commonly known as SARS Co 2 on March 11
2020 the who declared covid-19 a global
Health Emergency the virus has so far
infected over 22 CR people and killed
more than 4.5 million Innocents in India
there have been over 3.3 CR confirmed
cases and nearly 441,000 deaths have
been reported so
far this data is according to official
figures released by The Union Ministry
of Health and Family
welfare as the world tries to cope up
with this deadly virus we request all
our viewers and their family members to
follow all the necessary precautions to
avoid getting
infected quiz time
now let's see our first quiz in this
project what does Corona in Corona virus
mean here are the options is it a
beer B respiratory is it C crown or is
it d sun this is a very generic question
I'm sure a lot of you may already know
some of you may
not please let us know your answers in
the comment section of the video we'll
be glad to hear from
you now in this video we will use three
different covid-19 data sets and perform
data analysis using Python and tblo the
project will give you hands-on
experience working on real world data
sets and how you can use the different
python libraries to analyze and
visualize data and draw conclusions you
will learn how to create different plots
in Tableau and then make a dashboard
from the visuals the project will give
you an idea about the impact of Corona
virus globally in terms of confirmed
cases deaths
reported the number of of recoveries as
well as Active
cases we will also see how India has
been affected since the pandemic started
and dive into the different states and
union territories to learn more about
the covid-19 influence and the
vaccination status first let me show you
the two data sets that we'll be using so
for our first project using python we'll
be using the first two data sets
covid-19 India and covid vaccine
statewise let me open the two data
sets
okay so this is the first data set you
can see here we have the date we have
the time then we have the different
state names I scroll down you can see we
have Kerala Tamil Nadu Delhi harana
Rajasthan this ladak Punjab telengana
and other states then we have something
called as confirmed Indian national so
actually this two data sets confirmed
Indian national and confirmed forign
National we won't be using so in the
demo itself we'll be dropping these two
columns what we are concerned about are
the last three columns the cured cases
or the recoveries the number of deaths
reported and then we have the total
number of confirmed cases let me just
sort the B column that is the date
column so that you have an idea about
the recent data we have I'll continue
with the current selection
and sort it you can see here this is
till 11th of August
20121 so this data was collected from
Kel it has some discrepancies that we
will see in the demo the data is
available for free we will provide the
link to the data sets in the description
of the video so please go ahead and
download them the visualizations and
results that you will see in the demo
are based on the data sets that we'll be
using we haven't pre-processed the data
to REM remove outliers or any missing
values now before I jump into the demo
let me show you the second data set that
we are going to use okay so covid
vaccine statewise is my second data set
let me open it there you go
so this is the second data set that
we'll be using in the python project you
can see we have a column called updated
on then we have the state again you can
see here there are a few discrepancies
here uh it has taken the country name
and not the state name below you can see
there are the different state
names
and you can also see we have information
about the total doses administered we
have the sessions sites first do
administered then we have the second do
then we have information about male and
female doses you can see here the
different vaccines administered
covaccine and coov shield you have
Sputnik V and here are the different age
groups as well and finally if you see we
have male individuals vaccinated the
total number of female individuals
vaccinated for a particular day we have
information about transgender
individuals vaccinated and finally we
have the total individuals vaccinated
each day all right before we jump into
the Hands-On part let's have a look at
this second quiz in this
project so here is the second quiz
question which is the first country to
start covid vaccination for toddlers is
it a Japan B Israel C Portugal or is it
D Cuba this is a very recent development
that took place if you watch Daily News
updates on Corona virus you'll be
definitely able to answer the question
please give it a try and put your
answers in the comment section of the
video it is really important for our
viewers to know the right
answer all right so now let's begin with
our
demo so I am on my jupyter notebook so
the first project we are going to use
Python jupyter notebook I'll just rename
this notebook as
covid data
analysis
project I'll click on
rename all right so first and foremost
we need to import all the necessary
libraries that we are going to use so
first I'm importing pandas aspd this is
for data manipulation then we have nump
as NP nump is used for numerical
computation then we are importing
matplot lib cbor and plotly these three
libraries will be used for plotting our
data and creating interesting
visualizations finally I'm also
importing my date time function all
right so I'll hit shift enter to run the
first cell now it's time to load our
first data set which is related
to the covid-19 cases in India for the
different states and union
territories so I'll create a variable
called coore DF DF is for data frame
I'll use my pandas
library and
then give the read CSV fun function
since our data sets are CSV files and
inside double codes I'll pass in the
location where my data sets are present
so I'll just copy this
location I'll paste it
here we'll
change the back slash to forward
slash and after that I'm going to give
my file name followed by the extension
of the file and I'll say
co9 india.
CSV let's go ahead and run it all right
now to see the first few rules of the
data frame I'm going to use the head
function I'll say head and within
brackets let's say I'll pass in 10 which
means I want to see the first 10 rows of
data if I run it there you go here you
can see from 0 till 9 so we have 10 rows
of information and these are the
different column names you have S number
date time state or Union territory then
you have confirmed Indian national
confirmed foreign National cured cases
deaths reported and the confirmed
cases all right now moving ahead let's
use the info function to get some idea
about a data
set if I run it you can see here it
gives us
the total number of columns we have nine
columns the total number of entries or
the rows we have 18,0 rows of
information starting from 0 till
18,19 you see here the different types
of variables or column names that we
have then it has information about the
memory usage as well
and this side you can see the data types
cool now we'll use another very
important function which is to
get some idea about statistical analysis
the basic statistics about your data set
for that I'll be using the describe
function okay so if you can see
here the describe function is for
numerical columns only and you have the
measures such as count the mean standard
deviation maximum minimum the 25th
percentile 50 percentile and the 75th
percentile
value okay now let's move ahead and
import the second data set which is
related to
vaccination so I'll create a variable
called vaccine _ DF I'll write p
do read CSV function which is present in
Panda's Library I'll move to the top and
I'll copy the file location and we'll
change the name of the file copy this
and let me paste it here and instead of
coore 19 India I'm going to say
covid
underscore
vaccine underscore
statewise okay so this is the data set
that we saw coore vaccine uncore
statewise all right let me run it
cool and let's display the first seven
rows of information from this data
frame I'll be using the head function
and inside the function I'll pass in
seven
there you go so here you can see we have
from 0 till 6 there are total 24
columns a lot of them have null values
you can see
here all
right
now from the first data set which is
the coore DF data frame we'll be
dropping a few
unnecessary columns such as the time
column confirmed Indian national and
confirmed foreign National as well as
the s number we don't need these columns
so it's better to learn how to drop the
columns for our
analysis so I'll say
coore DF dot I'll use the drop
function and within square brackets I'll
pass in the column names the first is s
number
I'll give a
comma within double quotes I'll see the
next column is
time my third column that I want to drop
is
confirmed Indian
national given another comma within
double quotes I'll
say
confirmed foreign
National outside the square brackets
I'll give another comma and pass in my
next
argument that is in place equal to I'll
say
true I'll give another comma and say
axis equal to
1 let's run
it okay it has thrown an error let's
debug the error says confirmed Indian
okay it should be Indian national and
not Indian Nation
I'll
just mention it as National we'll run it
again okay now we
have removed these four
columns let me show you the data set
now there you go so we have only the
date column state or Union territory
cured deaths and
confirmed now let's see how you can
change the format of
the date column for that you have the
function called two date time I'll say
coore
DF I'll pass in my column name that is
date I'll say equal to PD
dot I'll use the pandas function that is
2core date
time
I'll say coore DF which is my data frame
name pass in my variable which is
date give a
comma and I'll use my argument that is
format equal
to I'll say percentage
y give a dash say percentage M give
another Dash and say percentage d
let's run it and I'll
print the head of the data
frame
cool now moving
ahead now we will see how to find the
total number of active cases so Active
cases nothing but the total number of
confirmed cases minus the sum of cured
cases plus deaths
reported so
let's find the ACT cases I'll give a
comment
okay I'll first write
my data frame name that is coore
DF within square brackets I'll give my
new column which is
activecore
cases I'll say equal
to coore
DF and My First Column would
be the confirmed cases
column
minus I'll say coore
DF then I'll pass in my qod column
plus I'll again
say
coore
DF and add my deaths
column this time let's print the
last five rows from the new data frame
that we have
created okay let's run it okay it has
thrown an error let's debug
it says data frame object has no
attribute tals this should be
teal there you
go can see here we have added a new
column called Active cases which is the
confirmed cases minus the sum of cured
and deaths reported
column now we will learn how to create a
poot table using the Panda's Library so
in this table we'll be summing all the
confirmed deaths and cured cases for
each of the states and union territories
so we'll be using the pcore table
function for
this I'll create a variable called
statewise and say PD
dot I'll use the pivote undor table
function I'll pass in
my data frame that is coore
DF and then I'll give my values
parameter inside the square brackets
I'll pass in
my columns
confirmed
deaths and then we'll have
the cured
column we give a comma and next argument
would be
index which is going to be my state
slash the union trory
column let me bring this to the next
line so it is more readable
I'll say Union
territory I
will give a comma
Now and pass in my last argument which
is
AG function that means aggregate
function
and this function would be
Max all
right let's run it
okay now I'm going to find out the
recovery rate so recovery rate is
basically the total number of cured
cases divided by the total number of
confirmed cases into 100 so I'll
say
statewise and within square brackets
I'll pass in my variable that I want to
create which is recovery
rate this will be equal
[Music]
to
the cured
cases multiplied by
100 by the total number
of confirmed
cases within square brackets I'll give
my column as
confirmed let's run this
okay I'll just copy this column paste it
here so this time we are going to find
out the mortality rate so mortality rate
is nothing but the total number of
deaths divided by the total number of
confirmed cases into 100 so I'm just
going
to replace the names here I'll say
mortality all right and then instead of
cod I'll say
my deaths column into 100 divided by the
confirmed cases let's run it okay
now we are going to sort the values
based on the confirmed cases
column and we'll sort it in descending
order so let me show you how to do it
I'll say statewise equal
to I'll use the function sore values
so we pass in my variable statewise Dot
and use the short
underscore values function I'll say by I
want to sort it by my
confirmed cases
column give a comma and I'll say
ascending equal
to false
let's run
it now we are going to plot our P
table using a
nice visual so for that I'm going to
use my background underscore gradient
function and inside that function we'll
pass in our cmap
parameter I'll show you how to do
it say style Dot
background underscore
gradient and inside this we'll pass in a
parameter called cmap so cmap stands for
color Maps this is present inside the
matplot lib Library so here you can see
there's a nice documentation on choosing
color maps in matplot lib this is
provided by matplot lp.org
if I scroll down you can see there are a
number of c maps that you can use
purples Blues you have something called
Reds there are other things like magma
you have summer autumn spring winter
cool all these you can use whichever
color map that you want and here you can
see the different
shades or the
gradients
okay so I'm going to use my color map as
as cube
Helix let me run it and show you the
pivote
table there you go here you can see we
have our pivot table
ready now as I said in the beginning
there are a few discrepancies in the
data set so here you can
see there's one called Maharashtra and
there's also Maharashtra Triple
Star this you can ignore even if I
scroll down you have madha Pradesh
followed by three asteris you can ignore
this value as well even for biar we
have so these have been
duplicated and here you can see the
different state names and union
territories then on the top you have the
confirmed cases cured cases the deaths
reported and the new columns that we
created these are calculated columns
recovery rate and mortality
rate and we have ordered it
in descending order of confirmed cases
so so
far our data says that Maharashtra has
the highest number of cases followed by
Kerala Karnataka Tamil Nadu Andra
Pradesh and utar prades so these are the
top five states which have the highest
number of confirmed cases even if you
see the mortality rate is also high for
Maharashtra
and if I scroll down the mortality rate
is also high for utarak if you see
here if I scroll further you have Punjab
the mortality rate is also
High all
right so this was our
first visual that we created in the
covid data analysis project now moving
ahead we'll see
the top 10 states based on on the number
of active
cases so we'll
start I'll give a comment top
Active cases
States
okay so we're going to explore another
very important pandas function in this
which is known as Group
by so I'll
first pass in my data frame which is
coore DF
dot followed by the group by
function I'm going to group my data
based
on state SL Union territory
column then I'll say
dot Max which is to find
the maximum value from the
stats that have
the highest Active cases so I have
passed in my Active cases
column and we're also going to group it
based on the date
column after that we're going to sort
the values so I'll use my function that
is
sortore
values I'll say short by
my column that
is Active
cases let me bring this to the next
line
underscore
cases I'll give a comma and
say ascending equal
to
false say dot and
then
reset my
index for that I'll use reset uncore
index
function okay let's check if everything
is
fine I have missed a square bracket here
let me give another square bracket here
okay and all this we are going to store
in
our variable called topor 10 and
underscore
active underscore
cases okay now let me go ahead and run
this cell okay there
is a syntax error
here now let's run it
okay now I'll create another variable
called
fig here we'll pass in the PLT which is
for matplot Leb library and we'll give
the figure
size using
the Fig size
argument see equal to and within a
topple and passing the size let's say 16
comma
9 we'll run
it okay
and let's
give a title to our plot so here we are
going to create a bar
plot
so using PLT do tile we'll pass in the
title let's say top 10
states with
most active cases in
India I'll give a comma and passing the
size of my title that's a 20
25 okay you can see we are
slowly being able
to create our
graph the most important thing is to
pass in the x axis and the Y AIS I'll
say ax which is for axis to pass in the
axis I'm going to use the bar plot
function that is present inside the cbor
Library I'll say SNS do
barplot I'll say data equal to
my variable which is top _ 10
underscore
States this is actually active
States all right and now I'm going to
use the ilock
function and take the first 10 states so
I'm using a
colon and then giving 10 as my value
iloc is for index
location I'll give a comma and say my Y
axis To
Be Active
cases give another comma and say my
x-axis to
be
state
slash Union
territory
give another comma we're going to pass
in the line
width to two I'll say line width equal
to two and we'll give an edge
color let's say the edge color
is
red okay so I have my Axis defined now
let's run
it there's an error here it's it says
top 10 active States not
found let's go to the stop and see the
exact okay so this is top 10 Active
cases let me change it
to cases
here now run it okay the x-axis also has
a mistake this should be State /un
territory now let me run it there you go
we have
our plot created but as you can see here
the labels of the different states and
union territories are overlapping so for
that let me first pass in the X labels
I'll say PLT
dox
label and my X label would be
States then I'll see PLT do V
label my y Lael will we'll have the
total Active
cases and finally I'll write PLT do show
before I run it let's collate all the
lines of code that we have written for
our top 10 states for most active cases
in India into one cell so what I'll do
is I'll just copy
this and we'll keep
adding in this cell itself
okay I'll go to the top next we'll copy
my figure size and
we'll paste it
here next let's take
the title and put it
here give a
space and we are going to
copy this cell and I'll paste it
here all
right now it's time to run
it there you go you see it
here we have a nice bar plot ready on
the top you can see the title top 10
states with most active cases and you
see the edges are in red color for all
the bars on the xaxis you have the
different state names Maharashtra
Karnataka Kerala you also have Andra
Pradesh Gujarat West and chattis card so
as you can see Maharashtra has the
highest number of active cases based on
our data followed by Karnataka Kerala
and Tamil Nadu at second third and
fourth place respectively and the ninth
place we have West Bengal in the 10th
place we have chattis
Gad on the y axis you can see the total
Active cases which are in
lacks okay now moving ahead now now
we'll see the top 10 stats based on the
total number of deaths reported so I'll
give a
comment top states
with
highest
depths okay so I'll first create my
variable saying top 10
underscore
TS this will be very similar
to what we did here just that we need to
change a few column names so instead of
Active cases we'll be using
deaths
okay so I'll start with my data frame
that is coore DF followed by using the
group by function and I want to group my
data based
on the state SL
Union territory
column then I'll choose the max
function and
within double square brackets I'll pass
in my column names deaths and
date let's make it consistent I'll be
using single
codes okay I'll say dot
going
to short my result therefore I'm using
the sore values function I want to short
it
by deaths
column I'll give another comma and
say ascending equal to false which means
I want to order my result
in descending
order then I'll say dot reset uncore
index
okay after that I'll give my figure size
I'll say PLT do
figure and within brackets I'll pass in
my argument which is fig size equal to
using a tle I'll say 18 comma let's say
5 now let's give a title for that I'll
use the title function which is
presented the mat plot lab Library I'll
say top 10 states with
most
deaths and let's give a size to the
title
25 now it's time for us to give the
access labels I just scroll
down okay so I'll say ax equal
to again this will be a bar plot so I'm
using my cbon library followed by the
bar plot
function my data will be top _ 10or
deaths which is this
variable I'll
give my index location
I I'm going to
choose 12 States the reason being there
are some discrepancies in the data I'll
show you once I plot this result so in
the y axis we'll
have deaths
column in the x-axis we'll
take state
slash Union
territory okay I'll give another
comma and
say line
width equal to 2
and we'll give an edge color to our bars
like we did
here so I'll say Edge color equal to
let's
say
black okay
now finally we'll
give the X label the Y
label so I'll say PLT do X label X Lael
would be States
my y
label will
be total death
cases then I'll write PLT do
show now let's run
it there you go you can see here we have
a nice bar plot on the top we have the
title top 10 states with most deaths now
what I specifically wanted you to see
was these discrepancies in the data you
can see here Maharashtra is repeated
twice even in our data that we collected
from kle Karnataka spelling has an error
you can see here we have a few rows of
information where Karnataka is spelled
as k a r a a n instead of k a r n all
right so
to
remove these
two results or to ignore these two
results I had given my index location
till 12 so we have Maharashtra Karnataka
Tamil Nadu Delhi then utar Pradesh West
Bengal Kerala Punjab Andra Pradesh and
chattis
Gad with the states that have the most
number of deaths
reported okay now we'll create a line
plot to see the growth or the trend of
Active cases for top five states with
most number of confirmed cases so the
states are Maharashtra Karnataka Kerala
Tamil Nadu and utar Pradesh I can show
you so these are the states with highest
number of active
cases okay hello everyone welcome to
today's video tutorial by simply Loan in
this video we are going to perform a
really interesting data analysis using
python on the Spotify music streaming
service platform data set I'll also be
asking you a few questions related to
Spotify during our discussion please
make sure to answer them in the comment
section of the video so now let's get
started Spotify is a stest audio
streaming and media services provider
founded in April
2006 it is the world's largest music
streaming service provider and has over
381 million monthly active users which
also includes 172 million paid
subscribers the total number of
downloads on the Spotify app in the
Android store exceeded 1 billion in May
2021 so millions of people listen to
music all day even I'm hooked to music
as an analyst what's better than
exploring and quantifying data about
music and drawing valuable insights
before I move ahead I have a quiz
question for you people the name Spotify
comes from a combination of two words so
which are those two words please let us
know your thoughts in the comment
section below I would like to repeat the
question again the name Spotify comes
from a combination of two words so what
are those two words we would love to
hear from you so please put your answers
in the comment section
below now let's use Python libraries and
functions to analyze and visualize our
data set first I'll show you the two
data sets that we'll be
using so here is the first data set that
we'll be using for our demo and then I
have my second data set called Spotify
features which is essentially about the
the geners of the different
soundtracks now these data sets have
been downloaded from
k.com now the Links to the data sets
have been provided in the description
box please go ahead and download them
now let me just go ahead and brief you
about the columns that are present in
our first data set which is about tracks
we have our column A which is ID this is
the unique ID for each of the songs then
we have the name column which is
essentially the name of the song then we
have a column for popularity so the
popularity ranges from 0 to 100 then we
have duration in milliseconds this is
the duration of the track in
milliseconds next we have a column
called explicit now we are not bothered
about this column because we are not
going to use it in our
analysis then we have artist so the name
of the artist who has composed or sung
the song then we have ID of the artist
then we have a column for release date
which is basically the date on which the
song was released then we have a column
for danceability so this describes how
suitable a track is for dancing based on
a combination of musical elements such
as Tempo Rhythm stability beat strength
and overall regularity the value ranges
between 0 and
1 next we have a column for energy so
the energy is a measure between 0.0 to
1.0 and represents a perceptual measure
of intensity and activity typically the
energetic tracks feel fast loud and
noisy higher the value the more
energetic is the song then we have a
column for key so key is the pitch notes
or scale of song that forms the basis of
a song there are 12 Keys ranging from 0
to
11 moving ahead we have loudness so the
overall loudness of the track in decb it
ranges from- 60 to 0
DB then we have mode so songs can be
classified as major and minor 1.0
represents major or one represents major
and zero represents
minor next we have speech so speech
recognizes the presence of spoken words
in a track more exclusive speech like
the record ing example talk show Audi
book or poetry the closer to 1.0 the
attribute
value then we have a column for AC
costic so a confidence measure of 0 to 1
of whether the track is acostic or not
so 1.0 represents high confidence the
track is acostic then we have other
information
about
instrumental then we also have a column
for
liveness so liveness detects the
presence of an audience in the recording
then we have a column for Valance so
balance is a measure between 0.0 to 1.0
and describes the musical positiveness
conveyed by a track or a
song and finally we have the columns for
Tempo and time
signature now even in the second data
set we have almost the same columns just
that we have an additional column that
is about the genre of the songs present
in the data set cool now let's head over
to our Jupiter notebook and we'll start
with our
analysis okay so one more thing to
remember our data has information
from 1922 onwards so all the songs from
1922 till
2021 cool okay so I'm on my Jupiter
notebook so so you can see I have a few
cells that have already been filled up
so we'll start with our analysis first
of all let's go ahead and import the
necessary librar so I'm importing numpy
pandas mat plot lib and C Bor for my
analysis and visualization I'll hit
shift enter to import the libraries all
right and in the next cell I'm going to
load my data set using the pandas read
CSP function I have my location already
put here let me show you the location
where the data files or the data sets
are located so this is my location under
Chrome downloads I have a folder called
Spotify data sets Okay so let's import
and check the first five rows in the
data set so for that I have used the
head function there you go so here you
can see I have my first five rows of
information from the data set and on the
top you can see the different columns
you have ID name
popularity
artist then we have the release date
danceability energy key
loudness liveliness or
liveness balance Tempo and other
information
cool now let's check for null values in
the data set I'll just give a comment as
null values
every time when you download a data set
from an open repository there are
chances that the data set would contain
null values so it's better to check them
beforehand so I'm going to use the
isnull function present in the pandas
Library PD I'm using because I had
imported pandas as PD so PD do is null
then I'm going to use the variable name
DF _ tracks because I inputed my data
set and stored it in the variable DF
undor tracks so I have my data frame
under dfdore trxs variable and then I'll
use the sum function to check the total
number of null values present in the
data set for each of the columns if I
run it there you
go so here you can see my name column
has
71 missing values or null values and we
don't have any null values for the rest
of the
columns
okay now let's use the info method that
will give us the total number of rows
and columns in the data set and we'll
also check the data types and the memory
usage so I'll see my data frame name
that is DF TRS
doino if I run it you can see here now
if you mark there are total
names or the names of the songs present
in the data set while the rest all have
5 lakh
866727 song names or soundtracks missing
from our data
set and Below you can see the data types
we have float integer and object and
then you can see the memory
usage
cool now before I move ahead with our
next analysis I have another question
for you which artist or musician has the
most number of followers on Spotify I
repeat which artist or musici has the
most number of followers on Spotify
please put your an in the comment
section below we would be happy to hear
from
you now let's move ahead and do our
first major analysis in this demo we are
going to find the 10 least popular songs
present in the Spotify data set so I'll
create a variable called sorted _ DF
that will be equal to my data frame name
that is DF TRS dot I'm going to use the
sortore values function and
say my column name is
popularity so I'm going to sort the
values based on the popularity and then
say ascending equal to
True since I want only the least popular
songs and then I'm going to say head of
10 which means I want the top 10 least
popular songs now let's go ahead and
print sorted D if I run it you can see
we have the list
of 10 least popular songs on Spotify you
can see that popularity is
zero and you can see the names of the
songs some of them
are songs which are not an English
language and you can see the artist
names as well
cool now moving
ahead let's see some descriptive
statistics for the numerical variables
that are present in our column so I'll
say DF tracks do
describe which is the function to get
some descriptive statistics and I'm
going to use the transpose function
after
that if I run it there you go so we have
the statistics about count mean standard
deviation minimum value 25th percentile
50th percentile 75th percentile and the
maximum value for these columns like
popularity duration in milliseconds then
we have energy key loudness
mode cool now if you see this popularity
column the minimum value is zero and the
maximum value is 100 and you can see the
50th percentile is 27 which is
essentially the median you have the
standard deviation as
1837 then similarly you can check for
the other features as
well
cool
now we'll see
the 10 most popular songs which are
greater than 90 so we are going to check
for the top 10 songs with popularity
greater than 90 let me show you how to
do it so in this cell I'm going to
create a new variable called most
popular and I'll say DF score tracks dot
this time I'm going to use the query
function that is part of pandas Library
again I'll use the column that is
popularity and we'll set the condition
popularity should be greater than 90
I'll give a comma and
say in place equal to false because I
don't want to change my original data
frame and then I'll say so
underscore
values and I'm going to sort it based
on
popularity
in descending order so I'll
say ascending equal to
false and then
let's take only
the top 10 popular songs so I'll say
most popular use square brackets use
square brackets and we'll then pass the
slicing operator and say colon 10 now if
I run this there you go so here you can
see the 10 most popular songs that is
present in our Spotify data set first we
have features by Justin
baver Daniel Cesar and gon then we also
have a song name called driver SL
license astronaut in the ocean save your
tiers you also have the business streets
and heartbreak anniversary so these are
the most popular songs that are present
in our data set based on the popularity
you can see paches has the highest
popularity
with 100 all right now moving to the
next cell so here we are going to set
the index to be release date column in
the main data frame so I'm setting my
index using the setor index function I
have passed in my column name as release
date and I'm saying in place equal to
True which means I want to change it in
my original data frame and then I'm
changing the value to date time format
and let's print the head of the data set
so you can see here we have successfully
changed our index now here you can see
instead of 0 1 2 3 we have the release
dat column and the rest of the columns
are
intact
cool now let's move ahead so suppose you
want to check the artist at the 18th Row
in our data set you can use the index
location method for that let me show you
how to filter only specific rows of
information from the data set I'll use
my data frame DF tracks and using double
square brackets I'll
say my column name which is
artist and I'll use the index location
method and say let's say I want to check
the artist who is
present in the 18th Row in my data set
so I'll use iock 18 if I run it the
artist name is Victor
Boucher
cool now let's move ahead we are going
to convert the duration in milliseconds
to just seconds
so if you see our data set we have a
column called duration in milliseconds
so all our songs are present in
milliseconds let's convert them into
just seconds so for that I'm using the
Lambda function and dividing the values
in milliseconds by th000 so that they
get converted into just seconds I have
used in place equal to true so I I want
to change it in my original data frame
let's run it and do the necessary
changes all right now we'll print the
head of the data set just to check the
duration column so I'll say
dfdore
tracks dot
duration do head if I run it there you
go
so you can see the values have now been
changed to just
seconds cool
I have the final quiz question for you
who has the most monthly listeners on
Spotify please put your answers in the
comment section below we' be glad to
hear from
you now coming to the next
cell so here we are going to create a
first visualization that is going to be
a correlation map we are going to drop
three unwanted columns and those are key
mode and expl explicit and then we are
going to apply Pian correlation method
now I have set my figure size to 14
comma 6 and then we are using the cbon
heat map function to create our
correlation map I have put
the variable that is correlation _ DF
you can see above we had created this
and then I'm setting annotation equal to
true so
this will write the data value in each
cell I have set fmt equal to do one G so
this is a string formatting code to use
when adding annotations then I have set
my vmin and Vmax so these are the values
to Anchor the color map otherwise they
are inferred from the data and other
keyword arguments cmap here stands for
color map you can just search for SNS C
map you will get the documentation so
you can choose whichever color palette
or the color map you want here I have
used
infoo and I have set my line BDS and
line color finally I'm giving a title to
my coration map and I have set the xtic
labels let's go ahead and run this to
get our first
visualization if I scroll down there you
go we have got a
nice correlation map so here on the
right side you can see the scale it
ranges from minus1 to + 1 minus1 means
the variables have least or negative
correlation while the values which are
above
0.0 means that the variables have a
positive
correlation
now here you can see there are
values like minus. 7 for energy and
acostic which means if the energy is
high the acostic is gly low again for
loudness and say speech if the song is
loud the speech is low so there is
negative correlation but if you see for
energy and loudness there is really high
correlation between these two variables
you can see the value is point8 so if
the song is is loud this implies the
song has really high energy and vice
versa now if you see for a few other
variables there is negative correlation
between acostic and
danceability there is negative
correlation again between Valance and
acostic similarly there is positive
correlation between energy and balance
which
is4 and and even for danceability and
Valance that is positive correlation
which is05 cool so from the correlation
heat map you can note that acostic
appears to have a strong negative
correlation with energy so if you see
for acostic and energy there is a strong
negative correlation and there is a
moderately strong positive relation
between loudness and popularity so if
you see for popularity and loudness the
color is orange which means it in this
positive
region and there is also a moderately
strong positive relation between
danceability and balance so if you check
for danceability and balance here there
is a moderately strong positive
correlation all
right now let's move ahead we are going
to sample our data and take just 4% of
the total data and we'll create two
regression plots using this data so let
me first sample my data so I'll create a
sample data
frame using my original data frame which
is DF tracks and see
sample I'm going to use the int function
and see
0.004 multiplied by the length of my
original data frame which is
dfdore
tracks
all
right now let's run
this and we'll
print the length of my sample data
frame if I run it you can see
Point 4%
of my total data set is
2,346
rows
cool now we are going to create a
regation plot between loudness and
energy now in our correlation map we saw
there was a positive correlation between
loudness and energy which was point8
let's plot it in the form of a
regression line so I'll use PLT dot
figure
I'll set my figure
size equal to let's say 10 comma
6 I'll say SNS
dot regression plot so I'm using the
function called reg plot and I'll use my
data as sample
underscore
DF give a comma and
say in my Y axis I'll have my
column
loudness and in the x- axis we'll have
energy I'll give a color
to my data variable let's say the color
is
C then I'll set my title
to
loudness versus
energy let's say
correlation all
right let's make sure everything is
fine now we'll run and see our result
the you go so you can see here clearly
there is a very high positive
correlation between loudness and energy
on the y- axis we have loudness and on
the x-axis we have energy and you can
see all the data points or the songs
are in One Direction so if the energy
increases the loudness of the song also
increases and similarly if the loudness
of the song decreases your energy of the
song or the track also decreases so
there is a very high positive
correlation and you can see the
regression line here it has
gone and is increasing
gradually cool now similarly I'll just
copy this code and we are going to see
another regression plot this time for
two different features let's say we
have popularity in the y axis so I'll
say
popularity and then in the x-axis we
have let's say
acostic I'll change the color to let's
say B which stands for
blue and will set the title
to popularity
versus I'll have theost
thickness
correlation just scroll down and we'll
run it to see the
result there you go so I have
the different points for the songs and
here you can see the regression line is
downwards which means if the acostic of
the song increases the PO popularity
decreases and similarly if the
popularity increases acostic decreases
you can see the downward trend of the
regression
line all
right now in the next cell we are going
to create a new column called Year from
our release date column and I have
changed this to date time format let me
just run it
cool now after that
we are going to create a distribution
plot to visualize the total number of
songs in each year since 1922 that is
available on the Spotify streaming app
so I have used my cbon library and disc
plot function now one thing to remember
you need to update your cbon library
to this
version if you haven't done it so use
this command pip install D- user cbon
and
the
version so here in the distribution
plot we are going to plot a histogram so
I have used kind equal to hist which
stands for
histogram let's run and see the result
okay so here you can see I have
my distribution plot so the plot tells
us that the number of songs for each
year in the data set according to their
release date have increased in the
recent years since music became more
accessible to people globally with
technological advancements so earlier
you can see there were very few songs
available in the
1920s later on the number of songs
increased rapidly and now you can see we
have a lot more songs available for
people to listen
cool
now we are going to see the Dury of
songs over the years for that again we
are going to create a bar plot so I'll
first create a variable called total
duration equal to
dfdore tracks
dot I'll use the duration column that we
created with
seconds and
then I'm going
to
set
my figure Dimensions so I'll use figure
underscore DMS for Dimensions equal to
18 comma 7 after that I'll have my
figure axis defined so I'll use the
matplot Leb subplots
function
and I'll set
the figure size
equal to my figure
dimensions and
then I'll say figure equal to SNS dot
I'll use the bar plot
function and say my x-axis to be
years my Y axis will be total duration
or total _ Dr that we created here I'll
set my Axis equal to
ax and then I'll set error
width equal to
false let's set the title for my plot
as title equal
to year versus
duration and finally I'll say PLT do
xtex I'll rotate it
by let's say
90° all
right let me just recheck once if
everything is fine and then we'll go
ahead and run
it my access error width title okay let
me just run
it we'll see the result in a
moment if I scroll down you can see we
have the bar plot for the different
years and the duration of the songs in
seconds in the y axis so earlier in the
1920s you can see the duration of the
songs were less and later it increased
around late 1930s and this remained
consistent until 2010 where the duration
was high but after 2010 you can see the
duration of the songs have started
decreasing now in the next cell I'm
going to create a line plot to analyze
the average duration of the songs over
the years it is going to be similar to
our bar plot just that now we are going
to visualize it in terms of a
line so I have my code ready you can see
here I've used my cbone library and the
line plot function in the x-axis I have
ear and in the y axis I have total
duration I've set my title to year
versus duration and I'm rotating
my X labels by 60° let's run it and
we'll see the
output there you go
now if I scroll down you can see we have
a
nice line plot and on the x- axis you
have the years and on the y axis we have
the duration we can see that the songs
from
1920s to
1960s have comparatively shorter
duration since most of the songs tended
to be more singing based rather than
instrument
based after after 1960s you can see the
duration of the songs started increasing
until I would say
2010 and in the present day the duration
of the songs have started declining
since the attention span of the average
listener is also declining all right now
let's move to our second data analysis
project which is based on geners of the
songs so I'm importing my data set using
the pandas read _ CSV function I have
given my location and here I have my
data set name followed by the extension
of the type so this is a CSP data set
let's go ahead and run
it okay now let's print the first five
rows of the data set I have stored my
data set in a data frame called dfdore
Jer
I'll use the head function to get the
first five rowes of
information I'll hit shift enter to run
it there you
go you can see here I have my genre
column artist name track name track ID
popularity
acostic duration in milliseconds again
and we have the rest of the other
columns that we saw in our first data
set just one thing to note here key is
present in terms of c d e c minor F
minor and not in terms of numbers
between 0 to
11 now we'll
see the duration of the songs for
different genners for that I'm going to
create a bar plot so I'll start with
setting the title for my plot
as
duration
of the
songs
in
different
geners I'll use the seon
library and I'll set
my color pallet to let's say
rocket do a comma and say
as cmap equal to
true this would be color
pallet
now I'll say SNS do
barplot in the y axis I'll
have
Jer
and in the x-axis I'll
have my duration column which is in
milliseconds so duration underscore Ms
and then I pass my data frame using the
data argument so I'll say data equal to
DF do
Jer
next we'll set the xels so I'll say PLT
do X
label let's see my X label is duration
in
milliseconds and then I'll say PLT do V
label as
Jers now let's go ahead and run
this there you go so here you can see we
have the different genners on the Y AIS
and on the x-axis you have the duration
in
milliseconds and if you see the graph
for classical genre and for songs that
belong to World genre the duration of
the songs are more compared to other
genes now if you check for children's
music Jer the duration is less or the
least
cool and
finally we'll move to our last demo
where we'll see the top five geners by
popularity so I'll say SNS do set
uncore
style I'll set
my style to
dark
grid which will be my background and
then I'll see PLT
do figure I'll set my
figure size
to 10 comma
5 then I'll create a variable called
fers since I want to take only the most
popular songs based on the JRE so I have
created a variable called femus and I'll
pass my data frame name that is DF
uncore Jer and I'll sort the values
based on my popularity
corner so I'll
say
popularity and I want to sort it in
descending order so I'll say ascending
equal to
false and I'll take
the
first 10 values I'll tell you the reason
why I'm taking the first 10 values and
not
five then I'll say SNS dot bar
plot and in the y axis I'll have
Jer in the x-axis will
have
popularity and I'll give a comma and
using the data argument I'll say my data
to be Famers which is this variable that
we
created and then I'll set
my
title
as top five
geners by
popularity all right now the reason why
I took head of 10 is because there are a
few genes which are repetitive so if you
see this we have children's music
appearing twice so hence we have taken
10 instead of all
right hi everyone welcome to this really
interesting video on data analysis of
the 2021 World happiness report using
python so today we will perform some
exploratory data analysis using python
Library ities to analyze visualize and
draw insights from 2021 World happiness
Data before I begin make sure to
subscribe to the simplon channel and hit
the Bell icon to never miss an update
first let's understand what the world
happiness report 2021 is all about the
international happiness day is
celebrated every year since 2013 on 20th
of March to emphasize the importance of
happiness in the daily lives of people
so the United Nations sustainable
development Solutions Network publish
the world happening report on 19th of
March 2021 that ranks the world's 149
countries on how happy the citizens
perceive themselves to be based on
various
indicators the happiness study ranks the
countries on the basis of questions from
the Gallup world pole the results are
then equated with other factors such as
GDP life expectancy generosity Etc this
year it focused on the effects of the
covid-19 pandemic and how people all
over the world have managed to survive
and prosper the the covid-19 pandemic
and how people all over the world have
managed to survive and
prosper so using this 2021 data we will
answer critical questions such as the
top 10 most corrupt
countries we will plot a graph to
understand how the happiness score is
related to the freedom of making Life
Choices we'll look at the life
expectancy of 10 happiest and 10 least
happy Nations so these are a few
examples but we will explore more about
the data in detail in our demo
session let's get started so first I'll
show you the data set we'll be using in
this demo so this data has been
collected from keigle let me show you
that so this is the CSV data set that we
have downloaded from kel.com so you can
see here World happiness report
and we will share the data set link in
the description of the video you can
click on the link to download the data
set now we have information about 149
countries you can seat here count is 149
let me go to the top and I'll run
through the columns that are there in
this data set so the First Column is the
country name so we have 149 different
countries and then we have something
called as Regional indicator we can call
this as just the region so you can see
we have different regions I've applied a
filter we have Central and Eastern
Europe then we have Commonwealth of
independent states so these in include
countries such as Russia then we have
East Asia Latin America and Caribbean we
also have South Asia southeast Asia
subsaharan Africa Western Europe and
other regions I'll just cancel this and
then we have the happiness score column
that has been sorted in descending
order so we have Finland Denmark and
Switzerland who are the top three
happiest Nations now if I scroll down we
have countries like Randa Zimbabwe and
Afghanistan which are the least three
happy
countries now there are a few columns
that we won't be using in our analysis
so we will learn how to exclude those
columns and keep only the relevant ones
so columns such as standard error of
ladder score then we have upper whiskers
and lower whisker column so we are going
to ignore these columns we are only
concerned about the GDP column which is
this one then we have the social support
or the social status column then we have
the health life expectancy freedom to
make Life Choices generosity and
perceptions of corruption and there are
a few other columns you can see to the
right and these these columns are not of
our interest so we are going to ignore
them now let's head over to our jupyter
notebook and we'll start by importing
all the necessary libraries for analysis
and data
visualization okay so I'm on my jupyter
notebook so first step I'll just rename
this notebook to let's say happiness
report data
analysis I'll click on rename all right
now we'll start by importing our
libraries so first Library I'm going to
import is nump as
NP then I have
import pandas as
PD then I'll import two data
visualization libraries cbon and matplot
lip so I'll say
import cbon as SNS and
then
import matplot
lib
dot pip plot which is the module name as
PLT and I'll
say
percentage mat plot
lib in
line okay now let me just go ahead and
run
this all
right well now let's set the parameters
that control the general style of the
plots the style parameters control
properties like the color of the
background and whether a grid is enabled
by default or not so for that I'll say
SNS do
setor style I'll give it as dark
grid next I'll
say PLT do RC
per
amps which stands for runtime
configuration parameters I'm going to
set my font
size
to let's say
15 then I'll
say PLT
do
RC perams
now I'm going to set the figure size so
I'll say figure
dot fix
size let's say 10 comma
next I just copy
this paste it
here now we are going to set the the
face color so I'll
say figure
dot face
color I want to set it to peach color so
I'm going to pass in my RGB values for
peach I'm going to set it in terms of
hex code so for peach the value is
FF e
5 b and
4 now let me run it
okay now it's time to load our data set
so for that I'll create a variable
called data and I'll use the pandas
Library followed by the read undor CSV
function because our data set that we
saw is a CSP data set which is this one
now inside the parenthesis I'll pass in
the location of
my data file so I have my data here
World happiness report 2021 I'll just
copy this location and we'll paste it
here and make sure the location is
within
quotes and you need to change it to
either forward slash or double back
slash so here I'm using double Black
slash so let me just include one more
backs
slash and then I'm going to pass in
the file name which
is
World
hyphen
happiness hyphen report hyphen
2021 do CSV which is the extension of
the file now let me run it all right now
to display the first five rows of
information you can use the head
function so I'm writing data which is my
variable that holds the data frame so
data. head there you go you can see here
we
have printed the first five rows from
the data set you have the country name
Regional indicator happiness score then
we have information about the GDP life
expectancy generosity then we have
corruption data and these are some of
the columns that we are not bothered
about so we are going to drop these
columns from our
analysis now we going to do that so I'll
create a variable called Data columns
which
are of our
interest so I'm going to take only
specific columns I need the country name
so I have taken country name make sure
the column names are within single codes
so I have my country name next I want
the second column which
is regional
indicator give a
comma we also need the happiness
score next I need
the logged GDP per capita data so I'll
take that column I'll say logged
GDP per
capita give a comma my next column would
be social
support give a comma
here my
next colum would be Health life
expectancy so I'll write health
life
expectancy let's give another comma and
we'll take the next column as well which
is freedom to make Life Choices so I'll
write that column name freedom to
make life
choices and
finally we'll take
the next two columns that is General
generosity and perceptions of corruption
So within single quotes I'll
say
generosity give a comma and we're going
to include the final column which is of
our interest that is perceptions of
corruption let me have a
recheck to ensure that I have put the
column names correctly otherwise it will
throw an error
now let me go ahead and run this cell
I'll hit shift enter all right so we
have
successfully taken the columns that
we'll be using for an
analysis now I'm going to say data equal
to data I'll pass in my new variable
that is dataor columns and I'm going to
copy all the data so I'll say dot
copy let's run it okay this should be
data _ columns all
right
now let's rename all these columns we'll
make it more simpler
and easy to understand so I'll
say let's say my
new variable is Happy _ D which stands
for data frame equal to I'll say data
dot we'll use the rename function and
using a dictionary we will rename our
columns so I have used a curly
bracket I'm going to pass in
My First Column which is country name
I'll just paste it here then I'm going
to give a colon and again within single
codes I'll say country uncore name so
this is going to be my new column name
I'll give a
comma we'll take the
next column which is regional
indicator I'll paste it here give a
colon and the new column would be small
R Regional
underscore
indicator now similarly we'll do this
for all
the remaining columns in the data
set okay now I have renamed all my
columns you can see it here let's run
it now we going to display the head of
the data set again so I'll say happycore
DF do
head there you go so we have only those
columns that are of our interest so I
have the country name Regional indicator
happiness score GDP social support life
expectancy freedom to make Life Choices
then I have generosity and perceptions
of
corruption
cool
now we are going to check whether any of
the columns have any null values so for
that I'll say happycore
DF
dot I'm going to use the asol
function I'll give another Dot and we
are going to find the sum for each of
the col columns you can see from the
data we do not have any null values in
any of the columns in the data set it is
all
zero okay now let's get started with our
first visualization that is we'll create
a plot between happiness score and the
GDP for different
regions so for that I'll give a comment
as plot
between
happiness and
GDP I'll just scroll down
cool first I'm going to set
the RC parameters so I'll say PLT do RC
params within square brackets I'm going
to give my figure size so I'll say
figure Dot
fix
size equal to let's say my figure size
is
15 comma
7 I'll set
the title that is PLT do title of my
plot
to let's say plot
between happiness
score and
GDP
next I'm going to say SNS dot let's
create a scatter plot so I'll say SNS do
scatter
plot I'm going to Define my xaxis and
the y axis for the plot let's say in the
x-axis we
have my data frame
happycore
DF
dot this should be an
underscore I'll
say a column name as happiness uncore
score give a comma and in the y axis
we'll
have my data frame name that is Happy _
DF dot we'll have the GDP column that is
logged underscore
GDP uncore peror
capita
let's give a comma and we'll pass in Hue
for the color let's say for Hue I'm
going to use the regional column or the
regional indicator column so I'll say
happycore
DF
dot Regional underscore
indicator
and then I'm going to give the size of
the dots as let's say 200 then I'll give
a
semicolon come to the next line I'll say
PLT dot let me just scroll down now we
are going to define the legend so I'll
say PLT do
Legend and in Legend we'll
have the location let's say I want to
put the legend at upper left corner so
I'll say say Lo which is for location
equal to upper
left give a comma and then see font size
of my Legend let's say B
10 make sure this is within
quotes then I'm going to pass my x-axis
labels and the y-axis labels so I'll say
PLT dox
Lael let's say the X label is happiness
score and my y label is GDP per capita
so I'll say PLT doy
label within single codes I'll say GDP
per
capita uh there's an error here there
should be plot all right so I have
written my code to create a scatter plot
let's run it and see the
result there is some error
here okay this should
be
Regional indicator and not indicatory
there's a spelling mistake let's run it
again all right so here you can see we
have a nice scatter plot on the top you
can see we have the title of the plot
that is plot between happiness score and
GDP on the x-axis we have the happiness
score from 0 to 8 and above and on the y
axis you have the GDP per capita and if
you see here in this region we
have countries from Western Europe which
have
the highest happiness score and the GDP
per capita is also the highest around
this region you can see here which is
for green and in the legend you can see
green is for subsaharan Africa so all
these countries have low happiness score
and and even the GDP per capita is also
low and if you see
the countries for Latin America and
Caribbean you see a lot of the values
lie here so they are all within the
range of 5.5 to 7 in happiness score and
even the GDP per capita is more than 9
for most of them
now even the happiness score is high for
the countries that lie in the North
America andz region and even that GDP
per capita is also the highest I can
name a few countries such as Australia
New Zealand we have Canada and United
States of America which belong to the
North America and Enz region cool now
there is one country which you see here
this seems to be like an outlayer which
means that this is the country which has
the lowest happiness score and even the
GDP per capita is also low but it is not
the lowest because you can see here
there are a few countries up here from
the subsaharan Africa which have the
lowest GDP per capita but the happiness
score is higher than this value or this
country so we can assume that this
country is Afghanistan which has the
lowest happiness score as per the 2021
happiness report
data
cool now we'll plot a pi plot to
understand the GDP by region so by this
we can know which region has the highest
percentage contribution to the world's
GDP as per our data so for that I'll
create a variable GDP uncore
region equal
to we'll use a data frame that is Happ
pcore DF dot I'm going to use the group
by
function and after that I'm going to use
my column that is
region so we have named the column as
Regional uncore indicator so I'm going
to group it by this region
column and I'm going to sum the values
of
GDP so I'm going to use the logged
underscore GDP uncore per
capita
column and after that I'm going to use
the sum
function and let me just print GDP
uncore
region you can see it here we have
the sum of all the countries for
different regions and their GDP all
total now this data we are going to plot
it in the form of a p plot so I'll say
GDP uncore
region Dot
Plot dot
Pi we are going to plot it in terms of
percentage so I'm going to use a
parameter
called autop PCT
equal to then I'm going to pass in my
format so I'll say percentage
1.1 F percentage
percentage then I'll say PLT dot
title let's say the title of my P plot
is going to be GDP by
region and I'll say PLT Dot
by
label which is going to be
blank let's run it okay so here you can
see we have the peach background at the
back because we
had
assigned a peach face color you can see
it here so for the
first scatter plot also we had the peach
color at the back
and now you can
see we have subsaharan Africa
contributing 20.7% to the world's GDP
the reason being we have around 34
countries in the subsaharan
Africa and we have the Western European
countries contributing to 16.2% of the
GDP
to check the least we have North America
andz region because we only have four
countries America Australia Canada and
New Zealand so hence they are
contributing only 3.1% to the world's
GDP okay now moving
ahead let's find the total number of
countries in each region so for this we
are going to use the group by function
that is part of the pandas library and
we'll count the total number of
countries in each region so I'll just
give a
comment as total
countries or all right just scroll
down so I'll create a variable called
total underscore
country I'm going to use my data frame
that is happycore DF dot I'm going to
use the group by
function I'll group the values based on
the region column So within single codes
I'll see Regional
underscore indicator
and then I'm going
to find the total count of country name
so I'm using the column country uncore
name and after that I'll just use dot
count now let's go ahead
and print my variable that is total _
country all right now let me hit shift
enter okay so here you can see
all right so for subsaharan Africa there
are total 36 countries and not 34 as I
mentioned earlier so hence you can see
because it has the highest number of
countries it is contributing the most to
the world's GDP that is
20.7% then we have the least number of
countries in North America andz that is
only four we have six countries in East
Asia and then we have 20 countries in
Latin America and Caribbean countries in
Commonwealth of independent states then
we have 17 countries in Central and
Eastern Europe
cool
now I'm going to show you how to create
a correlation map so that we can see the
relationship that exists between each of
the variables that are present in our
data set I'll just run through the code
and we'll see the
output okay so here I have my code
written for the correlation map that I
want to create so first of all I'm going
to compute the correlation Matrix so I
have used the C RR function which stands
for corelation and the method I'm going
to use is peon method now here I have a
Wikipedia page opened for peon
correlation coefficient so this is a
nice article where you can understand
what the pieron correlation is all about
and then I'm going to set up the matte
plot lib figures so I've have used the
the subplots function and I've have
given the figure size as 10A 5 and after
that we are going to draw the heat map
with the mask so I'm using the heat map
function present in the cbon library and
then I have passed in my variable that
is co which essentially stands for
correlation and then I have used mask
which is a Boolean array or it can be a
data frame and it is an optional
parameter if it is passed last the data
will not be shown in cells where the
mask is true and the cells with missing
values are automatically masked after
that I have used the cmap parameter
which stands for color map so you can
customize the colors in your heat map
and I'm going to create a heat map which
is in square shape so I have said Square
equal to true and the axis I'm going to
pass it as ax which I have defined here
here so this is the mat plot La axis and
it is optional so axis in which you want
to draw the plot otherwise you can use
the current active access now let me
just go ahead and run this and we'll see
the heat
map there you go so if I scroll down
here we have
the correlation Matrix and since I had
given my C map as blue and here here you
can see it is mostly blue and we have
the scale here now I'll tell you how to
read this correlation Matrix so wherever
the
cells are in blue or dark blue color
this means that the variables have very
high correlation and all this cells
where you see light blue color or
grayish and white color uh this
indicates that the variables have very
low correlation for example there is
very low or almost negative correlation
between happiness score and perceptions
of corruption so obviously if the
citizens of a country feel that there is
a lot of corruption in the country their
happiness score would obviously be less
or low and if you see there is also low
correlation between happiness score and
generosity there is again low
correlation
between Health life life expectancy and
perceptions of corruption and if you see
these places there is really high
correlation between the happiness score
and GDP per capita again for social
support also there is very high
correlation now if you see even
for social support and healthy life
expectancy there is very high
correlation but there
is low correlation
between
making life choices and
generosity and there is negative
correlation between corruption and
freedom of making life choices you can
see it is almost white color which means
it falls around this region so negative
correlation similarly
for logged GDP per capita and Corruption
that
is negative correlation all
right
okay now we are going to visualize a bar
plot that will tell us the corruption in
different regions so I'll just give a
comment corruption
in
regions let me just scroll down okay so
I'll create a variable called
corruption which will be equal to my d
frame that is Happy _ DF now first of
all I'm going to use the group by
function to group all my regions so I'll
say Regional
underscore indicator which is
my column name present in the data set
and after this I'm going to find the
average of the variable that is
corruption if I run it you can see here
I have the values for the different
regions and from here you can see
that Central and Eastern Europe has the
highest perceptions of corruption as per
the questions answered in the poll and
if you see the
table we have Western Europe and the
North America region with the least
perceptions of corruption now we are
going to visualize this using a barplot
now so first of all I'll set
my parameters by giving the figure size
I'll
say fig
size it's rather figure do fix
size I'll just add figure
here okay and now let's
say I'll assign it as 12a 8 now I'll
give a title to my plot so I'll say PLT
do
title and my title of the plot is going
to be perception of
corruption
in
various
regions all right then I'm going to
Define my X
label so I'll say x label will
be
regions
and we'll set the font size of the X
label to let's say 13 or let it be
15 then we are going to set the Y
label in y label I'll
have corruption index as the label name
again we are going to set the font
size to
15 now I'm going to use x
tix
parameter since I want to rotate the
axis labels in the x-axis by 30° so I'll
say rotation equal to 30 and I'll say h
a which stands for horizontal alignment
equal to
right make sure this right should be
within single
codes and finally I'll say PLT dot bar
because I'm going to plot a bar
graph I'll say
corruption dot
index
comma and then I'll
say
corruption
dot per options of corruption which is
my column
name all right so I have my code ready
for the bar plot now let me just go
ahead
and print the bar plot make sure
everything is correct I'll just hit
shift
enter okay there is one mistake here it
says okay this should be X tick and not
X tick let me run it again there you go
so if I scroll down on the top you have
the title which is perception of
corruption in various regions on the
x-axis you have the regions label on the
Y axxis you have the corruption index
and if you see this as per our table
that we
created we have least corruption in
North America andz region then we have
the next least corruption in Western
Europe but we have the highest
corruption in Central and Eastern Europe
as per their citizens perception
similarly we have
the second and third highest corruption
in Latin America and Caribbean as well
as South
Asia
cool now moving ahead I'm going to show
you how you can find the life expectancy
of the top 10 happiest countries and
bottom 10 happy countries so for that
I'm going to run you through the code
and we'll see the visualization side by
side okay so I have my code written in
these two cells so first I'm going to
find out the top
10 happiest countries and then I'm going
to find the bottom 10 happiest countries
so for that I'm using the head function
and I passed in 10 since I want the top
10 names and to get the bottom 10
countries as per their happiness score
I'm using the tail function so let me
just run it so we have saved the result
in two variables topor 10 and bottomore
10 and to create the bar plots we are
using two
different codes so here you can see I
have set my figure size and axis and and
then I have my X label as country name
after that I am setting my title of the
barplot to top 10 happiest countries
life expectancy I've used my xtick
labels and I'm rotating it by 45° and I
have my horizontal alignment as right
you can see it here we have used the
barplot function I have the xaxis as
country name and Y AIS as healthy life
expectancy column and I have set my Axis
then I am using the X labels and Y
labels as country name and life
expectancy and similarly I have my
barplot for the bottom 10 least happy
countries life
expectancy let's just run it and we'll
see the result there you go now if I
scroll down you can see we have two
different bar plots the first one is for
the 10 happiest countries and then we
have the bottom 10 least happy
countries so if you
see on an average the top 10 happiest
countries life expectancy is above 70
years so if you are from one of these
countries you are expected to live for
more than 70 years now if you check the
bottom 10 least happy countries you see
here loto has less than
50 life expectancy age and most of them
are less than 60 years so if you are
from one of the top 10 happiest
countries you expected to live 10 years
more than these countries that lie in
the bottom 10 region cool now moving
ahead all right so now we are going to
see the plot between freedom to make
life choice and the happiness score for
this I'm going to use a scatter plot so
I'll first Define my figure size so I'll
say PLT do RC p a r Ms which stands for
parameters I'm going to pass in
my figure size so I'll say figure dot
fig
size equal
to let's say 15 comma
then using the cbone library and the
scatter plot
function we'll passing
the xaxis let's say the x-axis is my
data frame name happycore DF and I'll
have the freedom to make life choices in
the
xaxis so the column name is freedom2
underscore
me underscore life and
choices I'll give a comma and we'll pass
in the Y AIS again I'm going to use my
data frame name Dot and I'll have the
happiness
score I'm also going
to pass in a hue
parameter to
differentiate
the different
regions so I'll say DF
do Regional uncore
indicator and I'll give the size of the
dots or the Bubbles as let's say
200 now I'll
say PLT
dot
Legend I'll Place The
Legend at upper left corner so so I'm
giving the location which is lo equal to
upper
left
and font
size let it be
12 I'll say PLT dot X
leble
as freedom to make
life
choices and my y label
would be happiness
score all
right now we have the code written for
the scatter plot that I want to create
let me just run
it there you go so here we have the
legend for the different regions and we
have the different colors for each of
these regions and you can see here I
have on the xaxis freedom to make life
choices and on the y axis we have the
happiness
score so you can see it very
clearly for the countries that lie in
the Western Europe region the blue dots
the freedom to make Life Choices is more
and so is the happiness
score then if you see the values in the
green region which is for Middle East
and North Africa the freedom to make
Life Choices is lower and hence the
happiness score is also low and for all
these countries that are part of the
subsaharan Africa some of them
have decent score for freedom to make
life choices but the happiness score is
low
again now if you focus on the pink dots
which is for the Southeast Asian
countries the happiness score is
comparatively lower but the freedom to
make life's choices is more than
8 cool and again we have one data point
which
is lying at the bottom we can assume
this is Afghanistan so in Afghanistan
the freedom to make life's choices is
very low and even the happiness score is
really
low
cool now moving to our next analysis we
are going to see the top 10 most corrupt
countries so first I'm going to sort the
countries in the list so for that I'm
going to create a variable called
country I'll have my data frame name
that is happycore DF do
sortore
values by I'm going to sort by column
that is
perceptions
of
corruption dot head and I want to find
the top 10 most corrupt countries as per
the
poll
and
then I'm going
to pass in the figure size so I'll say
PLT do
RC
perams and then I'm going to set the
figure size so I'll say figure
dot fig
size make sure there is no spelling
mistake let's say the figure size is 12a
6 I'll pass in the title so I'll say PLT
do title let's say the title of my plot
is going to be
countries with
most perception
of
corruption after that I'll say PLT do X
Lael in the X label I'll have country
and I'll set
the font size to
13 then I'll say PLT
do y
label in by label I'll have the
corruption
index
next I'll passing the font size for the
Y label again it is going to be
13 now I'll see PLT do
X
TI I'm going
to rotate it by
30 and I'll say horizontal alignment
equal to
right and then I'll have my bar function
or the bar plot function so I'll say PLT
do
bar I'm going to pass in country
dot country underscore name and then
we'll have my variable country dot the
column name that
is perceptions
of
corruption all right
now if I run it you can see
here so these are the countries with the
least perceptions of corruption so
Singapore has
the lowest corruption
index and then we have Randa Denmark
Finland now if you want to see the
countries with the highest perceptions
of corruption you need to change this
head to tail of 10 since we are sorting
it in ascending order so we would want
to know the bottom 10 countries if I run
it there you go so these are the
countries with the most perception of
corruption you have Slovakia loto Kosovo
that's Ukraine Afghanistan Bulgaria
Romania and Croatia all of these
countries have a corruption index of
more than 8
5 cool now coming to the final section
of this interesting video on happiness
report data analysis for 2021 I want to
visualize a scatter plot that will tell
us how the corruption varies in terms of
Happiness score so I'll just say a
comment as corruption
versus
happiness okay so first of all I'll set
my figure size so I'll say PLT do
RC per
amps within single codes I'll give the
figure
size
as 15 comma
7 then I'm going to use the scatterplot
function that is part of the cbon
library in the x-axis I'll have
my column that is corruption or rather
we'll have the happiness score in the
x-axis so I'll say happycore DF dot
column name that is happiness
score let me give a comma and in the y
axis we'll
have the corruption column so I'll say
happycore DF
do perceptions of corruption
and
then in h we'll have the region that
is regional uncore indicator so I'll say
happycore DF
dot
Regional
indicator and I'm going to give the size
of the dots so I'll say s equal to 200
then I'm going to say PLT dot
Legend I'm going to put it
at lower left corner this time so I'm
giving my location as lower
left
and the font size of the legend I want
is
after that I'll just say PLT do X
Lael
as corruption and PLT
dot V
label as happiness
score oh this should rather be the
opposite since in the x axis we have
taken happiness score so we'll put the
happiness score label in X and I'll have
corruption in
y all right so I have my scatter plot
code ready let me just run
it there you go so here you can see on
the lower left I have the different
regions and on the x axis I have the
happiness score on the y axis I have the
corruption index now you can see the
general Trend as per the scatter plot
that the countries with greater
happiness score have lower corruption
index so you can see these countries
which are from the Western European
regions
have highest happiness score and their
corruption is also really low so all
these blue countries you can name a few
Finland we have Sweden we have Belgium
France Netherland lying in these regions
we also have a few countries from North
America and Enz which are essentially
Australia then we also have Canada us
and New
Zealand okay now if you focus on these
green region this
region now these are the countries from
the sub Sahar and Africa and most of the
countries from these regions have have a
very low or less than five happiness
score but the corruption is also really
high you can see here they have almost
more than7 in the corruption index now
you also have a country here which is
from the southeast Asia we would like to
give you a task it would be really great
if you can tell us in the comment
section which country is this it has
more than six happiness scores but the
corruption index is really low Which is
less
than2 now if you
consider Middle East and North African
regions the darker green countries here
also if you see the happiness score is
less than five and the corruption index
is also high now there are a few
countries the Commonwealth of
independent states for example
countries such as usbekistan then you
also have kakistan we have Russia
Armenia belonging to
these gray color dots you also have
Georgia and Ukraine as part of
Commonwealth of independent states so
here you see the corruption is
below 6 for these countries and the
happiness score is more than
five all right so with that we have come
to the end of this demo session on world
happiness report 2021 data analysis
using python if you're a professional
with minimum one year of experience and
an aspiring data analyst looking for
online training and certifications from
prestigious universities in
collaboration with leading experts to
enhance your credibility then search no
more simply Lars postgraduate program
and data analytics offered by per
University in collaboration with IBM is
just what you need for more details head
straight to our homepage or simply click
on the link in the description box below
now without further delay over to our
training hello everyone welcome to this
exciting video on Olympics State asset
analysis using python by simply
loan this is going to be a very
interesting and interactive session
where I'll give you a brief about the
history of Olympics and throw some light
into the recently held Tokyo Olympics
but we'll focus more on using Olympics
data set that is available on kigle and
perform some exploratory data analysis
you will understand how to use different
functions in Python to analyze and
extract meaningful information during
the course of our discussion I'll be
asking you a few general questions
related to the Olympics try to answer
them in the comment section of the video
so let's begin the Olympics is one of
the biggest sporting events on the
planet it is held every 4 years the
first modern Olympics to took place in
Athens Greece in
1896 as per National Geographic the
original Olympics took place in 776 BC
so they began as part of an ancient
Greek festival which celebrated Jews the
Greek god of sky and weather the Rings
in the Olympics logo represent the five
continents Europe Africa Asia the
Americas and Oceania from 1924 to 1992
the winter and the Summer Olympics took
place in the same year but now they
alternate every 2 years before I move on
here is an interesting question for you
only two people have ever won gold
medals at both the summer and the Winter
Olympics who are those two people please
share your answers in the comment
section of the video we would like to
know from
you the Summer Olympics in Tokyo began
on the 23rd of July and recently
concluded on the 8th of August we got to
witness some Thriller matches that went
down to the wire some amazing victories
and sadly there were a lot of
heartbreaks as well winning and losing
are part and parcel of any
game fans across the world were really
happy to see This Global event happen
this year Following last year's
postponement due to the Corona virus
pandemic with our Olympic fever High
let's take this opportunity to work
around a project to perform exploratory
data analysis using python to analyze
and visualize past Olympics data and
answer specific questions in this video
we'll be using specific python libraries
such as numpy pandas matplot lip and
seon to make sense of our data and
extract meaningful information we are
going to visualize our results with
different charts and graphs before I
show you the data set that we are going
to use for our analysis I have another
general question for you which is the
first Olympics where all the
participating countries sent female
athletes I repeat which is the first
Olympics where all the participating
countries sent female athletes
put the year and the city name where the
Olympics was held in the comment section
of the video we'll be more than happy to
hear from
you now let me go ahead and show you the
data sets that we'll be using in this
video so here you can see I have my
Olympics data set folder that has two
data sets these are CSV files one is
called the athlete events and the other
one is called noore regions so we'll be
using these two data sets these data
sets can be downlo loed from kigle we
will post the data set links in the
description of the video please go ahead
and download them these data sets have
been directly taken from the internet
now I'll show you the data sets so this
is my first data set you can see on the
top athlete events so I have around 15
columns you can see the count here and
there are
nearly 2 71,1 2016 rows of
information so this this is a huge data
set that we are going to use the other
data set we are going to use in this
demo is called nocore regions now here
one thing to notice nooc stands for
National Olympic Committee this is a
three-letter code that is given by the
Olympic Committee we have the region
names so afg is for Afghanistan you have
ALB for Albania ALG for Algeria we have
also a column called notes you find some
notes about the region for example here
antiqua is actually antiqua and
baruda all right let's move to the first
data set that I showed you this is our
primary data set for our
demo so these data sets have been
directly taken from the internet and
were not validated so the results that
you will see in the demo is purely based
on the data that we have
collected so the file athlete events. CS
V contains nearly 2 lakh 71,1 2016 rows
of information and there are 15 columns
so each row corresponds to an individual
athlete competing in an individual
Olympic event so here ID is actually a
unique number for each athlete then we
have the name which is basically the
athletes name we have the sex or the
gender which is male or F for female
then we have the age of the athlete
which is in terms of
integers we have the height in cm of the
athletes then we have the weight in
kilogram we have the team name these are
the country names you have China Denmark
Netherland there are around 200 country
names then we have the nooc as I said
nooc is a three-letter code that stands
for National Olympic
Committee we have the games this games
contains the year and the season you can
see here 1992 summer you all also have
the Winter Olympic information all right
then we have a specific year
column to tell you in which year this
event had
occurred now the year column is also an
integer column we have the season so
whether it was summer olympics or Winter
Olympics then we have the city name this
is the host
City then we have the sport name you can
see here we have basketball Judo
football tgof War speed skating there
are so
many then we have another column called
event which is the complete event name
as you can see the sport name is
basketball but the event name is
basketball men's basketball to be very
specific again for Speed skating you
have different categories like women's
1000 M 500
M all right now the final column is the
medal column so it has
the information about the athlete
whether the athlete had won a medal be
it gold silver bronze and any means the
athlete did not win any medals so we'll
use these two data sets now let's get
started with the demo we'll be using
jupyter notebook for our analysis so
I'll take you to my jupyter notebook
right
away I have opened it on Chrome so this
is my jupyter notebook that we are going
to use you can see here Olympics data
set analysis I have
already have a few cells that have been
filled with some piece of code and you
can see there are some Commons written
as well we are going to use this data
set so let's get
started first and foremost we'll import
the data sets so we are going to use
numpy pandas matplot lib and cbon let me
hit shift enter to import all the
libraries all right now the next thing
is to load the data
setes using pandas read CSV function
so I'll create a variable called
athletes I'll say equal to PD dot I'll
use the read CSV
function and inside this function will
give the location of the files so I'll
copy this location
and here I'll paste make sure this is
within
quotations and these are
all forward
slash I'll give another forward slash
and after that I'll give
the file name that is
athlete
underscore
events. CSV
I'll close the
quotation let's run it okay similarly we
will load this second data set I'll
create another variable called regions
so it will have my data frame I'll use
the same function pd. reor
CSV I'll just copy this file path till
here we paste
it and
I'll give my second file name which is
nocore
regions. CSV you can verify here the
first one is athlete _ events the second
one is nocore
Regions okay I'll close the quotation
and we'll run it
again okay there seems to be some error
I think this is the
regions
cool now moving ahead let's see
the first few rows of both the data
sets I'll use the head function for
that I'll
say
athletes. head so this will print the
first five
rows from my data set athletes you can
see here from 0 to four you have five
rows of information the ID name sex or
the gender age right
weit if I go to the right you have games
year season sport event and
medal now let's see
the second data set that we imported or
loaded I'll say regions.
head it says
regions is not
defined let me cross check it
okay I have taken it as region let's
make it
regions
cool now let's run it there you go so
these are the first five rows from our
second data set you have nooc region and
some
notes all
right now the next step is to combine
both the data sets so we'll join the
data frames using the pandas merge
function let me show you how to do it so
this is going to be a horizontal join
I'll create a
variable called athletes uncore
DF then I'll use my first variable which
is athletes I'll say do merge which is
my function name I'm going to merge the
regions data
frame I'll use the how
parameter in how I'll give my value as I
want to do a left
join and my common column in both the
data sets is actually
nooc so I'm going to use the nooc column
as my common column to merge both the
data sets now let's go ahead
and print the merged data frame I'll say
athletes DF do head let's run it there
you go so if you see clearly if I move
to the
right you can see here we have added two
more columns that were present in the
second data set which was regions so we
have regions and
notes added to my first data set that is
athletes
uncore
events cool now one thing to note here
is see the column names are not
consistent if you see here the rest of
the columns start with a capital letter
but if you you see the last two columns
that we just added now start with the
lower case letter so we'll use the
rename function to make the column names
consistent but before
that
let's see the shape of the data frame so
I'll print the shape of the data frame
to know the total number of rows and
columns I'll
say athletes if I hit tab you'll see it
will give me the prompt I'll select
athletes
DF I'll use
the shape
attribute let's run it and see the
result you can see here it gives me the
total number of rows so 2 lakh 71,1
20116 rows and earlier we had 15 columns
in the first data set and now that we
have added two more columns so the total
number of columns becomes 17 now
cool so now it's time to make
the column names
consistent so I'll show you how to do it
I'll say athletes uncore
DF dot I'll use the rename function and
then I'll say
columns equal
to I'll use curly
braces My First Column that is reg
I want to change it
to region but the r should be Capital
now or
uppercase I'll give a
comma and then see my second column this
should be region
actually my second column that is notes
I want to change the first letter to
uppercase so I'll say capital n the rest
all remains same I'll give a comma here
and say in place equal to true so it
will
change the column names and will
reflect in this athletes uncore D of
data
frame let's run it now to verify you can
again use the head function I'll run
this again let me scroll down and move
to the right you can see the difference
there you go so we have successfully
renamed the last two columns region and
notes all
right now moving
ahead
now I'll show you how you can use the
info method to print information about a
data frame including the index data type
the column data types non-null values
and memory
usage so for that you just need to use
the info function so I'll write athletes
uncore d DF
doino let's run it there you go so here
we have the data columns you can see
total 17 columns you have 2 lakh 71,1
2016 rows or entries then you have
the different column names and you say
it says non null and the data type of
the column below you can see some
information about the memory us
all
right
next the described method is used for
calculating statistical information such
as mean standard deviation the percenti
of the numerical values of the data
frame and much more it analyzes both
numeric and object series and also the
data frame column sets of mixed data
types so let me show you how
using the describe function you can
display some statistical
summary I'll just write
describe and give parenthesis let's run
it okay if I scroll down you can see
here by
default the describe function will only
give information about numerical columns
so here you can see we have the total
count the mean of each of these columns
you have the standard deviation the
minimum and maximum value and then we
have the 25th percentile the 50th
percentile and the 75th percentile value
of the columns ID age height weight and
year all right now one thing to notice
here is if you see the year column the
minimum year is
1,896 so this is when Olympics started
and until recently the r Olympics that
was held in
2016 all right now moving ahead now
let's check if there are any null values
present in The Columns of the data set
so first I going to create a variable
called Nan
values give equal to I'll see athletes
undor DF and the function to check is
I'll say is
na I'll create
another variable called
ncore
columns and here I'll use the any
function I'll say
ncore this variable which is underscore
values dot I'll see
any and I'll print my n columns variable
so this will display the result in terms
of Boolean values so if there are any
null or n or missing values in any of
the columns it will say true otherwise
it will say false let's display the
result there you go so if you Mark here
clearly so there
are nearly six columns where we have
missing values we have age height weight
metal region and notes columns that have
missing values so hence it has given us
true the rest of the columns do not have
any n an or missing values hence they
are false
all
right let me scroll
down
now let's see the total number of null
values for the above six
columns so I'll
say
athletes underscore DF dot I'll use the
function is null and again I'll use the
sum
function okay this should be is null if
I run it you can see it
here so our age column has
9,474 rows where we have null values
then we have some null values for the
height column as well for the weight
column so these are the total number
of rows where we don't have any
information regarding age height weight
or
region notes this medal is
self-explanatory because a lot of the
athletes who participate in Olympics
don't win any medals so for them the
value is na now before I move ahead I
have a question for you people so the
question is I want you to print the
column names containing null values or
missing values in the form of a list
so please answer this question and put
it in the comment section of the video
we would be happy to know your
approach so the question I'll repeat it
again I want you people to print the
column names containing null values or
missing values in the form of a list so
basically on the top we saw there
were six columns that had null values I
want you to print these six columns in
the form of a list all right now moving
ahead now let's see the data for
specific countries let's say you want to
see the athletes who have participated
in the Olympic Games from the beginning
for India for that you can filter your
result using a function called query so
let me show you how to do it I'll say
athletes uncore DF dot we'll use the
query
function and then
I'll say team which is my column name
should be equal to equal to and the
value I'll give is
India now let's display the first five
rows of
information or the details for the
athletes who are from India if I run
this okay there is some error here okay
so we need to make sure this entire
expression or the condition should be
within single quote I'll just delete
this single quote from here and we'll
add it in the
end now let's run it there you go so
here you can see we
have the top five rows
of the athletes who are from India you
can see here the region is India you can
see the nooc is India the team is India
and let me go to the left you can see
the name of the athlete the sex each so
for each you have some missing values
you have the weight team year and
everything all right similarly you can
also check for Japan let me just copy
the above
code I'll paste it here and instead of
India I'll say
Japan
I'll run it there you go so if you see
here you can see all the details are for
the athletes who are from Japan all
right moving ahead now I want to know
the top 10 countries who have
participated since the Inception of
Olympics in
1896 so for that I'll create a variable
called topor 10
uncore countries
I say equal
to I'll use my data frame that
is athletes uncore
DF I'll say dot
team then I'll use the
function value
underscore
counts I'm going to
sort my count in ascending
order just Mark the way in which I'm
writing the function
any error in terms of syntax of the flow
will throw you an error I want to
display the top 10 countries now let's
go ahead
and print it I'll say topor 10or
countries all right let me run
it okay it has given us an error let's
debug it okay so this should be value
counts and not count let's run it again
another
error okay so this should be short
underscore values and not value let's
run it again there you go so here you
can see the top 10 countries
participating in Olympics since 1896 you
have United States then we have France
so these are the number of participants
who have taken part since
1896 so the most number of participants
have come from us then we have France
Great Britain Italy Germany Canada Japan
Sweden we also have Australia and
Hungary I'll scroll
down now we are going to convert this
table that we got or the output that we
got in the form of a cph so I'm trying
to create a bar plot to plot the top 10
countries who have participated in Lumix
so here I'm using
the figure function to give the figure
size so these are the dimensions 12a 6
now I'll tell you what this PLT X6 means
just wait for a while I have given a
title to my plot saying overall
participation by
country and then using the cabor library
and the barplot function I am plotting
the X and
the Y AIS so my x axis has top I should
make this top 10 countries because above
we used topor 10or countries similarly
for y axis I'll make it topor 10or
countries and then I'm using a color
palette called set
two let's run it there you go so if I
scroll down you can see here we have a
nice
bar plot this is a vertical bar plot and
here you can see the bars which
represent the different country names
first we have United States which has
the highest participation since the
beginning of the Olympics then we have
France Great Britain Italy Germany
Canada and we have the rest of the
countries
cool now moving
ahead the next visualization we are
going to see is the the age distribution
of the athletes so for this we are going
to create a histogram I'll be using the
matte plot lab Library specifically for
this
visualization so I'll say PLT do
figure will give the figure size using
the argument fig size equal
to and this will be a tle
actually my size is going to be 12a 6
I'll
say
PLT
dot
title now you can
give any title that you want I'll say
age
distribution of the
athletes then we'll also give the X
labels I'll say PLT do
X
label this will have
age then we see PLT do y
label and this will
have the label as number
of
participants next I'm going to use the
hist function so I'll say PLT
doist and I
I'll pass in my data frame that
is athletes undor
DF dot age which is my column name comma
I'm going to pass in the
bins for that I'm going to use the NP do
earing function so NP is for
NP and inside this I'll say 10 comma
80 comma 2 so my bins will start from
the value 10 and go until 80 with a size
of
two
comma I'll give another parameter that
is going to specify the color of the
bins I want my color to be
orange and then I'll use the edge color
to separate the
bins I'll say Edge color this is
the parameter or the argument name and
the color I want is
white let's give a semicolon here and
this should be Edge color there's a
spelling mistake here now let's run it
and we'll see the output so there you go
so this is a nice histogram that shows
the distribution of the age of the
athletes you can see the title age
distribution of the athletes on the y
axis you have the number of participants
on the xaxis we have the age values
ranging from 10 to 80 with a size of
2 and if you see this we have most
number of athletes who have a age
between 20 to 30 you can see here so
early 20s we have maximum number of
athletes participating in the Olympics
we also have a few athletes who are
Beyond 40 years of age you can see here
we we have a few athletes even closer to
60 also and similarly we have a few
athletes who are under 18 years of
age all
right now you can see here the bins we
had taken orange color so are all
the bars are represented in orange color
and the edge you can see here we have
the white color all
right now moving ahead
now in the initial slides of the video
we discussed the summer and winter
Olympic games let's look at the
different sporting events that are part
of the summer and winter Olympic Games
just to give you a heads up the Winter
Olympic Games are held once every four
years for sports practiced on snow and
ice so here I have my variable name
wintercore Sports so I'm
extracting for season equal to equal to
Winter and I am going to display only
the unique values now let me run this
cell okay so you can see here these are
the different winter sports that
are held during the winter Olympics now
similarly let's see for Summer Olympics
so what I'm going to do here is I'll
just copy this cell of code and we'll
edit the variables I'll say
summercore sports athlets _ DF Remains
the Same here season will change it
to
Summer do sport do unique Remains the
Same and here I'll see summercore
Sports this should be small now let's
run it there you go so here you can see
we
have more number of Olympic sports that
are held during the summer olympics
compared
to Winter Olympics so these are the
sports that have played on snow and ice
and these are the sports that are played
during
summer moving ahead now it's time to
analyze the total number of male and
female participants who have taken part
in different games since 1896 till 2016
Rio
Olympics all right so I'll
see
gender underscore counts which is my
variable name I'll use
my data frame that is athletes uncore DF
dot my variable name that is sex dot
Valore
counts and then we are going to
print gender uncore
counts let's run this there you go so
since the Inception ofmp pics we have
more number of male participants than
female
participants now here in this current
cell you can see we are trying to plot a
pie chart for male and female athletes
so I have given my figure size then I
have my title as gender distribution I'm
using the matplot lab library and the pi
function I'm using the variable gender
counts that we used here then I'm giving
my labels as gender counts. index now
I'm using this autop PCT the autop PCT
parameter enables you to display the
percent value using python string
formatting so this is my string
formatting that I have used and I'm
initialized my start angle for the pie
chart as 150° and I'm also giving Shadow
to my pie chart so I have written Shadow
equal to True let's run it all right so
you can see here this is my pie chart
that shows you the distribution of the
male and female participation so for
male it is
72.5% for female so far it is 27.5% as
per the data set that we have we can
change this start angle to let's say
180° and it will change the pie chart to
this
direction cool now moving ahead
this time we're going to find the total
number of medals that the athletes have
won so I'll use
my data frame athletes DF Dot and then
my column that is medal I'll say dot
value uncore
counts let's run it there you go so you
can see the gold medals the bronze
medals and the silver medals are very
much similar to each other the numbers
are pretty much the
same all right now it's time to focus on
the total female athletes who have taken
part in each
Olympics so I'll create a variable
called female
uncore
participants I'll say equal to and then
use my data frame name that is athletes
uncore
DF using square
brackets I'll
see
athletes underscore DF
dot the gender should be equal to equal
to
female and I'll use
erson I'll
say just copy
this paste it
here LC do
season equal to equal to we'll check for
Summer
Olympics and I want to extract only the
gender column so here it is sex
comma my year column which is
here
okay and then I'll
say
female
underscore participants
equal
to I'll just copy
this paste it here and then I'll use the
group by
function say Group by which is part of
the pandas
Library I'll say
here and then I want to find the
count I'll reset the
index say reset uncore index this is a
function and finally we are going to
print female uncore
participants and let's say the
head all right so what we are trying to
do is I'm trying to filter my data only
for the female athletes for Summer
Olympics and here I am
printing the participation based on each
year so I'm finding out the count
so here we need to
add one more square
bracket all right now we'll run it and
see the result there you go so you can
see here from 1900
1994 all these years you can see the
female
participation let me change it to tail
so that we have the recent data of the
Olympics you can see it here for the
Beijing Olympics
5,816 women athletes participated in
2012 London Olympics we had 5, 8115
Olympics similarly for the 2016 re
Olympics we had more participation than
the London Olympics so
6,223 women athletes had
participated all
right now here this is another way in
which you can filter your data for
female athletes so I'm using two
parameters my gender should be equal to
female and season is Summer Olympics let
me just run it I have stored it in a
variable called women
Olympics now here I'm trying to find a
count plot or I'm trying to create a
account plot using my cbon SNS Library
I've set my style to dark grid then my
figure size I have given as 20 comma 10
my count plot will have the
x-axis as year the data is women
Olympics and pallet I'm using as
spectral and then I have given a title
women participation let's run and see
the
output there you go if I scroll down you
can see on the top I have the title for
my count plot which says women
participation and on the y axis I have
the count and at the bottom you can see
the different year values from 1900 till
2016 and 2016 had the highest number of
female
participation cool let me scroll down so
in this cell of code we are trying to
plot a line graph let me run it and show
you the output so this line graph shows
the trend which says plot for female
athletes over time so here you can see
the line graph so gradually the women
participation has increased in Olympics
since its Inception there was a slight
decrease here this is
around
1950s and again that you can see here
there's a decrease with the women
participation in 1980 but since then
since 1980 there has been
continuous increase in the participation
of female athlete numbers cool now
coming to the next section of our
analysis we are going to filter the data
to see the details of the athletes who
have won gold
medals so I'll create a variable called
gold
medals it's equal to I'll use
my data frame as athletes uncore
DF
and within then parenthesis I'll use my
data frame name which is
athletes
uncore DF
dot I'll use the condition medal equal
to equal
to and my value would be
gold next I'm going to
say gold medals.
head let let's run it there you go so
here we have
the top five rows of the athletes who
have won a gold medal you can see all
the records have medal as
gold now we are going to use
this
subset of the data and perform some more
analysis so
here I want to take only the values that
are different from n so I'm going to use
is
finite function and inside that I have
said gold medals age let me just run it
cool now I want to
see the athletes who have secured a gold
medal beyond the age of 60 years which
is very
rare so we'll see the total number of
athletes with more than 60 years of age
having won a gold
medal so here I'm going to
say gold
medals I'll use
my column as
ID and
then I'll
use my variable gold
medals and
then I'll say
age should
be greater
than
60 and then I'll close my square bracket
and say
count okay let me just verify if
everything is
fine yeah I'll run it and we'll see the
result so there are
total six athletes who have won a gold
medal having age more more than 60 years
cool now let me
check for
which sport these six gold medals have
come so I'll
say sporting uncore event this is going
to be my variable
name equal to I'll use
the same variable name gold
medals I'll going to
choose my sport column and
then I'll give
my condition
AG greater than
60 now let's go ahead and will
print the variable sporting event if I
run this you can see it here
so for art
competitions even for archery and
suiting and this one called
Rook we have had gold medals from
athletes who had an
age more than 60 years now we are going
to
plot this result or the table that we
achieved on the
top so I'll say PLT do figure
I'll give
my figure
size equal to let's say 10 comma
5 then I'll say PLT
dot we'll use
the tight
layout see tight underscore
layout then I'm going to use the cbon
library
and create a count plot for my
variable sporting underscore
event then I'll see PLT do
title I'll give the title as gold
medals
for athletes over 60 years of
age let's run
it and if I scroll down you can see here
we have an a nice count plot I have my
title gold medals for athletes over 60
years and since for archery we had three
players who secured a gold medal having
an age more than 60
years you can see here archery is three
art competition one Rook is one and
shooting we had one
medal all
right now we'll see the total gold
medals from each country so for
that I'll
say
gold
medals dot we'll use
the region column and followed by that
I'll use the value underscore counts
function and I'll reset the
index with
name equal to I'll provide the the medal
column then we are going to print the
head for the top
five countries let me run it you can see
it
here
so
USA has secured the most number of gold
medals then we have Russia Germany UK
and then we have
Italy
cool now in this cell I'm going to
create a plot
to visualize the table that I got above
so I've used my labels my titles I'm
using the cat plot function that is
present in the cbon library I have my x-
Axis my y AIS the data which is total
gold
medals let me just
verify okay and we'll run
it if I scroll down
you can see this is a different pallet
that I had used which is
rocket and you can see USA has got the
most number of gold medals then we have
Russia Germany UK Italy and France now
we also have included France here which
was not present in this table the reason
being I have used head as six so it will
give me the top six
countries all right now we will analyze
and look at the data for the most recent
Olympic event that is present in our
data set I'm talking about the
2016 Rio Summer
Olympics so first of all I'll create a
variable called Max
year which will be equal to my data
frame name athletes unor
DF my column name year and I'll use the
max
function then let's go ahead and print
my Max here
I'll just show you the output you can
see here my Max year present in the data
set is 2016 the r
Olympics
next we will create another variable
called teamore
names that will be equal to
my data frame name athletes
DF within square brackets I'll give
parenthesis and then see
athletes uncore DF dot
ear should be equal to equal
to my output that is Max here which is
actually
2016 and then I'll
say
erson I'll just copy
this we'll paste it here
this time I'll use
the middle column and say equal to equal
to
Gold I'll say dot
team then I'll say
teamore names
do
value
underscore counts
do head and we'll display the top
countries let me run this there you go
so in Rio
Olympics United States secured the most
number of gold medals now the reason
this is 137 is we have also counted the
team events for example
basketball similarly Great Britain had
had 64 gold medals in total Russia 50 we
have Brazil 34 Argentina 21 France 20
and Japan
17 all
right
now using the above result we are going
to create a bar plot I'll just change
this teamore list to teamore names
similarly here also I'll make the
corrections as teamore names cool now
we'll run it and you can see here we
have a nice horizontal bar plot so we
have United States at the top Great
Britain Russia Germany China Brazil so
here I'm displaying the top 20 Nations
since I have used head as 20 so these
are the top 20 Nations who secured the
most number of gold medals in the real
Olympics all right
now in the final section of this video
we will create a scatter plot to
visualize the height and weight of male
and female athletes who have won a medal
now it can be a gold medal a silver
medal or a bronze medal but before that
we need to filter the data only for
athletes who have won a medal now if
you had noticed here
our medals column also had a few null
values so we are not going to consider
those null values here we are only going
to consider for the athletes who have
bur a medal so for that I'll create
a variable called notore
nullcore
medals equal to I'll
say athlete Le underscore
DF
then I'll give
my let's make it
DF I'll give my
condition let me just copy
this I'll paste it
here and
then I'll give my condition
height and use
the not null
function and then I'll say
Amberson create another parenthesis I'll
see athletes uncore
DF this time we'll consider the weight
column again I'll use the function as
not
null
and I'll close the
parenthesis okay I had missed one s here
cool let me just run it now all
right now we are going to create our
final plot I'll say PLT do
figure I'll give my figure
size equal to I'll say 12 comma
10 I'll say
access equal to SNS dot we'll be
creating a scatter plot to plot
the height and weight of the athletes
who have won a
medal I'll say scatter plot in my x-axis
I'll
have
height
comma in my y- AIS I'll have
V
comma my data should
be not underscore null underscore
medals so this is what we created here
notore nullcore medals comma I'll use H
equal to my six
column cool finally I'll say PLT dot
I'll give a title to my plot
seeing height
versus
weight
of
Olympic
medalist cool now let's see our scatter
plot this might take some time to give
the result because there are so many
athletes present in a data set who have
won a medal and also we are
filtering in terms of hue which is for
male and female there you go so if I
scroll down you can see here we have a
nice scatter plot on the top we have the
title of the plot saying height versus
weight of Olympic medalist you can see
our age as the hue so blue points are
for the male athletes and orange points
are for the female
athletes and on the y- axis we have the
weight in terms
of kilog and you have the height in
terms of
ctim
cool so that brings us to the end of
this demo session on Olympics data set
analysis so we used two data sets to
carry out this exploratory data analysis
and we created some visualizations to
analyze and visualize the data all right
want to be a certified data expert then
here we have postgraduate program in
data analytics by simply learn take a
glance at the notable features and
skills offered in this course you will
benefit from exclusive IBM hackathons
and ask me anything sessions eight times
more interaction in live online classes
with IND indry experts Capstone projects
across three domains and over 14 data
analytics projects using real data sets
from Google Play Store Lyft World Bank
and more master classes from puu faculty
and IBM experts along with simply learn
job assist for better job prospects
acquire skills in data analytics
statistical analysis using Excel data
analysis using Python and R and data
visualization using tableu and powerb
enroll Now using the course Link in the
description
box do you know what's common between
International Tech giants like meta
Google and a Smalls size d2c startup
that is running from Jakarta is it the
product their services or their work
culture not really the biggest common
denominator between all tech companies
globally today's data and AI the
overarching need of utilizing data for
decision making and implementing the
almost necessary capabilities of AI in a
product or service has become the demand
of the home all things considered
wouldn't it be amazing if you can
utilize AI to perform some of the most
complex processing and analytics task on
data I think your answer would be yes
with that being said hello everyone and
welcome to this extremely important
video in data analytics using AI in this
video we will discuss how you can
utilize AI for performing data analytics
which is the very first skill you must
learn to make a career in the field of
data analytics business analytics and
even becoming a data scientist but
before we begin with that make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon for regular updates the fear
is in there whether it's marketing
automating building driving medical
practice or anything you name AI can do
it coming into data analytics which is
believed to be one of the promising
career options AI is getting integrated
and it is leveraging analytics by
enhancing and revolutionizing the way
data is analyzed interpreted and used to
derive meaningful insights here are some
key ways in which AI is leveraging
analytics number one data processing and
preparation AI algorithms automate and
streamline data processing tasks
including data cleaning data integration
and data transformation this enables
faster and more efficient data
preparation ensuring that high quality
data is available for analysis the next
is pattern recognition and anomaly
detection AI powered analytics systems
excelerate recognizing complex patterns
in large data sets machine learning
algorithms can identify hidden patterns
Trends and relationships that may not be
apparent to human analyst additionally
AI algorithms can detect anomalies or
outliers in data helping to identify
potential issues or fraudulent
activities and the next is Predictive
Analytics
AI techniques such as predictive
modeling and forecasting enable
organizations to make accurate
predictions about future events or
outcomes based on historical data by
averaging AI algorithms business can
anticipate customer Behavior demand
Trends Market changes and more allowing
for proactive decision making and the
next we have is natural language
processing and text analytics AI powered
NLP techniques and enable the analysis
of unstructured data such as text
documents social media posts customer
reviews and emails by extracting and
analyzing textual information
organizations can gain valuable insights
into customer sentiment market trends
and emerging topics and the next we have
is automated insights and Reporting AI
powered analytics systems can
automatically generate meaningful
insights and reports Based on data
analysis this reduces the time and
effort required for manual analysis and
Reporting allowing analyst to focus on
higher value tasks like interpretation
and strategy development and the next we
have is personalization and
recommendation systems a algorithms are
employed in recommendation systems that
provide personalized suggestions to
users based on their preferences
behavior and historical data this is
particularly prevalent in e-commerce
streaming services and content platforms
where a driven recommendations enhance
user experiences and drive customer
engagement and next we have is
optimization and decision support a
algorithms can optimize complex
processes and decision making by
valuating multiple variables constraints
and scenarios for example AI powered
optimization models can assist in Supply
Chain management resource allocation
inventory planning and pricing
strategies that helps organizations
achieve better operational efficiency
and cost savings and the next we have is
continuous learning and Improvement AI
systems have the ability to continuously
learn and adapt based on new data and
feedback this allows analytics models to
improve their accuracy and performance
over time making them more effective in
generating valuable insights and
predictions and by leveraging AI
capabilities in analytics organizations
can unlock the full potential of their
data gain a competitive advantage and
drive datadriven decision making across
various domains the Synergy between Ai
and analytics is revolutionizing how
businesses extract insights from data
leading to transformative outcomes and
Innovations if you are watching this I
believe you are either an aspiring data
analyst or a professional already now
the question of the r is Will AI replace
you should I even care to proceed with a
C in data analytics don't worry we are
here to answer your questions and make
things less complicated or we believe we
can sort it out now a is designed to
assist humans for example jity B and B
this smart AI language models can
automate the time consuming task such as
writing down emails performing data
extraction transformation and loading
and exploratory analysis and Reporting
however in the real time every
organization has specifically customized
needs and requirements a special set of
KS and kpis to address you may have to
understand the business requirements and
build a custom dashboards you may have
to understand the realtime streaming of
data integrate AWS with powerbi not just
these there are a gazillion tasks that
need human intervention and
Logics I still lacks the human cognition
and the ability acquiring the domain
knowledge which only a human can you as
a data analyst may need to understand
that AI can perform a redundant and
straightforward task but not the
critical operations which completely
rely on a
human only a human has the caliber to
decode the intentions of the client and
simplify the technical Concepts to
nontechnical client has a strong focus
on the business outcomes most
importantly try to unravel the potential
of of AI and leverage it to improvise
and gete if you are someone that not
only performs analysis but also is a
torch Bearer the organization with the
right business strategies in very short
time then you are someone which all
major Tech Giants need a study from new
Vantage Partners suggest 97.2% of
companies are now investing in data and
its analysis nowadays every company
needs a data expert do you also want to
become a part of this Market if yes how
to become a part of of it what are the
essential skills one should
have this video will answer all these
questions but before watching this video
please subscribe to Simply learns
YouTube channel and press the Bell icon
to never miss any updates question for
you which one of the following is not a
python library for
visualization mat lot lip sapai Panda
Jupiter notebook please leave the answer
in the comment section below moving on
who is a data analyst a data analyst
collects analyzes and interprets data a
data analyst will convert raw data into
useful information data analyst are in
high demand because every industry uses
data analysis work of a data analyst as
a data analyst you will work closely
with the raw data and generate valuable
insights to help companies decide their
future goal if you like thinking out of
the box you are the perfect fit for this
domain data analyst help maximize output
when it comes to generating Revenue
working closely with with both business
and data nevertheless this field boost
handsome salaries for all levels of
expertise can become a data analyst
without prior experience yes anyone can
become a data analyst if they enjoy
solving real world problems have a
strong background in statistics and have
a creative mind if you feel you don't
have it you can definitely develop it so
let us know the skills in detail what
are the basic skill sets required for a
data analyst data analyst must know
basic mathematics ICS and statistics
programming skills machine learning and
also data visualization tools so let us
know what are the basics that you need
to learn as a data
analyst mathematics it is always better
to know basic mathematics like linear
algebra and probability fundamentals
linear algebra is used in data
pre-processing and transformation which
is the critical process of every data
analyst statistics a branch of mathem I
that deals with collection analysis
presentation and
implementation probability we know that
probability is the study of How likely
something will happen which is essential
for concluding both probability and
statistics are the backbones of data
analysis it is feasible to become a data
analyst with only a basic understanding
of these three areas of mathematics but
in order to remain relevant and grow as
a data analyst one's mathematical
knowledge should not be restricted
compulsorily use some of the tools as a
data analystic what are
that first is Microsoft Excel it is the
most well-known spreadsheet software in
the world it also has computation and
graphick features that are excellent for
data analyst no matter your area of
expertise or additional software you
might want Excel is a standard in the
industry it's useful built-in features
include form design tools and pivot
table it also generate a wide range of
additional features that help simplify
data
manipulation as a programming language
every data analyst should know python it
is easy to learn and has a simple syntax
python is quite adaptable and includes a
vast variety of resource libraries that
are appropriate for a wide range of
diverse data analytics activities these
libraries help in numerical and data
computation the pandas and numai
libraries for instance are excellent for
support in standard data processing and
stream lining highly computational
operations you can also choose between
Python or r r is a well-known
open-source programming language much
like python data visualization tool as
we previously mentioned data
visualization tool is also necessary to
become a data analyst powerbi is a
userfriendly interface makes building
interactive visual reports and dashboard
simple its most vital selling point is
its superb data integration it works
flawlessly with Cloud sources like
Google and Facebook analytics as well as
text files SQL servers and
Excel is one of the best commercial data
analysis tool available it handles huge
amounts of data better than many other
bi tools and is effortless it has a
visual drag and drop interface however
because it has no scripting layer there
is a limit to what tblo can do for
example it could would be better for
pre-processing data or building more
complex
calculations you might have heard about
MySQL a lot of time it is a standard
language for interacting with databases
and it is very helpful when working with
structure data SQL creates userfriendly
DBS that may present in various data
ways in since it is so simple to send
complex commands to databases and change
data in seconds it has commands like add
edit delete data in addition SQL is an
excellent tool for creating data
warehouses because of its Simplicity
Clarity and
interactivity overall I would suggest
that to become a data analyst you should
work on programming languages like
python or R plus MySQL to work on
databases adding to that Excel plus
visualization tools like Tablo or
powerbi you now know what are the skills
are and how it is used what what are you
up to in an organization as a data
analyst to create and evaluate the
report using automated tools like tblo
or
powerbi to troubleshoot the reporting
database environment and reports data
analyst you will use statistical method
to analyze data sets and spot any
valuable trends that may develop over
time evaluate company's functional and
non-functional requirement data analyst
assess data warehouse housing in
inspecting and Reporting needs these are
all the responsibility of a data analyst
in an organization coming to companies
hiring a data analyst IBM Accenture
capam mini TCS Facebook Amazon flip cart
meta these are the top companies hiring
a data analyst but data suggest that
every small and mediumsized Company
needs a data analyst therefore demand of
a data analyst is in every company so
there is no need to worry job and salary
of a data analyst this is the final part
the salary of a data analyst is high all
over the world when it comes to the USA
the average salary for a data analyst as
a beginner is going as high as 70,000
plus dollar per anom for experienced
professional it is going as high as
$120,000 per anom in India for a fresher
it is going as high as 8 lakh perom and
for experienced professionals it is 20
lakh plus per anom such is the demand
for data analyst now that we have
covered every important skill it's time
for you to start working on it hello and
welcome to data analytics interview
questions my name is Richard kersner
with the simplylearn team that's www.s
simply learn.com get certified get
ahead today we're going to jump into
some common questions you might see on
numpy arrays and Panda's data frames and
in the python along with some Excel
Tableau and
SQL let's start with our first question
what is the difference between Data
Mining and data
profiling it's really important to note
that data mining is a process of finding
relevant information which has not been
found before it is a way in which raw
data is turned into valuable information
you can think of this as anything from
the
cells uh stats and from their SQL Server
all the way to web scraping and Census
Bureau information where the heck do you
mine it from where do you get all this
data and
information then we look at data
profiling is usually done to assess a
data set for its uniqueness consistency
and logic it cannot identify incorrect
or inaccurate data values so if somebody
has a statistical analysis on one side
and they're doing their you might the
wrong data to then program your data
setup so you got to be aware that when
you're talking about data mining you
need to look at the Integrity of what
you're bringing in where it's coming
from data profiling is looking at it and
saying hey how is this going to work
what's the logic what's the consistency
is it related to what I'm working with
find the term data wrangling and data
analytics data wrangling is a process of
cleaning structuring and enriching the
raw data into a desired usable format
for better decision making and you can
see a nice chart here with our Discover
it we structure the data how we want it
we clean it up get rid of all those null
values we enrich it so we might take and
reformat some of the settings instead of
having uh five different terms for
height of somebody you know an American
English or whatever who clean some of
that up and we might do a calculation
and bring some of them together and
validate I was just talking about that
in the last one need to validate your
data make sure you have a solid data
source and and then of course it goes
into the analysis very important to
notice here in data wrangling 80% of
data analytics is used in this whole
part of wrangling the data getting it to
fit correctly and don't confuse that
with data cooking which is actually when
you're going into neural networks
cooking the data so it's all be between
zero and one
values what are common problems that
data analysts encounter during
analysis handling duplicate and missing
values collecting the meaningful right
data the right time making data secure
in dealing with compliance issues
handling data purging and storage
problems again we're talking about data
wrangling here 80% of most jobs are in
wrangling that data and getting it in
the right format making sure it's good
data to
use number four what are the various
steps involved in any analytics
project understand the problem we might
spend 80% doing wrangling but you better
be ready to understand the problem
because if you can't you're going to
spend all your time in the wrong
direction this is probably uh the most
important part of the process everything
after it falls in and then you can come
back to it two data collection data
cleaning number three four data
exploration analysis and five interpret
the results number five is a close
second for being the most important if
you can't interpret what you bring to
the table to your clients you're in
trouble so when this question comes up
you probably want to focus on those two
noting that the rest of it does 80% of
the work is in two three and four while
one and five are the most important
parts which technical tools have you use
for analysis and presentation purposes
being a data analyst you are expected to
have knowledge of the below tools for
analysis and presentation purposes
there's a wide variety out there uh SQL
Server
MySQL you have your Excel your SPSS
which is the IBM platform Tablo python
uh you have all these different Tools in
here now certainly a lot of jobs are
going to be narrowed in on just a few of
these tools like you're not going to
have a Microsoft SQL server and MySQL
server but you better understand how to
do basic SQL polls and also
understanding Excel and how the
different formats um for column and how
to get those set
up number six what are the best
practices for data cleaning this is
really important to remember to go
through this in detail these always come
up because 80% of most data analysis is
in cleaning the data make a data
cleaning plan by understanding where the
common errors take place and keep
Communications open identify and remove
duplicates before working with the data
this will lead to an effective data
analysis process focus on the accuracy
of the data maintain the value types of
data provide mandatory constraints and
set Cross Field validation standardize
the data at the point of entry so that
is less chaotic and you will be able to
ensure that all the information is
standardized leading to fewer errors on
Entry number seven how can you handle
missing values in a data set listwise
deletion and listwise deletion method
entire record is excluded from analysis
if any single value is missing sometimes
we're talking about records remember
this could be a single line in a
database so if you have uh your SQL
comes back and you have 15 different
columns every one of those that has a
missing value you might just drop it
just to make it easy because you already
have enough data to do the processing
average
imputation use the average value of the
responses from the other participants to
fill in the missing value this is really
useful uh and they'll ask you why these
are useful I guarantee it uh if you have
a whole group of data that's collected
and it doesn't have that information in
it at that point you might average it in
there regression substitution you can
use multiple regression analysis to
estimate a missing value that kind of
goes with the average imputation input
uh regression model means you're just
going to get you're going to actually
generate a prediction as to what you
think that value should be for those
people based on the ones you do have
multiple imputation so we talk about
multiple inputs uh it creates plausible
values based on the correlations for the
missing data and then averag the
simulated data sets by incorporating
random errors in your
predictions what do you understand by
the term normal
distribution and the second you heard
the word normal distribution should be
thinking a bell curve like we see here
normal distribution is a type of
continuous probability distribution that
is symmetric about the mean and in the
graph normal distribution will appear as
a bell curve the mean median and mode
are equal that's a quick way to know if
you have normal distribution is you can
compute mean median and mode all of them
are located at the center of the
distribution 68% of the data lies within
one standard deviation of the mean 95%
of the data Falls within two standard
deviations of the mean 99.7% of the data
lies within three standard deviations of
the
mean what is time series analysis time
series analysis is a statistical method
that deals with ordered sequence of
values of a variable of equally spaced
time intervals time series data on a
covid-19 cases and you can see we're
looking at by days so our space of days
and each day goes by if we take and
graph it you can see a Time series graph
always looks really nice you have like
two different in this case we have what
the United States going over there I'd
have to look at the other setup in there
but they picked a couple different
countries uh and it yes is time
sensitive you know the next result is
based on what the last one was Co is an
excellent example of this uh anytime you
do any word analytics where you're
figuring out what someone's saying what
they said before makes a huge difference
is what they're going to say next
another form of Time series
analysis 10 how is joining different
from blending in Tabo so now we're going
to jump into the tblo package data
joining data joining can only be done
when the data comes from the same Source
combining two tables from the same
database or two or more worksheets from
the same Excel file all the combined
tables or sheets contains common set of
dimensions and measures data blending
data blending is used when the data is
from two or more different sources
combining the Oracle table with the SQL
server or two sheets from Excel or
combining Excel sheet and Oracle table
in data blending each data source
contains its own set of dimensions and
measures how is overfitting different
from
underfitting always a good one uh
overfitting probably the biggest uh
danger in data analytics today is over
fitting model trains from the data too
well using the training set the
performance drops significantly over the
test set happens when the model learns
the noise and random fluctuations in the
training data set in detail and again
the performance drops way below what the
test set has the model neither trains
the data well nor can generalize to new
data performs poorly both on train and
the test set happens when there is less
data to build and an accurate model and
also when we try to build a linear model
with a nonlinear
data in Microsoft Excel a numeric value
can be treated as a text value if it
proceeds with an apostrophe definitely
not an exclamation uh if you're used to
programming in Python you'll look for
that hash code and not an Amber
sign and we can see here uh if you enter
the value 10 into a field but you put
the apostrophe in front of it it will
read that as a text not as a
number what is the difference between
count count a count blank and count if
in
Excel we can see here when we run in
just count D1 through
d23 we get 19 and you'll notice that
there is 19 numbers coming down here and
so it doesn't count the cost of each
which is a top bracket it doesn't count
the blank spaces either with the
straight count when you do a count a
you'll get the answer is 20 so now when
you do count a it counts all of them
even the title cost of
each when you do count blank we'll get
three why there's three blank
fills and finally the count if if we do
count if of E1 to e23 is greater than 10
there's 11 values in there basic
counting of whatever is in your column
pretty solid it on the table
there explain how vlookup Works in
Excel vlookup is used when you need to
find things in a table or a range by
Row the syntax has four different parts
to it uh we have our lookup value that's
a value you want to look up we have our
table
array uh the range where the lookup
value is
located column index number the column
number and range that contains the
return value and the range lookup
specify true if you want an approximate
match or false if you want an exact
match of the return
value so here we see V lookup F3 A2 to
C8 2 comma 0 for prints now they don't
show the F3 F3 is the actual um cell
that prints is in that's what we're
looking at is F3 so there's your prints
he pulls in from F3 A2 to C8 is the the
data we're looking into
and then number two is a column in that
data so in this case we're looking for
uh uh age and we count name is one AG is
two keep in mind this is Excel versus a
lot of your um Python and programming
languages where you start at zero in
Excel we always look at the cells as one
two three so two represents the age zero
is uh false for having an exact matchup
versus one we don't actually need to
worry about that too much in this zero
or one would work with this example and
you can see with the Angela lookup again
her name would be in the F column number
four that's what the F4 stands for is
where where they pulled Angela from and
then you have A1 to C8 and then we're
looking at uh number three so number
three is height name being one age two
and then height three and you'll see
here pulls in her height
5.8 so we're going to run jump over to
uh SQL how do you subset or filter data
in
SQL to subset our filter data in SQL we
use where and having clause and you can
see we have a nice table on the left
where we have the title the director the
year the duration we want to filter the
table for movies that were directed by
Brad Bird um why just because we want to
know who what Brad Bird did so we're
going to do select star you should know
that the star refers to all in this case
where what are we going to return we're
going to return all typ directory year
and duration that's what we mean by all
from movies movies being our table where
director equals Brad Bird and you can
see um he comes back and he did the
incredible and Rit
2E to subset or filter data SQL we can
also use the wear and having Clause so
we're going to take a closer look at the
um different ways we can filter here
filter the table for directors whose
movies have an average duration greater
than 115 minutes so there's a lot of
really cool things into this SQL query
and these SQL queries can get pretty
crazy select director sum duration as
total duration average duration as
average duration from movies Group by
director having average duration greater
than
115 uh so again what are we going to
return we're going to return whatever we
put in our select which in this case is
director we're going to have total
duration and that's going to be the sum
of the duration
we're going to have the average duration
average underscore duration which is
going to be the average duration on
there and then we of course go ahead and
group by director and we want to make
sure we group them by uh anyone that has
an having an average duration greater
than
115 these SQL queries are so important I
don't know how many times your the SQL
comes up and there's so many different
other languages not just MySQL and not
Microsoft SQL but in addition to that
where the SQL language comes in uh
especially with Hadoop and other areas
so you really should know your basic
SQL doesn't hurt to get that little um
cheat sheet and glance over it and
double check some of the different
features in
SQL what is the difference between wear
and having clause and SQL where wear
Clause works on row data in wear Clause
the filter occurs before any groupings
are made aggregate functions cannot be
used uh so the syntax is Select your
columns from table where what the
condition is having Clause works on
aggregated data having is used to filter
values from a group aggregate functions
can be used in the syntax is Select
column names from table where the
condition is grouped by having a
condition ordered by column
names what is the correct Syntax for
reshaped function in numpy so we're
going to jump to the numpy array program
and what you come up with is you have uh
in this case be numpy do reshape a lot
of times you do an import numpy as NP
reshape and then your array and then new
shape and you can see here as we uh as
the actual um example comes in the
reshape is a and we're going to reshape
it in two comma five uh setups and you
can see the print out in there that
prints in two rows with five values in
each
one what are the different ways to
create data frame in
pandas well we can do it by initializing
a list so you can Port your pandas as PD
very common data equals Tom 30 Jerry 20
Angela 35 we'll go ahead and create the
data frame and we'll say uh pd. datf
frame is the data columns equals name
and age so you can designate your
columns you can also is a index in there
should always remember that the index uh
in this case maybe you want the index
instead of one two to be um the date
they signed up or who knows you know
whatever and you can see right there it
just generates a nice pandas data frame
with Tom Jerry and Angela another way
you can initialize a uh data frame is
from dictionary you can see here we have
a dictionary where the date equals name
Tom Jerry Angela Mary age is 20 21 1918
and if we do a
dfpd do dataframe on the data you'll get
a nice the same kind of setup you get
your name age Tom Jerry Angela and
Mary write the python code to create an
employees data frame from the empcs v
file and display the head and summary of
it to create a data frame in Python you
need to import the Panda's library and
use the read CSV function to load the
CSV file and here you can see where we
have import pandas as PD employees or
the dataframe employees equals pd. read
CSV and then you have your path to that
CSV file there's a number of settings in
the read CSV where you can tell it how
many rows are the top index uh you can
set the columns in there you can have uh
skip rows there's all kinds of things
you can also go in there and double
check with your read CSV but the most
basic one is just to read a basic
CSV how will you select the department
and age columns from an employees data
frame so we have import pandas as ped
you can see we have created our data uh
we will go ahead and create our
employees PD data frame on the left and
then on the right to select department
and age from the data frame uh we just
do employees and you put the brackets
around it now if you're just doing one
column you could do just department but
if you're doing multiple columns you got
to have those in a second set of bracket
so it's got to be a reference with a
list within the
reference what is the criteria to say
whether a developed data model model is
good or not a good model should be
intuitive insightful and
self-explanatory follow the old saying
kiss keep it simple the model developed
should be able to easily consumed by the
clients for actionable and profitable
results so if they can't read it what
good is it a good model should easily
adapt to changes according to business
requirements we live in quite a dynamic
world nowadays so that's pretty
self-evident and if the data gets up
updated the model should be able to
scale accordingly to the new data so you
have a nice data pipeline going where
when something when you get new data
coming in you don't have to go and
rewrite the whole
code what is the significance of
exploratory data
analysis exploratory data analysis is an
important step in any data analysis
process exploratory data analysis Eda
helps to understand the data better it
helps you obtain confidence in your data
to a point where you're ready to engage
a machine learning algorithm it allows
you to refine your selection of feature
variables that will be used later for
model building you can discover hidden
Trends and insights from the data how do
you treat outliers in a data set an
outlier is a data point that is distant
from other similar points they may be
due to variability in the measurement or
may indicate experimental
errors uh one you can drop the outlier
records pretty straightforward you can
cap your outlier 's data so it doesn't
go past a certain value you can assign
it a new value you can also try a new
transformation to see if those outliers
come in if you transform it slightly
differently explain descriptive
predictive and prescriptive analytics
descriptive provides insights into the
past to answer what has happened uses
data aggregation and data mining
techniques examples an ice cream company
compan can analyze how much ice cream
was sold which flavors were sold and
whether more or less ice cream was sold
than
before predictive understands the future
to the answer what could happen uses
statistical models and forecasting
techniques example predicts the sale of
ice creams during the summer spring and
rainy days uh so this is always
interesting because you have your
descriptive which comes in and your
businesses are always looking to know
what happened hey did we have good sales
last uh quarter what what are we
expecting next quarter in sales and we
have a huge jump when we do uh
prescriptive suggest various courses of
action to answer what should you do uses
optimization and simulation algorithms
to advise possible outcomes example
lower prices to increase sell of ice
creams produce more or less quantities
of certain flavor of ice cream and we
can certainly uh today's world with the
covid virus because we had that on our
earlier graph you you could see that as
a descriptive what's happened how many
people have been infected how many
people have died in an area predictive
where do we predict that to go um do we
see it going to get worse is it going to
get better what do we predict that we're
going to need in hospital beds and
prescriptive what can we change in our
uh setup to have a better outcome uh
maybe if we did more social distancing
if we tracked the virus how do these
different things directly affect the end
and can we create a better ending by
changing some underlying uh
criteria what are the different types of
sampling techniques used by data
analysists sampling is a statistical
method to select a subset of data from
an entire data set population to
estimate the characteristics of the
whole population one we can do a simple
random sampling so we can just pick out
500 random people in the United States
to sample them you call it a population
in regular data we also call that a
population just because that's where it
came from was mainly from doing
census systematic sampling cluster
sampling stratified sampling and
judgment or purposive sampling then we
have our systematic sampling that's
where you're doing like uh uh using one
five 10 15 20 use a very systematic
approach for pulling samples uh from the
setup cluster sampling uh that's where
we look at it and we say hey some of
these things just naturally group
together if you were talking about
population which is the really a nice
way of looking at this cluster sampling
would be maybe by ZIP code we're going
to do everybody's zip code and just
naturally cluster it that way stratified
sampling would be more uh looking for
shared things the group has like income
uh so if you're studying something on
poverty you might look at their
naturally group people uh based on
income to begin with and then study
those individuals in the income to find
out what kind of traits they have and
then judgmental uh that is where the uh
researcher very carefully selects each
member of their own group uh so it's
very much um based on their personal
knowledge jumping on the 26 what are the
different types of hypothesis testing
hypothesis testing is a procedure used
by staticians and scientists to accept
or reject statistical hypothesis we
start with the hypothesis testing we
have null hypothesis and alternative
hypothesis on the null hypothesis it
states that there is no relation between
the predictor and the outcome variables
in the population it is denoted by H
notot example there is no association
between patients BMI and
diabetes alternative hypothesis it
states there is some relation between
the predictor and outcome variables in
the population it is denoted by H1
example there could be an association
between patients BMI and
diabetes and that's the body mass index
if you didn't catch the BMI and you're
not
MediCal describe univariate B variate
and multivariate
Analysis a univariate analysis it is the
simplest form of data analysis where the
data being analyzed contains only one
one variable an example is studying the
heights of players in the
NBA because it's so simple it can be
described using Central Tendencies
dispersion quartiles bar charts
histograms pie charts frequency
distribution tables the B variate
analysis it involves analysis of two
variables toine causes relationships and
correlations between the variables
example analyzing sale of ice creams
based on the temperature outside byari
analysis can be explained using
correlation coefficients linear
regression logistic regression Scatter
Plots and box
plots and multivariate Analysis it
involves analysis of three or more
variables to understand the relationship
of each variable with the other
variables example analyzing Revenue
based on expenditure so if we have our
TV ads we have our newspaper ads or
social media ads and our Revenue we can
now compare all those together the multi
analysis can be performed using multiple
regression factor analysis
classification and regression trees
cluster analysis principal component
analysis clustering bar chart dual AIS
chart what function would you use to get
the current date and time in Excel in
Excel you can use the today and now
function to get the current date and
time and you can see down here with the
two examples were just equals today or
equals
Now using the sum ifs function in Excel
find the total quantity sold by cell's
Representatives whose names start with a
and the cost of each item they have sold
is greater than
10 and you can see here on the left we
have our actual table and then we want
to go ahead and sum ifs so we want the
uh E2 through E2 20 B2 through B20
greater than 10 and this basically is
just saying hey we're going to take
everything in the u e column and we're
going to sum it up but only those
objects where the D column is greater
than 10 that's what that means
there is the below query correct if not
how will you Rectify it select customer
ID year order date as order Year from
order where order year is greater than
or equal to
2016 and hopefully you caught it right
there uh it's in the devils in the
details we can't not use the Alias name
while filtering data using the wear
Clause so the correct format is all the
same except for where it says where the
year order date is greater than or equal
to 16 versus using the order year which
we assign under the select
setup how are Union intersect and except
used in
SQL the union operator is used to
combine the results of two or more
select
statements and you can see here we have
select star from region one and we're
going to make a union with select star
from region two and it basically takes
both these SQL tables and combines them
to form a full new table on there so
that's your union as we bring everything
together when we look at the intersect
operator return Returns the common
records that are the result of the two
or more select statements so you can see
here we select star from region one
intersect select star from region two
and we come up with only those record
that are shared that have the same data
in them and hopefully you jumped uh
ahead to the accept the accept operator
returns The Uncommon records that are
the result of two or more select
statements so these are the two records
or the records that are not shared
between the two databases
using the product price table write an
SQL query to find the record with the
fourth highest market
price so here we have a little bit of a
brain teaser uh they're always fun and
the first thing we want to do is we're
going to go ahead and uh I'm going to if
you look at the uh script on the left we
really want the fourth one down so we're
going to select the top four from
product price but we're going to order
it by market price descending SP order
by market price ascending so what we do
is we take the top four of the market
price ascending and that's going to give
us the four greatest values and then
we're going to reverse that order and do
descending and we're going to take the
top one of that which is going to give
us the lowest value which will be the
fourth greatest one in the
list from the product price table find
the total and average market price for
each currency where the average market
price is greater than 100 and currency
is in the INR or the
AUD so um INR or AUD India Rupal or
Australia dollar you can see over here
the SQL query if you had trouble putting
this together uh you might actually do
some of it in reverse and you can see
right here where the average market
price is greater than 50 remember we use
use having not where at the end because
it's part of the group so Group by
currency because we want those two
currencies and we want the currency
India rup the INR or the
AUD and um as you keep going backwards
we're actually going to be selecting the
currency the sum of the market price as
total price and the average market price
as average price so there's our select
it's going to come from the product
price which is just our table over there
and then we have where our currency is
in uh and like I said you can put
together however you want but hopefully
you got to the end
there so this question will test your
knowledge in tblo exploring the
different features of Tabo and creating
a suitable graph to solve a business
problem and of course Tabo is very
visual in its use so it's very hard to
test it without actually just getting
your hands on and if you can't visualize
some of this and how to do it then you
should go back and refresh yourself
using the sample superstor data set
Create A View to analyze the sales
profits and quantity sold across
different subcategories of items present
under each category so the first step is
to go ahead and load the sample
superstor data set so make sure you know
how to load the sample the superstor
data set that's underneath either the
connect button in the upper left um or
the um table icon up there and be able
to pull in the data set and then once
you've done that you just drag the
category and subcategory on row and
salaries on two columns it will result
in a horizontal bar
chart so in this one we're just going to
drag profit onto color and quantity onto
label sort the sales axes in descending
order of sum and sales within each
subcategory and if you're at home doing
this you'll see that chairs under
Furniture category had the highest sales
and profit while tables had the lowest
profit for office supplies subcategory
binders made the highest profit even
though storage had the highest sales
under technology category copers made
the highest profit though it was the
least amount of
sales let's work to create a dual axis
chart in Tabo to present sales and
profits across different years using
sample Superstore data set load the
orders sheet from the sample Superstore
data
set drag the order data field from the
dimensions onto columns and convert it
into continuous
month drag cells onto rows and profits
to the right corner of the view until
you see a light green rectangle one of
those things if you haven't done this
Hands-On you don't know what you're
doing you're you're going to run into a
buying so you're going to be just kind
of dropping it and wondering what
happened synchronize the right axes by
right clicking on the profit
axis and then let's finalize it by going
under the marks card change some cells
to bar in some profit to line and adjust
the size and then we have a nice display
that we can either print out or save and
send off to the uh
shareholders let's go and do one more
table uh design a view in table to show
statewise sales and profits using the
sample Superstore data set in here you
go ahead and drag the country field onto
the view section and expand it to see
the states drag the states fi onto size
and profit onto
color increase the size of the bubbles
add a border and a Halo color States
like Washington California and New York
have the highest sales and profits while
Texas Pennsylvania and Ohio have a good
amount of sales but the least amount of
profits we'll go ahead and Skip back to
python numpy Suppose there is an array
number equals NP or numpy if you're
using numpy depending on how you set it
up do array and we just have one to n
broken up into three groups extract the
value8 using 2D indexing so you can see
on the left we have our import nump as
NP number equals our NP array if we
print the number we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
nine since the value eight is present in
the second row and First Column we use
the same index position and pass it to
the array and you just have number 2
comma 1 and you get eight and remember
we're in Python so you start at zero not
one like you do in Excel always gets me
if I'm working between Excel and python
where I just kind of flip and usually
it's the Excel that messes up because I
do a lot more
programming suppose there's an array
that has value 01 all the way up to nine
how will you display the following
values from the array 1 3 5
79 uh so first of all we go and create
the array uh np. a ring of 10 which goes
from 0 to 9 because there's 10 numbers
in it but we don't include the 10 we
print it out the first thing you want to
do is what's going on here with 1 3 5 7
9 well if we divide by two there's going
to be a remainder equal to one and then
from python remember that if you use the
percentage sign you get the uh remainder
on there so the remainder is one and
then you have the your numpy array and
then we just want to do um a logical
statement of all values that have a
remainder of one and that generates our
nice
13579 there are two arrays A and B stack
the arrays A and B
horizontally boy these horizontal
vertical questions will get you every
time and in numpy we go ahead and we've
created uh two different arrays over
here A and B uh the first one is your
concatenate np.
concatenate A and B on axes equal
one that is the same as
hstack and in the back end they're still
identical they run the same that's all H
stack is a concatenate axis equals
one how can you add a column to a
panda's data frame suppose there's an
imp data frame that has information
about few employees let's add address
column to that data frame and you can
see in the left we have our basic data
frame uh you should know your data
frames very well uh basically looks like
an Excel spreadsheet as you come over
here it's really simple you just do um
DF of address equals the address once
you've assigned values to the
address using the below given data
create a pivot table to find the total
cells made by each cells represented for
each item display the cells as a
percentage of the grand total so we're
back in uh table select the entire table
r range click on insert Tab and choose
pivot
table select the table range and the
worksheet where you want to place the
pivot table it will return a pivot table
where you can analyze your
data uh drag the cell total on the
values in cells rep an item onto row
labels it'll give the sum of the cells
made by each representative for each
item they have
sold and finally right click on sum of
sell total and expand show values as to
select percentage of grand
total uh real important just to
understand what a pivot table is we're
just pivoting it from rows and columns
and switching this direction on there
and finally uh we have our final pivot
table and you can see the values ruls
and sum of total
sale so we're going to go ahead and take
a product table this is off of an SQL so
we're going to do some SQL here and
we're going to use the product and sales
order detail table find the products
that have total units sold greater than
1.5 million and here's our sales order
detail table so we have a product table
and a sales order detail table two
separate tables in the database and
we're going to do is put together the
SQL query we want to select PP name sum
sod unit price as Cs and then we have
our pp. product ID from production
product as PP interjoint
sales. salesorder detail as sod on PP
product ID equals s. product ID Group by
pp. name comma pp. product ID having a
sum of s. unit price greater than uh the
150 million there that's a mouthful and
again these SQL queries they start
looking really crazy until you just
break them apart and do them step by
step and what we're looking for is the
in join and how did you do the group ey
this really want they know how do you do
this injin this comes up so much in SQL
uh how do you pull in the ID from one
chart and the information from another
chart and the sum totals on that
chart how do you write a stored
procedure in SQL let's create a storage
procedure to find the sum the squares of
the first in natural numbers so here we
have our formula n * n + 1 * 2 n + 1
over 6 and you can see from the command
prompt uh or the setup you have
depending on what your login is the
command is create procedure Square sum
one declare our variable at n of integer
as begin then we're going to declare the
sum of integer set sum equals n * n + 1
+ 2 * n + 1 um over 6 and then of course
we can go ahead and print those out
print First cast um IGN n or our
variable as a variable character 20
natural numbers paren the sum of the
square is cast the at sum as variable
character 40 end then we do the output
display the sum of the square for first
four natural numbers we have execute
Square sum one and then we're going to
put in four and you can see here where
brings up the first four natural number
sum of square is
30 write a store procedure to find the
total even number between two two user
given
numbers couple things to note here first
we go and create our procedure you have
your two different variables the N1 N2
and we go ahead and begin we're going to
declare our variable count as an integer
we're going to set count equal to zero
and then we have while n is less than N2
we're going to begin and if N1 remainder
2 equals 0 so we're going to divide it
by two even number begin we're going to
set the count equal to count Plus one
we're going to print even number plus
cast in as a variable character 10 for
printing count is plus cast variable
count as variable character 10 and else
print odd number plus cast variable
number one as variable character 10 and
then we go ahead and set the um
increment our variable one up one so
they go from n one all the way to N2 and
it'll print the total number of even
numbers and you can see here we went
ahead executed it we're going to count
the even numbers between 30 and 45 and
you just see it goes all the way down to
8 what is the difference between tree
maps and heat maps in
Tabo now if you've worked in Python
other
programmingsoftware rectangles tree maps
are a relatively simple data
visualization that can provide Insight
in a visually attractive format and
again you can see the squares over here
this is our tree map over here with the
each block also has its information
inside of its different
blocks a heat map helps to visualize
measures against Dimensions with the
help of colors and size to compare one
or more dimensions and up to two
measures the layout is similar to a text
table with variations and values encoded
as colors in heat map you can quickly
see a wide array of information and in
this one uh you can see they use the
colors to denote one thing and the size
of the little square to denote something
else a lot of times you can even graph
this into a three-dimensional graph with
other data uh so it pops out but again a
heat map is the color and the
size using the sample superstor data set
display the top five and bottom five
customer customers based on their profit
so you start by dragging the customer
name field onto rows and profit on
columns rightclick on the customer name
column to create a set give a name to
the set and select top tab to choose top
five customers by some profit similarly
create a set for the bottom five
customers by some
profit select both the sets right click
to create a combined set give a name to
the set and choose all members in both
sets and then you can drag top and
bottom customer sets onto the filters
and profit fi onto color to get the
desired
results as we get down to the end of our
list we're going to try to keep you uh
on your toes we're going to skip back to
numpy how to print four random integers
between one and 15 using numpy to
Generate random numbers using numpy we
use the random random integer function
you can see here we did the import nump
as NP random Arrangement equals np.
random. random integer 1 through 15 of
four from the below data frame going
jump again on you now we're into pandas
how will you find the unique values for
each column and subset the data for age
less than 35 and height greater than six
to find the unique values and the number
of unique elements you use the unique
and the in unique
function you can see here we just did DF
height so we're selecting just the
height column and we want to look for
The Unique that returns an array where
in unique if we do that on the height or
the age we'll return just the number of
unique values and then we can do a
subset the data for ages less than 35
and height greater than six so if you
look over here we have a new DF uh
remember this is going to be taking
slices of our original data data frame
it doesn't actually change the data
frame so our new DF equals the data
frame or DF the data frame where age is
less than 35 and the height is greater
than
six and in case you're not using a tab
blue which has a lot of its own uh
different mapping programs in there make
sure you understand how to use the
basics of matap plot Library plot assign
graph using numpy and matplot library
and Python and the way we did this is we
went ahead and generate an X we know our
y equals np. sin of x if you print out X
you'll see a whole value here our matap
plot Library pip plot as PLT if you are
working in Jupiter notebook make sure
you understand the matplot library
inline that little percentage sign M
plot library in line that prints it on
the page in the Jupiter notebook the
newer version of Jupiter notebook or
Jupiter Labs automatically does that for
you but I usually put it in there just
in case I end up on an older version
if you print y you can see here we have
our different y values and our different
X
values you simply put in PLT do plot XY
and do a plot
show and before we go let's get one more
in we're going to do a pandas uh using
the below pandas data frame find the
company with the highest average cells
derive the summary statistics for the
cells column and transpose these
statistics that's a mouthful just like
any of these computer problems break it
apart uh so first of all we're looking
for the highest average cells so group
the company column and use the mean
function to find the average sales you
can see here buy company equals DF do
group by
company once we've done that using the
describe function we can now go ahead
and look at the summary of statistics on
here use the describe function to find
the summary uh so by company there's are
groups we're just going to describe them
and you could actually bundle those
together if you wanted and just do them
Allin one line uh so here we go by
company. describe you can see we have a
nice breakout always good to remember uh
whether you're using any of the packages
whether it's tableblue or uh pandas in
python or even r or some other package
being able to quick look and describe
your data is very important and then we
can go ahead and just do a basic apply a
transpose function over the describe
method to trans Pros the statistics all
we've done here is flip the index with
the column names but if you're following
the numbers a lot of times it's easier
to follow across one line or maybe you
want to average out the count or there
all kinds of different reasons to do
that and with that we have reached to
the end of this session on data analy
course for 2023 should you need any
assistance PPD or any other resources
used in this session please do let us
know in the comment section below and
our team of experts will be more than
happy to help you as soon as possible
until next time thank you and keep
learning stay tuned for more from Simply
learn staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here
I